Master technical interviews this course
breaks down complex topics like data
structures algorithms and interview
strategies into easily digestible
content par teaches this course he is an
experienced engineer and he will teach
you both the fundamentals and help you
understand Advanced coding patterns and
common pitfalls to avoid Hello friends
hope you are having a fantastic day
today I want to welcome you to a journey
that will transform the way you approach
technical interviews and my aim is to
help you become significantly better at
technical interviews I'm here to be your
guide as someone who has walked through
this path and knows the twist and turns
every step of the way together we will
unlock the secrets of technical
interviews from the basics of bigo
notation to the integrities of data
structure and algorithms so before we
move forward let me introduce myself my
name is par and I'm based in Canada I
have been in the tech industry for close
to 10 years and I have worked at
companies like Microsoft NOK Kia and
Royal Bank of Canada I'm a big believer
in technology and love Building
Solutions and softwares last year I
became dad of twin daughters and on the
side I also run my own YouTube channel
called destination Fang where I teach
about data structure and algorithm
related problems so now let's just get
started with this
course so first let's try to understand
that what is going to be the format at
any typical interview for any tech
company usually during the interview
process you can expect somewhere between
3 to six rounds of interviews and they
are usually broken down into three main
categories first category is the
behavioral interview and the purpose of
the behavioral interview is to check
what kind of person you are are you a
good culture fit do you work well with
different people do you work well under
pressure can you raise your concerns if
you have any conflict between two people
how can you handle that and these are
the things companies wants to know
before they hire you second type of
interviews are system design design
interviews and they are usually more
emphasized for more senior level folks
and if you are someone with like 10
years or 20 years of experience that
would be one of the most significant
chunk of importance for any job that you
are applying to but that doesn't mean
that uh they are not going to be there
for junior level folks there would still
be some emphasis but not as great and
usually those interviews tend to be
open-ended where they ask you questions
like if you have to build your own
Twitter or your own Google how would you
do that what are the things you would
consider and then the conversation Dives
deep into the vast sea of software
Solutions and the third category is
technical interviews which is going to
be our main point of focus for now from
now on T typically a technical interview
lasts for somewhere between 45 to 60
Minutes during this time interviewer
usually ask one to two questions and
once you have the solution in place they
would judge the solution if solution
seems to be good enough or fine they
will ask you to write a preliminary code
for that in any language of your choice
but the thing is it's not quite as
simple as it sounds there are lot of
moving Parts in any technical interview
usually a technical interview has a
problem statement and that problem
statement usually refers to some real
life scenario and that problem statement
needs to be solved using a computer
program that we we are trying to build
for that you would need two things for
sure number one is data structures and
data structure is nothing but a way to
store the data inside the memory of the
computer there are lot of different
methods available uh so you will need to
take care of data structure second thing
is algorithm and algorithm is nothing
but a set of instructions that a
computer needs to follow in order to
come up with a solution trust me there
are lot of data structures and lot of
algorithms and lot of different
techniques that you have to understand
but when you combine these two you get
somewhat a solution but how would you
know that whether your solution is a
good solution or a bad one for that we
actually need some way to measure that
how effective our solution is and in
order to do that in computer system we
use something called Big O So Big O is a
notion where we compute what is going to
be the worst case scenario time and
space complexity and depending on those
results we make the decision that
whether the solution or the option of
solutions we have which one is the best
and most optimal one and which one are
suboptimal options so before we start
going deeper into the realm of data
structure and algorithm let's first
understand that what are the measurement
units how do we actually understand that
this is a good
solution okay so let's talk about big O
big O is typically defined by a big O
and in the bracket we are going to Mark
the complexity of Any Given algorithm
now usually when when we talk about Big
O we are usually talking about two items
and those two items are time complexity
and space complexity and remember the
purpose of Big O is to identify the
efficiency of Any Given algorithm now uh
there are couple of ways to measure the
efficiency of Any Given algorithm but
the most important consideration that we
are always going to have is that we are
going to consider the worst case
scenario that in the worst case how
efficiently our algorithm is going to
perform on top of that we are also going
to check that for any given algorithm
let's say that currently we are dealing
with five number of inputs uh so in with
five number of inputs what is the
efficiency now let's say that the number
of inputs grow to 5 million in this case
what is going to be the efficiency and
that becomes the true measure of Any
Given algorithm and there is also one
more condition consideration while
calculating big hope is that we don't
care about Hardware or software
abilities for any given particular
solution so we are assuming that our
algorithm is currently running on the
best hardware or software available so
that's why we eliminate those outside of
our control entities and only we focus
on the efficiency part of our algorithm
so first uh and foremost time or space
complexity is Big O of one now currently
I'm only going to talk about time
complexity because that is sort of like
more important of course space
complexity is also important but time
complexity is usually where you will
have to improve whenever you are
building your solution now in terms of
that uh I'm going to currently show you
five different examples of different Big
O's uh for all I'm explaining it using
the time complexity but throughout this
course we are going to be solving bunch
of different technical interview
problems and where I'm also going to
explain you the what space and time
complexity we are using and how do we
calculate that so don't worry about
anything we are we are going to cover
all the topics uh for that is for sure
now first and foremost the Big O
notation is a constant time Big O
notation that is usually defined by like
like this where in the middle there is a
big one present this simply means that
the current operation does not depend on
the given input size and uh one clear
example if you want to put it in the
real world is that let's say that you
are currently shopping in some uh Plaza
some shopping cart or some somewhere
like that
and you can see in front of you that uh
you have the option to pick any item
from the five available items so since
you have the option to see these items
and you are being asked that hey uh in
the bracket number three there is a
banana that you need to pick you can
just directly walk in and pick that
banana up and in this case you don't
have to think anything you just B there
fetch that data and you completed your
operation so same way instead of five
items let's say if there are 500 items
and we are assuming that your eye vision
is the best you are able to see
everything so in that case uh even if
the value is located at 499 place and I
tell you that go and grab that you can
still be able to go and grab that within
the constant time so timing would not be
impacted based on the growth of number
of input size so in this kind of
scenario we can consider that operation
to have a constant time now next
operation is bigo of end time now what
does bigo of end time means is that the
number of inputs as the number of input
size grows the more time it takes for us
to complete that task and the
progression is essentially linear so
let's say that uh this is the graph
where we can see that the number of
input size and the time it takes to
complete the line is going to be a
straight line that they are in
proportion to each other and if we have
to consider an example for uh this kind
of scenario let's assume that currently
uh you have 10 items that that are
already placed in 10 different pots and
now these pots they are covered with
different lids and you have no way for
know that what is currently present in
each of the pot so if I ask you that uh
from these 10 pots I want you to find a
banana so in this case what would be
your approach well you will definitely
go to the first place and in the first
place you will try to check that uh if
the banana is present uh currently
banana is not present here so you will
check the next spot you will check the
the next part again you will check the
next Sport and eventually you would find
a place where has a banana and you would
return that in that scenario let's say
that instead of 10 values if I put like
1 million pots then essentially you will
have to open 1 million pots in order to
find the banana so there is a direct
correlation between the given input and
the size so that's why this would be a
good example for bigo of n time
complexity where our solution is direct
ly in correlation with the given number
of input size next one is actually big
of log n and this is a logarithmic time
operation this is quite un interesting
to understand what it happens in this
type of operation is that with every
step you make you essentially eliminate
50% of given input and same thing
happens when you make the next step and
same thing happens when you make the ne
Next Step so say initially uh uh this is
your entire input size when you make the
first change the change is going to
enable you to essentially get rid of
this entire part so now you are only
dealing with these number of input sizes
with the next step you took again you
eliminated half of them so you get rid
of this part and then now you're only
dealing with this much portion of the
given input and same way if you keep on
going and going and going eventually you
would be able to find the solution you
are looking for if we have to consider a
practical example for this type of
logarithmic time I told you that hey
this is the phone book now in this phone
book I want you to find the number of
Patrick the plumber now for this in
order to find the number of Patrick the
plumber what will you do is you will
open the book somewhere from the middle
and let's say that you open uh at where
character or alphabet m in the middle
portion so essentially you can eliminate
that from a to M this Patrick the
plumber is not going to be present so
you will essentially get rid of all of
these pages so let's say that uh it's a
500 page phone book you essentially
eliminated 250 pages in just one go and
in the next iteration you only have to
check for n to Z and again you try to
open some middle page and then you would
be end up with this a smaller subset
size so with every increment of step you
take you get almost 50% closer to your
uh given answer and you are eliminating
50% of input sizes in that so that is
defined as bigo of log n or logarithmic
n time complexity well usually the
constant time complexity is the fastest
and second fastest is the logarithmic
time complexity now the next sequence is
going to be the combination of two items
and that is going to be bigo of n log n
so bigo of n log n is an operation where
essentially let's say that this is the
current input you are given initially
first of all you are you will have to
itate over all of these places in the
input but once you do that then for the
next set of instructions you only need
to do it in the logarithmic time so for
the next operation you are essentially
again eliminating half of the given
inputs with every single change you are
trying to make and this is quite an
interesting approach one of the good
examples for this one could be that
let's say that you are playing a card
game with your friends now initially in
your card game in your hand you receive
five random cards but you are are a
person who wants who likes to do things
in more of like a sorted array or sorted
way so your approach is that hey uh
since the these are random values let me
put them in a correct sequence so for
that what would be your approach your
approach would be that first you are
going to put down the value number two
and you will treat that two is the
minimum number and this is the new sort
of sequence that you are trying to make
now in this case currently since this is
empty you can put two anywhere so you
will put two in the first place now you
need to put value number 7 now again you
know that 7 is greater than two so you
put 7 on the right side of two now you
need to put value number three you
already know that all the values that
are currently present in this array they
are already going to be sorted because
one by one you are sorting them now in
order to put this value number three you
will have to find the location where it
should be the ideal location and ideal
location would be between two and 7 the
three should fall between two and 7 so
what would you do you would first try to
find the middle Point Middle Point is
currently let's say uh 2 and 7 so you
pick seven so which means you know that
three needs to be on the left side of
seven so again there is only one element
so you know that three needs to be in
the middle so once again you adjust the
values and you are going to put three
over here and then seven over here again
you have value number one so once again
you will have to make adjustments or you
will have to identify that one needs to
go in the beginning and again you are
going to use the binary search approach
the same approach we were using in the
previous uh
application or previous phone book
example that we saw so let me just
redraw all of this and this would be the
sequence and now you have value number
five you need to put so once again you
will try to find the middle value and
you find that the correct location for
five is going to be this place and you
will again going to put it over here so
now after this after completing this
example if you see the solution you
currently have is actually now sorted so
let's calculate the the complex for this
well you had to go through each and
every input in order to receive or
complete the steps so definitely you did
n work but even for every single element
once you did or process that you also
had to do some work in order to put it
in the sorted place so for that you are
not doing the N work you are actually
doing the log n work so in this case the
Big O is actually going to be Big O of n
log n so these are typically the four
four most popular Big O's um in terms of
like any architect any technical
interviews that you have to consider but
apart from that we also have to worry
about bigo of N squ and bigo of n cub
and bigo of uh 2 to the power n and then
there is the worst one and that is bigo
of n factorial so let me just quickly
explain these four of four of you for
this so suppose in this case uh big of n
Square you already you can already guess
that for every every single element we
will have to work with all the other
elements so let's say that currently I
have this value number X now I want to
check that in the remaining portion does
X is present or not so one by one I will
have to check all of these values and
since it is not present so then I can
say that okay for in order to process
one element I had to process all the
other elements so essentially I did B of
n Square work so or B of n cross n work
and same would apply for all the
subsequent examples as well and uh that
is how we reach big of n Square time
complexity this is also uh referred to
as quadratic time complexity then for
big of n Cube again you are adding one
more n over here so let's say that you
this step needs to be done as part of
one of your algorithm and then once you
get the process of this you again have
to do n work or compare with all of
these values and once again repeat the
same exercise in this case case uh the
time complexity is going to be big of n
Cub now this one big of 2 to the^ N is a
Time complexity where at every single
location you have the option to process
two values and among these two options
depending on which option you took your
complete computation path would change
so in these kinds of scenario the
typical uh calculation is going to be
big of 2 to the power n uh and the last
one is the factorial time complexity so
factorial time complexity is where the
input sizes grow exponentially with the
increase in the number of input size and
this is actually a huge restriction
because these two time complexities are
so bad that they can't even function and
one of the very good example for this
big of 2 to the power nend time
complexity is actually traveling
salesman problem um if you want go ahead
and search about that it's a quite an
interesting problem to study that gives
you quite lot of idea on how
computational how there are limitations
to computations as well uh for the N
factorial one of the very good example
is to find permutations and combination
for all the given input sizes that we
are trying to deal with so this is what
you need to understand regarding the
time and space complexity and uh now
let's try to start understanding that
what are the data
structures now we are going to talk
about data structures the most important
topic that you have to understand for
any technical interview or computer
science in general now when we talk
about data structures data structure is
nothing but a way for us to store the
data inside the computer's memory so
let's assume that these are all the
memory blocks of Any Given computer so
we have the option to store the data in
like an entirely common box like this or
we have the option to save the data
where one node is present over here the
connecting node is present somewhere
over here its next connecting node is
present some somewhere over here and so
on and so forth we also have the option
where we know the option of that this is
one node and then this node can only be
accessed through these two nodes or
something like that and then there are
also quite connected nodes as well plus
there are some structures data
structures like q and stack so data
structures in itself is a huge and
complex topic now let's try to break
this down into categories so it helps us
understand what type of data structures
are and how they operate so if we have
to create the categorization data
structures are typically two types of
data structures mainly first one is a
primitive data structure and second one
is a non-primitive data structure now
these primitive data structures are the
smallest unit of data that we can store
inside the computer and this is your
integer value or your character value or
Boolean value typically all the values
that we usually use in any compiler
language so to store store the raw bits
of data in the computer and lucky for us
or that this is too preliminary that it
is not considered for any technical
interview but you must have encountered
this if you are a programming person so
now the next category is the
nonprimitive types of data structure and
that two has further
subcategorization so in the
non-primitive type of data structure the
first of characterization is the linear
data structure and second one is the
nonlinear data structure now for the
linear as the name suggest linear data
structure defines as the data that are
typically stored in a sequence or in a
linear fashion so this includes
array then uh link list
stack and Q so these are the major
categorization of the linear data
structure now when we talk about
nonlinear data structure this is
essentially the data structure that that
is in a weird shape uh where the
connection or the hierarchy between any
two nodes is quite deep and quite
significant and this has some of the
most interesting properties actually so
that is uh trees and graphs now for the
apart from trees and graphs uh there are
many subtypes in each one of them and
when we get to those topics we will
discuss it in the in more detail but for
now understand that these are the to
generic subcategories now the there is
also third unofficial category which is
really important for us to learn and
that is Hash based data structure so
hash based data structure typically
includes uh hash map and hash set and
these will these are very powerful tools
at our disposal that we can actually
achieve quite an interesting uh output
with these data structure so without any
further Ado let's just get started with
the linear data structure
now arrays are a not only they are a
linear data structure but arrays tend to
be fixed in the size and there are some
properties associated with arrays so
first let's understand that typically uh
let's assume that if this is the whole
memory of the computer then if whenever
we Define an array we have to give it a
sum size uh and the size of an array
usually tends to stay within a fixed
Contin ous memory space inside any given
computer as well so let's say that we
create an array with the size five then
there would be a memory space like this
with five consecutive memory spaces are
going to be located next to each other
and this is how it would be represented
in the memory now since we already know
that there are going to be five
continuous bits of memory uh one good
thing about array is that if you want to
access any element even from anywhere in
the middle you can access it quite
quickly and very fast so uh let me give
you an example for that suppose uh this
uh this is currently the whole chunk of
memory for the given array now how would
the fast access work is that we already
know that what would be the initial
location of this position in the array
inside our memory I'm giving you like a
detailed explanation to help you
understand how does arrays work so let's
say that the computer memory address
like this portion is referred to as 100
and for the Simplicity we are expecting
that all of these nodes they are 100 in
the size which means that this if this
memory location is 100 then this
location is at 200 then this location is
at 300 and so on and so forth so let's
say that uh I currently wanted to access
the fourth element that is this element
present inside the given array so do I
have to do any additional research or
any additional extra effort no why why
because I can quickly come over here I
can see that okay this starts at Value
number 100 I want to access the fourth
element which means fourth element has
to be present at Lo value memory value
number 400 and that we can access quite
quickly so just because we learn about
the bigo time complexity the retrival
bigo time complexity for array is
actually going to be bigo of one or
constant and how typically we access the
elements inside the array uh we use
something called indexing so arrays
let's say that this is an array of size
five because we can store five elements
in this usually it is going to be
indexed starting with value number 0o so
0 1 2 3 and 4 this is going to this is
how array is going to be represented and
you can store any item in the array you
can store either character or you can
store integer you can store Boolean you
can store even some some of your
separate classes you created all the
things you can store inside the array
but uh in order order to access that you
will have to use these index values so
let's say that I put down the values as
uh 5 15 3 1 and two now if I want to
access that what is located on index
number two or position number three why
position number three because this is
the first element this is second and
this is third element and we have an
index starting from zero so why am I
pointing you out this because this tends
to be a tricky thing and many times you
would encounter in technical interviews
that they would say that hey I have an
array that starts with index one so that
this is like a common trap that you
sometimes can find yourself into so
that's why make sure that what type of
index you are using 99% of cases you are
going to be using an array starting with
index number
zero now let's just go back uh again so
in this case uh let's say that the name
of this array is a so if I want to
access this third element all I need to
do is try to fetch the value that is
located and on the second index position
and this would give us the answer as
value number three so retrival inside
the array is quite quickly now let's see
that what are the different operations
we we have the ability to perform inside
an array let's say that currently we
have a blank array present and what are
the things we can do so let's mark down
the index values now first operation we
can do is we have the ability to insert
element inside inside any given array
now inserting an element is actually
quite quick uh because if you know know
which index location you are inserting
element into you can actually do it in
within constant time so B go of one time
you can insert element you can insert
element to the end of the array you can
insert element to the beginning of the
array all you need to know is the index
value and that's it now second thing we
can do is we can retrive the G the
inserted array as well and retrival is
also quite quick we we just saw so that
is also a constant time next operation
we can do is we can find element inside
the given array so let's say that how
does finding inside the given array
would actually work and uh this is a
question for you guys that while I
explain try to think that what should be
the time complexity for this one uh
ready so let's say that currently the
values are 5 15 3 and 1 and I ask you
that inside this given array I want to
find that uh value number three where it
is located so how would you do it
approach is going to be quite simple the
logical explanation is going to be that
you go to the first element if it is
three that's it if it is not three go to
the next element again not three go to
the next element okay this is three then
retri the index position and that's how
you find it now in this case what was
the time complexity well the answer is
quite obvious because we had to jump
through all the values in order to find
the value we are looking for it was big
of n so logically why it was big of n
because this is unsorted array so in the
unsorted array always if you have to
find any element it's going going to
take big off end time but let me show
you a quick uh interesting thing over
here let's assume that I currently have
a sorted array so 1 2 3 4 5 these are
the elements I have and now I want to
find that whether four is present or not
so in this case what what is going to be
the approach since I already know that
this is a sorted array I'm going to
first check for the middle element and
again I can check what element is there
pretty quickly because retrival is Big
go of one so that is an important
property so in this case I can see that
this value is three the moment I realize
that this value is three I can say for
certainty that four is not going to be
anywhere left of three because all the
valents all the elements are going to be
less than three and we have we are
trying to find for the value number four
that is actually greater than three so
we can eliminate these two or these
three elements with a single check again
we will try to check for the middle
element and we find Value number four
and we can retrive that so if the array
is unsorted the finding is going to take
big off end time but if the array is
sorted then in that case the finding is
going to take because of log log and
time and why because the method we just
use is actually called binary search
where we are dividing the all the
elements in one half or the other half
and then we are essentially making
judgment on which direction to choose
and find the answer in the most optimal
manner so finding uh takes B of end time
next question is deletion so deletion is
also if you know what place you wants to
delete it only takes big off one time
because all you need to do is just go to
that index and get rid of that value so
deletion is also very quick inside the
array now we all find quite interesting
items about array let's see that what
are some of the drawbacks of an array
well the number one drawback of an array
is that it is actually a continuous
memory size
and it is also a fixed memory size so
what do I mean by fixed memory size
because initially when we are defining
an array we actually have to Define that
what is going to be the size of an array
and let's say if we exceed the size of
that array then the operation becomes
quite expensive uh let me give you an
example so in this case suppose the
array is 1 2 3 4 5 these are the five
values now we realize that in the same
array we need to add more elements so
what behind the scenes procedure is
going to be that
there will be a new array created of
size 10 and now in this new size 10
array first it is going to shift all of
these elements one by one and after that
once the shifting is done then the next
element that you wanted to add over here
value number six would be added over
here so previously when we have to
insert any element inside the given
array that was a bigo of one operation
the moment we exceeded the size the
operation became bigo of n operation uh
because we had to repeat this whole
process and that too when we did that
what was also another fault with that is
that currently all of this space is
actually unused so we we are already
running on a very important resource
that is our computer's memory and we are
leaving some values unused because they
have not been filled yet so this is one
of the biggest issue with the arrays now
second issue with the array is that uh
actually if you want to find any element
then it takes bigo of end time because
that you have no way for to understand
that where any particular element is
present so this is also another issue
with an array but apart from that if we
have to talk about benefits of an array
well uh there are quite a few benefits
actually if you believe it or not number
one it's the simplest algorithm to
understand or simplest data structure
number two it is actually quite uh
useful and and quite fast uh quite fast
means that whenever you have to retrive
any element from any particular index
you can actually do it quite quite
quickly uh allocation memory allocation
is not an issue this works really well
with other data structures when you are
trying to solve some complex problems so
when we get to the points of dynamic
programming and Matrix manipulation we
are going to learn quite a lot about
arrays and we are going to use lot of
arrays in many different scenarios now
let's try to understand that how does a
typical array problem work with an
example and the example we are doing is
actually the number one problem on the
lead code and one of the most popular uh
interview question that is two some
problem so what problem statement
suggest is that suppose we are given an
unsorted array and uh in this case we
have five elements so let's give some
arbitrary values of these elements and
in this case uh we are trying to
identify that uh the we are also given a
sum value so let's say that sum property
is currently given as value number 17
now we are trying to find that find a
pair that actually has the answer as
value number 17 and then return its
index position so we are know that the
answer is actually going to be in this
case 2 and three because these are the
10 + 7 but let's see that what is going
to be the approach that we need to take
so this will give us a very good Insight
on how does algorithms also work and how
does time and space complexity works so
let's see the first approach first
approach is going to be our Brute Force
approach or the most preliminary basic
approach the idea we are going to use is
that we will take any element we will
minus it with 17 so whatever the
remaining element is left we will try to
see that in the remaining array does
that remaining element is present or not
uh so if we are considering five so
let's assume that five is currently part
of this two some so which means if five
is part of this 17 that makes 17 then
there has to be a remaining value 12
present inside the remaining array and
we all know if we have to find any value
inside the array we can do it in B go of
end time because this is an unsorted
array so we are going to jump through
all of these values to find Value number
12 but currently 12 is not present so
because 12 is not present we can
consider five not to be part of the
answer then we will go back to Value
number three once again 17 - 3 value is
going to be 14 so we will try to see
that whether 14 is present again 14 is
also not present so we will get rate of
three again for seven So currently we
are considering value number seven which
means for the sum we need to have value
number 10 present somewhere and yes 10
is present over here so in this case we
did find the answer as 2 and three
because we need to return the index
value and we can return it quite quickly
but if I have to ask you that what is
going to be the time time complexity or
the Big O for this given input what
would be the answer it's quite obvious
for any single element we have to search
all the remaining elements and if we do
or consider that in the worst case
scenario essentially the time complexity
is going to be biger of n Square so that
let's see that can there be a better
approach using the array to solve this
problem and the answer is actually yes
there is a much better approach and
first let me give you a slightly better
approach right so a better approach in
this case would be that what if for the
given input array we decide to sort that
and if we sort this given input array we
will find the values to be 1 3 5 7 and
10 now once we have these values stored
all we need to do is uh we need to check
that uh whether for Value number one if
the subsequent pair the value number 10
n is present or not and in this case
since originally we need to find the
index value when we create the Sorting
we have to create actually a new array
so this is an important piece of
information so just Im Just a thing so
now if we have value number one which
means we are trying to find the sum to
be 17 so then uh 17 minus 1 is going to
be 16 so 16 needs to be present so since
this is a sorted array we can actually
find in log n time
that whether 16 is present or not and
all we need to do is we need to apply
the binary search where we first check
the middle value So currently this value
number five so we make sure that 16 has
to be somewhere on the right side but
since it is not present over here we are
not going to bother checking same thing
we are going to check with for the value
number three that again for Value number
three if that is has to be part of the
answer we can actually try to find the
answer in log and time so to check
whether value number 14 is present or
not again that is also not present for
five value number 12 is also not present
but when we get to Value number seven
actually the value number 10 is present
and we can find this in log n time so
what do what did we did we found out
that the correct values we need are 7
and 10 so once we have the solution we
again need to go back to our original
array because we need to return the
index values so now once again we would
search all of these values one more time
to see where what are the index location
and then return the values now let's try
to calculate the time and space
complexity in this case so for the time
complexity what are the operations we
did number one operation is that for the
given input array we actually sorted
this so once we sorted this given input
array uh it took us bigo of n log n time
to sort because based on the example I
showed you earlier plus after sorting it
we had to iterate over all of these
elements to find that what is is the
subsequent or remaining element that is
present or not and this so iterating
over all of these elements took us B go
of end time and uh in order to find that
for each one of them the subsequent
element is present or not again it took
us beo of log n time so again we did B
of n log n so in total we did two times
B go of 2 * n log n but the interesting
thing about Big O is that all the
constant values are not considered so we
are not going to consider big two in
this case and we will only consider this
to be big off and login on top of it
once we find the correct pair we again
had to go back to our original array to
find the uh appropriate index values so
for that we also did Big O of n work but
when we are generalizing the Big O we
only care so whenever there is a plus
operation or the additional task
essentially our main main component is
still heavily going to be dependent on
big of n login because that is greater
than big of n so we can also ignore this
one and the time complexity is going to
be big go of n log n in order to
generate this now in this case space
complexity is also an issue why because
we had to create an additional new array
for the sorted property and because the
new arrays size would be dependent on
the original size and the original size
we are considering the value to be n
because of that in this case the space
complexity is also going to be bigger of
n so I wanted to show you this approach
to show you that how to calculate time
and space complexity and what are the
considerations we need to make so I hope
you find that uh very useful and you
find the idea now of course this
solution is much better than our
previous Pro Force solution which gave
us the result of big of n square but
still this is not the most optimal
approach there are still optimal
approaches available and the optimal
approach uh let's see that how we are
going to deal with it well actually I
should not be showing it to you but I'll
just show it to you for the optimal
approach we are actually going to use
another data structure called hashmap
and when we get to that point we will
I'll explain you in much higher detail
that what an hashmap is but for now
consider that hashmap is a key value
pair uh data structure that looks like
like this where you have a key and you
have a value and if you know the key you
can find the value associated in
constant time we go off one time so it's
very quick now let's just draw back our
uh original array so I think the values
were 5 1 7 10 and 3 and we are trying to
find the sum for Value number 17 now
again the approach is going to be that
if let's assume that five needs to be
the part of the answer so if five has to
be part of the answer sir we need to
make sure that value number 12 is
present somewhere in the remaining array
now currently we don't want to check the
whole remaining array because if 12 is
present eventually we would also
encounter 12 somewhere down the road as
well by the time we would have already
processed value number five so what we
are going to do is we are first check
that whether 12 is present inside the
hashmap or not currently it's not
present in the hashmap if it is not
present in the hashmap we are going to
add an entry of key value pair over here
where we we will add value number five
as the key so this value and its
subsequent index value as its value
because we need to return this in the
answer now again going back currently
value number one if one has to be part
of the answer then value number 16 has
to be present but currently in the
hashmap we don't have value number 16 so
again we are going to add one more entry
that is value number one and oh sorry
for this five the initial entry is going
to be zero because its index location is
zero so for this one the index location
is one 1 once again for this 7 we need
to find the value number 10 but 10 is
not currently present inside the hashmap
and we are able to check all of these in
big off one time so that's a great
benefit now we are not able to check
this one so what we will do is we will
actually add entry number seven over
here with the index value of two now
let's add one more room and now we are
at Value number 10 so if 10 has to be
part of the answer then 7 needs to be
present somewhere in the array and 7 is
already present in the Dash map because
we have already processed that value the
moment we realize that all we need to do
is grab the index element of 10 that is
value number three and grab the index
element of value number seven that we
can find it from the hashmap over here
and we can return return uh 3 and two as
the answer that this is the index pair
that makes us the two sum possible
inside the given array and now let's
break down the time and space complexity
for this solution so of course time comp
complexity actually is very fast in this
case because we only have to iterate
over the given input array just once and
we would be able to find the array so
the time complexity is actually going to
be dependent on big of n the given
number of input sizes which is much
better compared to both our Brute Force
approach and our sorting approach now in
terms of space
complexity uh we actually have to create
an additional hash map and the size of
the hash map is actually going to be the
size of the array maximum in the worst
case scenario so again the space
complexity is also going to be bigger of
N and this is how you actually solve
this problem so now let's quickly try to
understand the problem statement for two
some problem that is I just explained it
to you and the coding solution so we
have a Java code over here and first of
all we have the two some method where we
need to return the index values for both
the positions and in the input we are
given the num nums array and the target
value or our two sum now first of all we
are initializing our hash map where we
are going to store the values of the
subsequent values we processed inside
the given array and also their indices
then we are simply going to run a for
Loop to iterate over our given array
first of all we will try to see that
what is the complement value that we
need to check and then we will we can do
that by subtracting the current array
position minus the target value once
that happens we check that if the
hashmap already contains that complement
value or not if it it contains the
compliment value we can return the index
positions quickly if it does not contain
then we are going to add that value in
our hashmap and in the end I'm just
adding uh an illegal argument exception
that there is no toome solution but this
is never going to be the case because we
are explicitly told that there is always
going to be exactly one solution so
let's try to run this code and this code
runs pretty quickly let's submit this
code and our code runs quite efficiently
compared to a lot of other Solutions
now let's learn about the next data
structure that is link list Now link
list is quite an interesting data
structure because it's not what array
was at all uh in the array we actually
had all the memories being stored in a
continuous block and the size used to be
fixed link list is actually complete
opposite of this let's say that this is
currently the memory then we would have
a link list that would look look
somewhere something like this it would
be sprad out all across computer and the
nodes would be connected with each other
where one node would know the address of
the other node and that is how we
actually Traverse over any given link
list so typically link list is a dynamic
structure well of course it is a linear
data structure but it is also dynamic in
nature and uh typically a link list
looks like this where we only have the
information of the first element that is
present inside the link list nothing
more than that that but if we have to go
and reach to any particular element we
can actually do it by going sequentially
to from that original first element to
the last element and we would be able to
find that value somewhere in between so
typically a link list would look
something like this where you have these
memory blocks or these nodes and the
first node is referred as the root of
the link list and in every single node
there is going to be a partition and
what this partition defines is that this
would have the memory location of the
next element inside the link list so
let's assume that currently we have this
value number five and this is located at
memory location 100 now this particular
block is going to have the memory
location of this block so let's say that
this block is currently located
somewhere randomly at Value number 600
so that 600 would be stored over here
once again let's give some arbitrary
value over here so let's say that value
number three is the value for this node
next element it has is it could be
anything it could be 300 and now at 300
memory location we have another node
that is present with value number seven
um and same way it has the address for
this next element so basically the
structure of a link list looks something
like this where we have the first
element that points to the next that
points to the next and that points to
the next and the last element actually
points to the null value and when we see
an element pointing to the null value
that defines that whether the given link
list uh where it ended basically now for
the link list it's actually uh there are
three different types of Link list now
what I just showed you this is called a
singly link list and why singly link
list because one element knows that what
is going to be the element after that
but any particular element has no idea
that what is the element before me
because it does not have that address so
that is why this is referred as a singly
link list where you have the idea of
what the single next node is going to be
in the iteration but there is also a dou
link list and W link list as the name
suggest it has the idea that who is the
previous caller and who is going to be
the next caller so the structure is
usually like this where you have
additional memory slots uh where we
store the information so something that
looks like this and uh once again so
let's assume that this is currently the
root node so even for the root node now
in this case since root node is not
being pointed by any other node this
address is going to be null value and
then we will have some value being
associated with this so let's say 10 so
10 11 3 1 these are the values
associated with the link list but now
this 10 this portion is actually going
to to contain the address of this
element so it has the address 300 let's
assume and we can also assume that this
address is 50 so this value number 50
would actually be stored over here that
this second node would know that who is
the first node that is calling them so
when this node needs to go back or
Traverse in the reverse order it can
also do that so when traversing in the
reverse order uh it will look something
like this that this would actually point
to this address and uh same way this has
the address over here this has this
address and this has this address and
this is this address and in the end we
have this last element that actually
points to a null value and when we see
last element pointing to the null value
which means that the link list has ended
or W link list has ended and when we see
first element pointing to the null value
which means that the W link list
actually started there is one more link
list that is called a circular link list
and in the circular link list as the
name suggest essentially there is a
cycle that keeps on happening and uh how
it operates is that usually if we
consider it's an additional extended
version of The W link list so let's say
that currently we have a w link list
where uh in the normal case scenario
this W link list would be pointing to
the null value in the first place but
let's assume that that is not the case
and currently let's just give some
arbitary values 1 2 4 7 these are the
values right now we know that that one
is pointing towards two and two is
pointing towards one same way this is
relation is already stable now
previously in the normal link list the
last element its next node would be a
null value but in this case the next
node is actually going to point back to
the very first value and same way this
very first node is actually going to
point back to the last element so that
is why there is a circle circular nature
happening inside the link list now
understanding this let's see that what
are the different operations we can
perform on any given link list and for
reference I'm just drawing a simple
singly link list but same would be true
for all the W link list and circular
link list as well and uh let's define
some arbitary values and currently this
one is pointing towards null and uh
currently this is going to be the root
of our link list so we have the option
to add values to the link list now if we
have to add values to the link list the
time complexity depends on where you are
trying to add so let's say that if you
are trying to add the link list to the
root element and sometimes this is also
referred as the head of the link list as
well so let's say that you are trying to
add elements to the root or the head
element of the link list it's actually
quite simple all you need to do is that
you will first try to go to the root
element you would see that what is the
current memory address for this root
element and then you would actually
create another node and let's mark the
value as nine you would point point this
nine back to this root Two element and
that's it now you have essentially
created a new head element or the new
first element where this is this becomes
the root and this is being pointed by
this value number nine or root so in
this case uh you only have access to the
next element so you give the next
element of the previous head to the new
head and this can be done in big of one
time constant time operation same goes
that if if you want to add an element
somewhere in the middle well this the
whole procedure is actually quite simple
let me first show you the procedure and
then we will talk about the time
complexity well the procedure would be
that let's say that I want to add a node
number seven over here so what I would
do is that currently this four is
pointing to the one rather than doing
that I'm going to Mark 4 do next or the
next element that four is pointing to to
7 and then 7 do next to the previous
element that four was pointing to so the
value number one so we would have a
temporary variable in between but
essentially you get the idea what I'm
trying to say and now this process only
took big off one time but now the tricky
part in this case is that in order to
reach to the four we actually have to
first go to Value number nine and then
through nine we would do sequential
jumps until we reach to Value number
four and then we would be able to make
this changes so if we have to make the
change somewhere in the middle uh the
time complexity is actually big of N and
same goes for the end as well because if
you have to add it into the end you will
also have to update and go to the end
and then that would also yield the time
complexity of big of n but now there is
there are some slight variation
difference where if you have a w link
list and you wanted to add to the last
element maybe you can do it faster if
you already have that information stored
or you can go in the reverse order or in
the circular link list you can do it
quickly in the end but that these are
rare anomalies that you are rarely going
to encounter now let's see that if you
have to delete an element how does it
would work once again deletion process
is quite simple that all you need to do
is that let's say I want to delete this
value number seven so what I would do is
currently the next node that seven is
pointing to I would ask four to point to
that node and that's it seven has been
deleted because now there is no way for
us to reach to seven and so this the
process in itself is quite easy but
again the same question remains that in
order to get to the value number four we
will have to do all of these Hops and
get there so if we have to do some
deletion in the start it takes big off
one time but in the middle it takes big
off end time now let's see that what is
the next operation we can do and that is
finding an element inside the link list
once again you get the idea you can find
the element but once again in order to
find the element you will have to
Traverse through all of those these
Hoopes in order ultimately till you
reach that element so that two is going
to be big go of end time and once again
uh the last one is that you can also
modify any existing element but in order
to do that that also takes big off end
time so essentially all the operations
in the link list if they are done
somewhere in the middle or the end of
the link list it takes big off end time
so now the question comes that why do we
even care about link list why should we
use it well one of the most important
benefit is that it it's dynamic in
nature so it keeps on growing and
growing you don't have to worry about
memory allocation size allocation
because it can find sizes anywhere so
anywhere there is an empty block of
memory present link list can acquire
that put it in the memory and do it on
top of it swapping any two elements so
if this pointing over here we can
actually start pointing or add couple of
new link list and then bring them back
and then get rid of this uh list this is
actually quite simple and quite easy so
in many of the branching strategies this
is actually quite helpful that uh you
can actually create all sorts of like
get a branch and repos and stuff like
that using link list on top of it uh
many times we are going to use just like
arrays link list in tandem with other
data structures so we will see that when
we get to that point now let's talk
about uh some of the examples of how
typically we solve any problem inside a
link list so one of the popular very
popular problem is that we need to find
the middle of the link list or middle
element of the link list so how do we
actually do that so let's assume that we
are currently given a singly link list
and we don't know that what is the size
of this link list so how do we encounter
that what would be the middle point for
this one so one approach is that uh it's
the simplest approach we actually start
at the root value or at the head of the
link list we keep on going to the next
element until we reach to a point where
the next element points to a null and
the moment we reach that we would know
the size of the link list so in this
case we found out that the size of Link
list is five so middle element is going
to be the third element then once again
we start once again from the root and
let me use another color and then you we
hop back and we reach to the middle
element and then we say that okay this
is the middle pointer of the link list
so this this can be one of the examples
so what is going to be the time
complexity well time complexity is going
to be big of n because we have to go
through essenti all the inputs but there
is also another better approach where
once again time complexity is going to
be biger of n but in practice it is
going to be faster and that is that
rather than making one hop you actually
make two hops and how to do that well
you can actually have two pointers so
one pointer is a fast pointer and the
second one is a slow pointer both start
at the same time but slow pointer makes
one jump and fast pointer makes two
jumps so the moment Fast Point pointer
reaches to the end of the link list the
middle pointer or the slow pointer has
to be in the middle and that you can
return as the answer so in this case the
time complexity would be big of n
divided by 2 so overall since 2 is the
constant value we would still write it
as big of n but in practice this is
going to be much faster compared to the
other approaches so now let's try to
understand the middle of the linkless
problem and as the problem statement
states that we are given the head of a
singly link list and we need to return
the middle node of the link list now
this is the Java code for that and
typically for the link list we are
initializing two pointers for that first
one is known as slow and second one is
known as fast and currently both are
located at the very first be uh
beginning position of the link list now
we run a v Loop that while fast is not
equal to null and fast. next is not
equal to null we are going to keep on
moving the slow pointer to one jump so
slow will go to the slow. next or the
next element inside the link list and
fast would go to fast do next do next so
it would make two jumps at a time and in
the end the moment this Loop ends we
would be at a position where fast is at
the last position or the next element to
the fast is actually the null value in
either case so slow has to be the middle
pointer of the link list and we can
actually return that so let's try to run
this code and our solution works
perfectly fine so let's submit this and
our code runs with 100% efficiency so
this is pretty good and uh all the code
that I'm showing you would be posted in
a gith up public repo so the link is
going to be in the description so you
would be able to check it out from
there now let's see another data
structure that is a
stack now stack is once again very
similar to an array or link list it's a
linear data structure but uh the stack
has a very specific property and that
specific property is actually that stack
is something like this uh you can
consider it as like a test tube um in
any lab or any sort of thing or a stack
of plates this would be like a good
example to understand what stack is
where the value where you first store
sto gets stored at the very bottom once
that value is filled then the next value
when you have to put in that would
become at like the bottom to the uh
second place and it will keep on going
now when you have to take things out you
will always take things out that are
currently at the very top because you
cannot reach to the bottom element
because they are already Behind These
memory lines so in order to reach to the
bottom elements you will actually have
to go through one by one for all the
values so let's see this an example
let's say that currently our stack is
empty we are trying to fill in some
values so let's say that we put down
value number one first so one has to go
at the very bottom now the we have we
are putting value number two then three
then four then five and then six So
currently we have six elements inside
our stack now when we start taking the
values out actually the only value we
can take out at this moment is value
number six because that is the only
value we have access to because this is
like a test tube or a a stack of plates
kind of a structure so that is why when
we decide to take things out we are
going to take value number six out first
after taking value number six out then
we we can start taking value number five
out after five we will get to the value
number four and so on and so forth so
essentially the last element that was
encountered or entered inside the stack
would be the first element that is going
to come out so this is this works on the
Leo principle last in first out okay so
and that's it this is what the whole
stack is uh now if you have to see what
are the operations you can do inside a
stack uh you actually have
some limited operations but they have
very specific use cases so let's say
that currently we have a stack like this
321 there are three elements so number
first thing we can do is we can push
value inside the stack because we
already pushed these three values uh
inside the stack so pushing element
inside the stack is actually quite
simple all you need to do is just push
it and whichever is like sequentially
available memory block so let's say that
this is a stack like this so this would
be the element that gets filled so this
takes big off one time now you also have
the option to pop a element out so when
you pop an element out you only have
access to just pop out the element that
is currently located at the first pace
so in this case you can only pop out
this element and after that is done you
will pop out this element so this also
takes big off one time now the next
option we have is that many times rather
than popping one element out we can just
check that what is the current element
at the very top and that for that we
usually do like a peak operation and
this also takes big off one time so you
would you must be thinking that hey this
is super fast uh data structure so let's
use this up to the fullest extent but uh
this is very limited in memory size and
also like the way data is being stored
so if we when we start talking about
additional operations if we have to find
an element inside a stack that takes big
off end time for obvious reasons because
at one point we are only accessing one
element out and let's say that the
element we are trying to get out is
actually located at the very bottom we
won't be able to reach it until we reach
all the elements if we have to once
again delete any element once again it
will take big of end time because we
will have to first find that element so
that also adds an additional layer of
complexity and same goes for modify as
well that that this also takes B go off
end time so all of these things they are
closed L correlated with each other now
let's see that what are the operations
we can do or what are the use cases of a
stack so number one use case of a stack
is that wherever you need to maintain a
sequence in one order and the reverse
order sequence has to be match in that
case uh stack would be a great example
and this is one of the very popular
scenario for that where we are we want
to check that the number of parentheses
we have are they in the correct order or
not and that can very easily be
determined using a stack where all the
parentheses that are coming in they also
get out in the same manner and U if you
want we can also try to do a quick
example so let's say that currently we
are trying to build a compiler and in
our compiler we wants to check that all
the parentheses that were opened they
are closed in the same sequence so what
we can do is okay the moment we open a
parenthesis we are going to push an
value inside the stack So currently
stack is empty and let's say that these
are the sequence of operation we are
going to do right that first we are
going to open a curly bracket then we
are going to open a square bracket then
a circular bracket and then we are going
to close in the correct manner as well
so the idea would be that first we open
the bracket so we are going to add a
value over here then once again open so
add open so add now when we are closing
the bracket we will remove the value and
try to see that whether the bracket is
of same kind or not so the first value
we removed is a curly is a circular
bracket and the value we are trying to
close is also a circular bracket which
means awesome so this sequencing was
correct now uh the very first element
currently is the square bracket open
square bracket and now the bracket we
are trying to close is also an open type
of bracket so once again this is also a
match so we can consider this and the
last element is a curly bracket and a
curly bracket so once again this is also
a match so the whole solution work and
now we are at the end of our parenthesis
at that time we also check inside our
stack and currently our stack is also
empty which means all the brackets that
were opened they got closed in the same
manner let's assume that uh there is one
more additional bracket over here in the
beginning that this was the case so then
after these three has been done we would
still have one entry over here which
would dictate that the parentheses were
not opened and closed in the same manner
and uh that would throw an error so this
is actually the use case being used in
many of the compilers as well so that's
actually quite cool to understand that a
simple data structure can give birth to
such a wide variety or such a huge
functionality now here is the problem
statement for the valid parenthesis
problem where we are given the string of
opening and and closing brackets and we
need to determine that whether it is a
valid sequence or not so for that we are
actually going to use a hashmap in this
case where we are going to create the
mapping of opening and closing brackets
where all the closing brackets are going
to be placed as the keys in the hashmap
and their subsequent values would be
their counterpart now let's move on to
our is valid method where as an input we
are given a string so first of all we
will initialize our stack uh we are
going to run a for Loop across the given
string and we will see that whether this
is a closing bracket or not if that is
the closing bracket we would get the top
element of the stack and if the stack is
empty we can return false if it is not
empty we will pop the element and we
will compare it with the closing element
so if they match that's fine if they
don't match we can return false and if
that is not the case if it is an opening
bracket we will simply push the value
inside the stack now in the end after
this whole Loop has ended essentially a
our stack should be empty if the stack
is empty we can return true that the
sequence is valid if it is not empty we
can return false so let's try to run
this
code and seems like our solution is
working as expected let's submit this
code and our code runs pretty
efficiently and you can imagine that how
Stacks are actually serving a very
critical functionality now let's try to
think about another example of what a
stack can do and that is a redo
functionality so we all know that what a
redo or undo functionality is basically
if you are going through your Google web
browser whenever you need to go back to
the previous website you were at uh
essentially a stack is being used and
how it does is that let's say that
initially you opened your Google So
currently your stack is empty now you
first go to the Facebook page so it will
Mark the value as Facebook from Facebook
you decided to go to the Instagram page
from Instagram you go to the YouTube
page and and from YouTube you go back to
the Twitter page now at the Twitter you
decide to hit that uh Arrow back button
or the undo button the moment you hit
back it is actually going to pop the
value out so currently okay uh you are
at the Twitter so previous element like
the YouTube would be there okay now
currently you are the Twitter you hit
the element back so it is going to pop
the first value out so first value
popped out would be YouTube so it will
take you to the YouTube page now from
the YouTube you once again hit the arrow
back so once again the Instagram page is
going to come out now currently you are
at the Instagram page and you have this
value now from the Instagram page you
decide to go to the let's say Uber page
so now because you went to a new page
there will be an entry for Uber being
added over here now once again when you
hit the undo button actually from The
Uber page you would actually go back to
the Facebook page so that's how these
things would work and uh this is
actually quite useful data structure in
my
opinion the last linear data structure
that is a Q and Q is also very popular
as the name suggest Q is actually quite
simple where unlike stack we actually
have both ends open but all the values
are coming in from one end and going out
from the other end so let's say that
currently you have the cube and you have
value number five come in so five would
be the first candidate to get out then
we have value number six coming so six
would be the second candidate to get out
same way all the subsequent elements
that keeps on coming in they all would
be stored in the same sequence of the
sequence they came in so we have a value
where we can NQ or where we can add
values to the cube and where we have a
position where we can DQ where the
values go out of the cube and uh we all
know the functionality of cube uh there
are lot of real life systems where we
need to have cues uh if we want to
generate like some Network packet
manufacturing or uh Network packet
submission type of system definitely we
are going to use because we want uh our
let's say that we have a system a and we
have a system B and we are sending some
Network packets so we want Network B to
receive the network packets in the same
manner they were sent from Network a so
for that on the B side we are actually
going to create a cube and this cube is
going to have the sequence IAL flow of
the networks so now let's see that for
the Q we already know the use case but
first understand that what are the types
of cues available so the number one type
of que is actually the just a regular
quebe then there is also priority Cube
now what priority Q means is that this
represents some real life scenario so
let's assume that you are currently
waiting at the DMV Center to make your
driving license and currently the
officer sitting there is asking for
everyone in a sequential manner so
currently all the people are standing in
the line and of course the person who
came the first would be the person
reaching out to the DMV officer in the
first manner but during this time DMV
officer identify a pregnant lady or some
person who had some disability so in
that case this person would be the first
person to go and meet to the officer and
complete the task and this is the real
example of how a priority looks like
where it mostly operates as a normal
queue unless you have some event that
you can Define that would dictate that
it has a higher priority so process that
first and this is quite useful in many
real life scenarios as well where let's
say that in your phone you wants most of
the stuff to happening in the sequential
manner but what if there is something
related to like payment fraud happening
so you want to put first first priority
for that and for that usually a priority
queue gets implemented now let's see
that what are the different operations
you can do or you can perform on a given
Cube so I'm drawing a preliminary basic
q and uh we are going to have the values
coming in from one end and going out of
the other end so essentially the first
value would be five that came in so the
first value would be five that would be
going out so Q operates on fif principle
first in first out unlike stack that was
working on Leo principle last in first
out so that is that is a difference
between them and you have to understand
now uh in the Q we first have the option
for NQ which means we are adding an
value to the back and this process takes
big off one time because it's a constant
time operation we already know where we
are heading same way for the DQ uh it
also takes big off one time because
again once again the operation is quite
similar now on top of that in the Q we
have the option to Peak that who is
going to be the first value coming out
so that does not actually comes out but
we would know that this is the value
then there is also another option to
search inside the queue but searching
like other data structure takes big off
end time and by the way for peing would
take big off one time now on top of that
we can actually delete an element from
the queue but we would rarely do that
because we want to process those
elements this also takes meig go off end
time and that essentially that's it now
I I think I already give you sufficient
examples of how does a queue operate or
how it looks like so you can actually
imagine that uh how things work with the
cube and one of the most popular data
structures out there is actually trees
so trees is not your everyday looking
array or link list it's actually
completely different uh first thing it
is a hierarchical data structure second
thing for the trees you actually have to
consider some terminologies so typically
a tree looks like this where it has a
node in this node you can store some
information so that information can be
anything you can store an integer value
you can store uh a character value or if
you want you can store some class values
as well so let's say that you created a
class called person and in that class
you have that first name last name and
date of birth you can fill out all of
the those information in this node but
apart from that on top of storing all of
this information let's say that you
store that information in the majority
part of the given tree node in the rest
of the part you actually create the
connections that it is connected to with
other nodes and this is really important
so one single tree you only have access
to the root node but from this root node
you can actually connect to multiple
places inside the given tree so you can
actually be connected with two more
nodes that are below that under one of
nodes you can be connected with three
more or four more or any more number of
nodes this node maybe only have one node
then and this node has another node and
this is how typically a tree progresses
so when we are talking about trees we
will have to first Define few important
things so I already told you the number
one thing that what a node is that node
is basically the portion of tree that
contains data that contains important
information now next important
information for that a tree needs is an
edge and what does an edge represents so
if we see or take a look at this picture
Edge is essentially the o that connects
any two node and there needs to be some
relationship between them so typically
in a tree you would always see a
relationship like this where a tree is
always under some other parent tree so
in this case this root node is actually
a parent node for these two subsequent
nodes but also at the same time let's
say that you have four more nodes over
here then in this case for these nodes
this becomes a grandparent and uh this
becomes uh these two nodes becomes
parents for these subsequent nodes so
there is always a parent child
relationship and that relationship is
typically defined through an edge next
we need to discuss that what a root
means so root means the node that is
that supersedes all the nodes so
essentially the great great great great
greatest grandparent essentially the
very first node that becomes your entry
point into the tree and this is defined
as the root node now let's talk about
that what does a leaf node means so Leaf
node means that the node that does not
have any children so let's say we have a
tree that looks like this in this case
we currently have a node this node is by
default the root node and this tree is
connected with these two edges to these
two children but these two children does
not have any subsequent children of
their own so in this case uh these two
nodes actually becomes the leaf node
that we are trying to explain now let's
talk about the concept of depth now what
does a depth means inside a tree
essentially for any given tree uh it is
always placed in the layers that one
root node has some children then these
children have subsequent children of
themselves as well there can be n number
of Childrens and for the Simplicity sake
I'm drawing two children for every
single parent but there can be n number
of children and in this case we can see
that currently this root node is
actually located at depth one or you can
also consider it depth zero depending on
what type of situation you're tackling
they are just numbers but they would be
the initial depth and then with every
level you go down the number of depth
increases by one so in this case this is
located at depth one this is located at
depth two so essentially depth can also
be considered as level of parents or
children uh that each one of them has
and very close and very similar similar
concept is of height so height basically
defines that how deep a tree goes so in
this case from the root node we actually
go two levels down so we can consider
the height of this tree to be two uh
same way uh from any single separate
node you can also calculate the height
from that position as well and in this
case the height would be one if we
consider this smaller sub tree of a tree
so these are the different terminology
that you have to understand before we
proceed with uh what a tree is now let's
try to see that what are the different
types of trees that are available and
trust me there are lot of types of trees
so first let's just start with the
simplest trees and that is binary tree
now what does binary tree defines well
we all know the meaning of binary binary
means either zero or one which means it
means two so binary tree means that
every single root node has exactly two
children so in this case this would have
two children same way these subsequent
nodes would have two children of their
each and so on and so forth and until we
run out of the level so in this case
let's say that this has two children and
that's it so this is a binary tree why
because by definition every single
parent has exactly two children or no
children at all so and that property is
followed across all the nodes uh so
binary tree is what you're are going to
encounter mostly in your typical
interviews and very closely and a a
subset of this binary tree is actually
binary search tree so what does binary
search tree means that it follows all
the properties that a binary tree has
that every single node has exactly two
children or no children at all but on
top of that the binary search tree has
an additional property where the values
that are being represented in that those
binary trees they are actually sorted
with the condition that everything on
the left is actually less than
everything on the right uh and this
property is followed throughout the
entire tree so let me give you an
example let's say that we currently have
a tree that looks like this and
currently the value of this root node is
s then it it can only have children
where the scenario is that everything on
this left sub tree has to be less than
seven if it is everything on this left
sub tree is less than seven and
everything on the right sub tree is
greater than seven in that case we can
Define this as a binary tree or sorry
binary sear tree so let's say that we
add two more nodes over here and these
two nodes Define the values as that this
one is value number five and this one is
value number eight so far this follows
the property of a binary search tree
that is good for us now let's just take
it one step forward as well so we have
two more child over here in this case so
in this case let's say that the value of
this child is three and again value of
this child is six is it still a binary
tree yes why because let's follow the
same property currently if we consider
this parent node then this becomes the
left sub Tree in left subtree all the
values are less than value s so that is
good now let's consider this node so
this node is five its left is three and
Its Right is six and that is also
followed because left sub tree is less
than five and right sub tree is greater
than five so both properties match same
way the right sub tree is currently
greater than seven so this property also
matches so in this case this would be a
binary search tree and binary search
tree has lot of potential and lot of
application you can actually use it for
sorting or you can use it for to store
data or to go hierarchically down so we
we will talk more about this when we go
when we start talking about uh various
uh scenarios where you can actually use
the uh tree data structure now there is
one more data structure that is called a
AVL trees so what AVL trees is that AVL
tree is actually a special kind of tree
where not only it is a binary tree but
apart from that it is also binary search
tree and on top of that it is a balance
tree so what does the balance tree means
so let me give you first an example of a
balance tree balance tree is any tree
where all the nodes on the left side of
sub tree and all the nodes on the right
side of subtree are even so in this case
let's say if I have a tree like this
this is a balance tree if I have a tree
like this where left node has two sub
nodes and right node also has two sub
nodes this is also balance tree so any
symmetric tree is basically balance tree
and AVL trees contains all of these
three properties yeah so that is about
AVL tree then there are all more
specialized trees that is red black tree
and there is also B trees but these are
just too higher of the concepts but I'm
just going to give you an example that
red red black tree is actually a tree
that has separate colors so some nodes
are defined in a certain color and the
other nodes are defined in the certain
colors and depending on their
positioning the colors are maintained so
whenever you try to add new value uh it
automatically maintains the colors and
it automatically generates that what
should be the next subsequent value
based on those coloring groupings so the
red black trees are great at sorting
various items and various operations
depending on the color property and B
trees are multi-level balance and sorted
uh tree data structure that can have
more than two uh more than two children
so it is actually much more complex
topic and in its own uh it has actually
lot of uh things that we can think about
but we are not going to go deeper
because that would be much that would be
a topic for much higher level I just
wanted to give you a brief overview for
that now let's let's see that what are
the operations we can do on a tree so
the operations are quite simple we can
do like searching we can also do sorting
we can also do uh deletion and in
insertion all of those things right but
in order to do that uh we actually have
to Traverse over the tree all the time
and the most important operation that
you will have to learn about is that how
how the traversal Works inside a given
tree so actually for trees there are
typically three different ways you can
Traverse over inside the given tree and
that that are that in order traversal
pre-order traversal and postorder
traversal so how each each and every one
of them is going to work well I actually
have a separate video on that but if you
want you can just check what I'm trying
to explain right now what in order
traversal means is that first we are
going to visit the node then we are
going to visit the left child and then
we are going to visit the right right
child child pre-order means that first
we are going to visit the left child
then we are going to visit the node and
then we are going to visit the right
child and post order means that first we
visit left then we visit right and then
we visit node so let's see this in
action suppose we uh we are given a
simple tree so I'm currently drawing a
simple most basic tree and we will go
through its values right so let's say
the values are one then on the left is
two and then Its Right is three and also
on the right is four and on the left is
five and on the right is six let's say
that this is the type of tree that we
are trying to generate now let's see
that what would be the in order
traversal would be for this part this
type of tree well of course first we are
going to visit the node so node in this
case is going to be the root node and
that is going to be one so the very
first value we are going to go through
is going to be value number one then we
are going to see all the left sub tree
So currently for the left subtree it
only has node number two but again at
node number two we are also going to
visit this and then after visiting now
currently for this node number two it
does not have any left sub tree that we
can visit so we are going to go into the
right side and on the right sub tree we
have value number three that we haven't
visited so we are going to visit node
number three after that again we are
going to repeat the same process now in
this case we already took care of this
value this value and this value so now
even for node number one we are going to
go to the right sub Tre but for right
sub tree again we are going to apply the
same logic of node left and right so
once again we we are first of all going
to visit node number four and after that
we are going to visit node number five
and then we are going to visit node
number six so we took care of all the
nodes so this is how uh the traversal
works for in order traversal now let's
do the pre-order traversal and inside
the pre-order traversal it's clearly see
that we need to go to the left as much
possible as we can so from the initial
note do we have a left sub tree yes uh
in the left sub tree we are going to go
to this node now does this node has any
left sub tree that we haven't checked no
because this does not have a left sub
tree then we can visit the node so while
visiting the node the first node we are
going to visit for the pre-order
traversal let me just write it over here
so the first node would be node number
two now the next node we are going to
visit is going to be the right subt tree
of this node now for this three it does
not have any children which means we
will have to visit this node so we are
going to visit node number three first
after visiting these two now for this
node number one we took care of the
entire left sub tree so we can actually
visit node number one now after visiting
node number one we need to take care of
the entire right subtree but again with
the same logic of left node and right so
again we are at this position now this
does have a left node so we are going to
visit five first then we are going to
visit the node and then we are going to
visit node number six so this would be
the pre-order traversal for the given
tree now let's see that what would be
the postorder traversal for the given
tree so in terms of post order traversal
it is going to be actually quite simple
uh again using the same logic we need to
First go through every single left node
then we need to go through every single
right node and then only we will visit
the existing node So currently for this
one it does have a left node for this
two it does not have a left node but it
does have a right node so we are going
to visit node number three first so in
the post order traversal the first node
we are going to visit is going to be
node number three then the next node we
are going to visit is going to be node
number two and then we are going to
visit node number uh one no we are not
going to visit node number one right now
because because node needs to be visited
in the end and it still has right subt
tree that we haven't checked so now we
are going to visit the right subtree and
this this portion now becomes the node
and for this it also has a left node so
now we are going to visit five then we
are going to visit six then we are going
to visit node number four and after
completing both of these portion we are
going to visit node number one in the
end so this would be the full traversal
for the given tree uh the in order
pre-order and post order traval uh this
is the most trickiest thing to
understand for any single tree and I
hope you find you find it useful now
let's see that what is going to be the
searching sorting deletion and insertion
for the given tree so let's say that
searching if we are given a normal tree
then the searching is for sure going to
take big of end time but if we are given
a binary search tree in that case
searching would be bigo of log n only
because every single iteration we would
be uh moving half of the element on one
side and we we can focus steadily on the
target so that is why binary search
trees are so popular now let's talk
about sorting uh so for sorting actually
if we are given a binary search tree
then sorting is actually constant uh
sorry because of log and time because
it's quite easy to do uh we only need to
Traverse over over the given tree and uh
many for many sorting algorithm binary
search trees are being used deletion if
if we know which node we have to delete
then it's a constant time deletion
operation but if we don't know the node
and we have to search first then it
becomes big go of n or log n depending
on what type of tree we are given and
same goes with the insertion that if we
know that we we can insert any randomly
then it's B go of one but if we cannot
do it and we have to insert it at
specific location then it's B of n or
big of log n depending on where we are
trying to insert and what type of tree
we are given so this is everything you
need to understand about trees but now
let's see that what are the uses on how
on and where we can actually use trees
so number one use case for a tree is
typically a database management system
uh why database management system
because number one binary search trees
then AVL trees then red black trees then
B trees all of these are huge and very
powerful in separating all the elements
so that's why they are quite popular
whenever you are trying to build a data
stru database on top of that they are
really po really powerful when you are
trying to index all the values and
indexing and enabling fast data retrival
can only be possible using the trees if
you have to use uh anything for file
systems or file management uh so because
tree they are already in hierarchical
nature and whenever you see your windows
path or your something something you
will always see something like C drive
it has a file called programs it has a
file called uh Java it has a file called
bin something like that so this is a
parent child relation where every single
node is connected with the other node
and uh you can actually go over that
plus if you want to create like a syntax
trees you can also do that using the
trees why syntax trees because let's say
that if you're trying to build a
scenario or a compile or something where
you want to show that what class is
connected with what other class and you
are trying to avoid any infinite Loop
scenarios so in that case tree data
structure would be a huge help and on
top of that you can actually use trees
to build priority cues as well so this
is also a very good benefit to use you
can actually do that using Heap and uh I
won't be explaining the whole concept
but just know that this can be done okay
so now let's try to see uh some examples
for the tree based questions so one of
the very common example is that
typically we are being asked to validate
a binary search tree now we all know by
definition that what a binary search
tree is that essentially every single
node that is on the left side of the
tree is actually less than uh the node
value and every single node on the right
side of the sub tree is actually greater
than the node value and this property
has to be followed throughout the entir
of tree so let me give you a couple of
examples where we will try to see that
which are some of the valid trees which
are not valid trees and how we can solve
this problem in an actual interview or
for our practice so assume we are given
a tree like this where the values are 1
2 3 4 and 5 and uh these are the
connection of the nodes so in this case
we can clearly see that this is a valid
binary search tree why because this is
the middle node node number three now if
we see the left sub tree for this node
is actually the values are 2 and 1 and
both are small than value number three
same way in the right side of the sub
tree the values are four and five and
again both are greater than that
particular value now we have couple of
more sub trees as well that we need to
check and that is this one so first sub
tree is that this value of two and the
value of one so again since the one is
less than two and it is on the left side
of the two uh it is a valid path same
goes for this four and five as well and
in this case we can Define this to be a
valid binary search tree but now let's
consider a scenario that if we are given
a tree like this suppose the values are
5 4 3 and then this one is 6 and then
this one is 2 and uh these are the nodes
that are currently connected now let's
break them down sube by sub tree so
let's consider first this value number
three and value number two they are just
uh simple or Leaf nodes so they don't
mean anything now let's consider this
sub tree is this a valid sub tree yes
why because three is less than four and
it is currently on the left child of
four so that is true now let's consider
this entire sub tree so this is also
valid because both four and five three
are smaller than value number five now
let's consider this sub tree this is
also valid scenario where six is
actually uh higher and in the greater
value so 2 is smaller than six so that
is why it is on the left side but when
we consider this whole portion then it
fails and why it fails because the value
number for Value number five the
expectation is that everything that is
on the right side of value number five
which means this portion has to be
greater than value number five but since
this two is actually less than five so
because of this we can Define this to be
a wrong wrongly placed uh value so this
is not a valid binary search Tre now the
question is how can we actually find the
solution for this type of problem uh for
trees so one simple approach is that if
we do an in order traversal for any
binary search tree if the tree is valid
we should get a sorted array or sorted
values in return and let me give you an
example for this let me for a moment
make this a valid binary search
Tre so the method for in order traversal
is first we visit the left sub child
then we visit the node we want to check
and then we visit Its Right sub child or
right child and we keep on repeating for
all the sub trees so so essentially
first of all we will start our journey
at this root position so at the root
position first we need to check that
whether a left child exist or not and
yes because left sh exist once again
this becomes our current root node or
current node we are working with again
this also has a left sh so three would
be the first value we would visit so
let's mark three would be the first
value we visited then we would go back
to the root now this node has no other
left Sub sub trial uh that has not been
visited so we would visit value number
four and then it does not have a right
child so we will again go back and now
for this five we took care of the entire
left sub tree so we can mark five as
visited as well and then we will go to
the right side of the sub tree now in
the right side of the sub tree for seven
we still have a left node available
which means we would first have to
Traverse that so we would Traverse value
number six and then we would go back and
since this seven we took care of the
left sub tree so now we will take care
of value number seven and this is where
we would end and now if you see this
sequence this actually came out as a
sorted uh values so this is all we need
to do that whenever we need to uh run
for a tree we simply need to do an in
order traversal if all the values are in
correct sorted manner then we can Define
this to be a valid binary search tree if
that is not the case we can Define it
invalid and let's try to understand this
with a very small example suppose we are
given the values as uh 5 3 and 2 suppose
this is the sequence of values now if we
do order traversal in this one first for
five we are going to visit the left
child so we are going to visit value
number three that is good then we would
visit value number five and in the end
we would visit the right side right sub
tree that is value number two now up
until this portion this was a valid
binary search Tre but the moment two
entered over here this this is no longer
a sorted uh sequence so that's why we
can Define that this is not a valid
binary search tree and let's see the
code for this one right now
so this is the validate binary search
tree problem and now let's see the Java
solution for this approach we already
know that we need to do an in order
traversal in order to validate that
whether given tree is valid or not and
for that we are creating a helper method
where first of all we are checking that
if the given root is equal to null then
we can return true if that is not the
case we need to do the in order for the
left sub tree of the given root and the
right sub Tre of the given roote so we
do this that we call our uh recursive
method once again where we call the left
subtree uh as an input and we try to see
that what is going to be its answer so
let's say that if this yields the answer
as false uh then we can simply return
false if that is not the case then we
can move forward and we will check that
if whether the previous element was null
not equal to null and if the value of
the root is less than the previous
element then also we can return false
which means in this scenario we
identified an anomaly where there has
been a mismatch between any two values
and they are not currently sorted if
that is not the case then we are going
to Mark the previous node as the root of
the value of the root we identified and
then we are going to call the in order
function once again on the right side of
the sub tree so this is a very simple
piece of code but it's actually very
powerful and help us Traverse the tree
in the correct manner recursively plus
we are learning that uh what type of uh
tree it is now let's submit this code
and our code runs pretty fast compared
to a lot of other Solutions so that's
pretty
good where graph is a very similar data
structure to a tree uh and if we just
talk about the terminology that we are
going to use in the graph even in the
graph we are going to have a node but in
the graph we can also Define node as a
vertex and that essentially represents
the same circular dot that I just
mentioned where you can store all sorts
of information like integer or character
Boolean or class value or whatever he
wants to store you can store that inside
but on top of that apart from that nodes
node having that important data
information it also has the information
of other nodes that is that it is
connected to in the current system and
those other nodes can be n number of
nodes on top of that those other nodes
can also be connected inter internally
as well and there are some scenarios
where one node is connected with another
node but another node is not connected
with that node and that node might be
connected with some other node and that
some other node might be connected with
that node as well so there are lot of
different uh ways uh graphs can work now
one key difference between a tree and a
graph is that graphs are graphs can be
cyclic in nature and what do I mean by
cyclic that let's say that you have a
node that is connected with another node
it could be possible that is also
connected with another node and that is
also connected with the previous note
and this type of configuration would not
be present inside a tree this this can
only be present or prevalent inside the
graph and that is the the biggest
difference between trees and graphs and
that's why they have their own entire
set of different con considerations and
connections so now let's just go back to
the basic terminology that we need to
understand first we understood that what
a node or Vex is or vertices is next
thing uh that we have to consider is The
Edge and Edge is the it means the same
thing that that is the connection point
between any two values uh that are next
to each that are connected with each
other so Edge means the connecting
points now there is also the concept of
adjacent uh adjacency or adjacent
vertices what do I mean by adjacent
vertices let's say I have a graph that
looks like this and in this case uh
currently let me Mark the values as a b
c and d so in this case if I consider
this node number c I can say that node D
node B and let's mark this node as node
e so B D and E are actually adjacent
nodes to this node C because they're
directly connected with that with an
edge but if the this node is not
actually connected with vertices then in
this case this node C and A are they are
not adjacent nodes to each other so this
is what what do we mean by adjacent
nodes now there is also a concept ccept
of degree inside for any single vertex
and what does a degree means that degree
means that how many number of vertexes
uh or connections that every single node
has so let's say if I have a graph that
looks like this in this case I have node
a b and c so I can Define that this node
only has one Edge so I can consider the
degree of this node to be one in this
case for this B it has the degree of two
and in this case this C it has degree of
one now there is also another concept of
the total degree depending on the
incoming and out
outcoming edges as well and where does
incoming and outcoming edges comes to
place well we we will talk more about
that when we discuss the type of graphs
but remember that graphs can have a
functionality where two one graph is
connected with another graph but another
graph is not connected so in this case
if we Mark if we have a graph like this
where a has an edge leading to the B but
B does not have an edge leading to an a
which means from a we can actually go to
B but from B we cannot go back to a so
in this case a would have an degree of
one but B would have degree of zero in
this case so that is that is the
difference between these two uh this
concept of degree for the graphs now
let's see that what are the types of
graphs that we we can deal with so
number one type of graph is a directed
graph and what does a directed graph
means that I just showed it to you you
that this is actually a directed graph
where one node is actually connected
with another node but it is not the vice
versa is not true and the directed
graphs can get really complicated as
well it is not always going to be this
simple or this similar and it could also
be possible that there can be hundreds
or even millions of nodes that are
connected with each other in this
fashion as well uh where we would have
various degrees and various directions
happening amongst different vertices
there could be undirected graphs as as
well and undirected graphs are actually
a graph where two nodes share a common
Edge so in this case rather than
treating is as a single edge typically
this is used to be like this where node
a has an edge leading to node B and B
has an edge leading to node a which
means from B you can also come back to a
and from a you can also go back to B but
in this case typically we only show them
using a single edge then whenever there
is an edge without an arrow it defines
that both nodes are connected with each
other in the simplest Manner and there
are there is a bidirected connection or
an undirected connection now there is
also consider uh also a concept of
weighted graph and what does a weighted
graph means that let's say that you have
different nodes and different nodes had
different connections and different
connections have edges so edges carry
weight as well let's say if I'm trying
to plot a graph of a city now in this
city uh this node represents the Young
Street and this node represents the main
street now these two streets are being
represented and there is let's say there
is also third street called Queen Street
now there is a graph that looks like
this but in this case it could be
possible that this is this graph I'm
defining this is defined as a road so it
could be possible that from Young to
main though there is a road there is
some construction going on so because of
that this Edge is actually weights five
which means it takes 5 minutes from
Young to go to main but it could be
possible that from Young if we need to
go to Queen it only takes 1 minute
because there is no construction and
from Queen there is only uh there is an
edge going to main that also only takes
1 minute because there's no uh traffic
so in this case because this Edge
contains higher weight if we have to
choose the shortest path between young
and Main Street it it has to go through
the queen Street and uh this would be
the concept of a weighted graph this is
really powerful especially for GPS
system and the shortest path that we
have to create uh between any two edges
like Google Maps use this like crazy uh
now there is also another concept of
unweighted uh Edge and unweighted Edge
is basically an edge that does not have
any parameter uh so let's say that I'm
creating a graph of just friends so
currently a is friends with B and B is
friends with c and C is also friends
with a so in this casee I don't need to
have any weight on the edge um they are
all just friends and none of them are
best friends so that's why it's a common
relationship and U we can do whatever he
wants to do then there is also concept
of Click graphs and a cyclic graphs so
cyclic and ayylic both means the same
thing essentially this is a cyclic graph
and let's say that if I did not had this
Edge in this case then this would have
been an ayylic graph where cylic graph
has means that there exist a cycle
between the nodes and a CLI graph means
that there are no no Cycles happening so
usually in ayli graphs there is a very
popular concept of dag which is which
means directed ayylic graph and directed
asly graph means that every single node
has an directed Edge so let's say that
there this is node a node a is connected
with node B and node B is connected with
node C and C is connected with node D so
this is an example of directed A
basically graph where we see bunch of
different edges but there are there are
no issues with the graph now because
graphs are a little bit trickier uh we
have to take care of two things we have
to take care of vertices and we also
have to take care of edges to represent
that what graph is connected with which
so that is why uh even in order to
represent a graph we need to have some
different set of data structure so one
possible data structure is an adjacency
Matrix and another data possible data
structure is an adjacency list so I'll
I'll give you give you an explanation of
both of them let's just have a demo
graph uh that is a simple enough so
let's just say we have a graph that a is
connected with B and B is connected with
C and C is connected with d and this is
a graph right uh that we are trying to
represent so if we have to create an
adjacency Matrix what adjacency Matrix
means is that we are actually going to
have a 2X two or sorry M cross n Matrix
where for every single vertices and
edges we are going to have uh a matrix
looking like this so we are going to
have rows a b c d same way we are going
to have columns marked as a b c d now
currently uh all of the these four
values will always be zero because node
cannot be connected or cannot be its own
neighbor now now let's say that
currently a has a connection with B so
we are talking about node a and its
neighboring Edge to be B so in this case
we would mark this value as one now B
has a connection with C so node B has a
connection with C so we would also Mark
this value as one C has a connection
with d so C to D we would mark it as one
and D to uh and D does not have any
connection which means this is going to
be zero and all the other values they
are going to be marked as zeros because
they don't represent anything which
means currently we have a graph that
contains four nodes a b c d amongst
these four nodes we only have connection
between from A to B so that is why this
is one but we do not have a connection
from B to a so that is why this is
defined as zero let's say that rather
than this being a directed graph If This
Were to be an undirected graph and we
only have edges like these in this case
in our adjacency Matrix we are going to
represent values differently
where uh even from B to a we are also
going to Mark as an edge same way from C
to B we are also going to mark an edge
and same way uh D to C we are also going
to mark an edge over here so all of
these values would also be one in this
case so this is the way on how we can
represent graph in The adjacency Matrix
Now adjacency list is a little bit
different where adjacency list we
actually have a hash map and I I know I
haven't talk talk about hashing yet but
inside a typical hash we have two values
we have a key and we have some value
associated with those that key so as a
key we are actually going to have the
four vertices that we are given so in
this case it's a b c and d now for this
we are going to mark that what are all
the neighbors that a is connected with
in this case currently a is only
connected with B so we are going to have
a value like B Associated for a same way
currently B is actually connected with A
and C both so for B we will have a value
of a and C both and this is actually
going to be a link list that where which
represents that there can be n number of
children associated with a sing or n
number of neighbors associated with a
single node same goes for C that from C
it is connected with b and d and d is
only connected with c and this is how it
would be represented in adjacency list
now the question is which one is better
and which one is worse well in my
opinion both does the job well but if
you're dealing with a low number of
edges then in that case it makes sense
to use an adjacency list because it SP
it uses less space uh meanwhile over
here you see that there are more zeros
than the number of ones but let's say
that we have bunch of different edges
that we are trying to work with
something like this in this case it
would make more sense to use an
adjacency Matrix rather than using
adjacency list so so these are the two
ways on which we can actually use uh to
represent graphs now what are the
operations we can do on the graphs uh
speaking of operations well the common
operations are always going to be there
that in terms of operations we would be
able to insert we would be able to
delete we would be able to modify we
would be able to search there is no
there is very little concept of sorting
in this case because it is not very
optimal for sorting but apart from that
these these are all the things that we
can do but in order to do that we can
only do it by traversing over the given
graph because we would not know that
where we are traversing so we must have
to Traverse and for Traverse we actually
have two options we have the breath
first search and we have the depth first
search so I'm going to talk about both
of them in a simplest manner uh if you
want to know more about this uh I have
created an entire separate videos on
these two topics so that's why let me
give you the basic idea that BFS
represents breath first search what does
breath first search means that we are
actually going to search our neighbors
first and before going to their
neighbors and DFS means that depth first
search what does depth for search means
that we will pick a neighbor then we
will pick one more neighbor for that
neighbor then we will pick one more
neighbor for that neighbor and we would
keep on moving forward in that direction
so let's try to see that in
let's say that we have a graph that
looks like this where we have bunch of
different nodes that are closely
connected with each other and we are
trying to find some particular value
right uh let me draw out bunch of
different edges and with every single
edge uh we would be able to reach to a
certain conclusion about the given graph
now let's say that this is the graph
currently we have and we also have a
cycle in in it now we are currently
located at this node number a and we are
trying to find this node number B and
all of these nodes they can have their
own subsequent separate values so if we
are going in the BFS manner breath for
search manner what we what we will start
to do is let's say that this a is also
the root node because even just like
trees graphs also have the concept of
root node so let's say that this a is
the root node so from this a we know
that what are the neighbors of a through
either adjacency list or adjacency
Matrix so we are going to use that in
information and we will start traversing
to all the neighbors so first we will go
to this neighbor okay this is not value
number B then we will go to this
neighbor this is not value number B then
we will go to this neighbor this is not
value number B then we will go to this
neighbor then we will go to this number
we ex ex uh excluded all the
possibilities for all the neighbors none
of these neighbors were actually value
number B so then we will pick one
neighbor at R random and we would keep
on moving forward so let's say we pick
pick this neighbor again we go to its
neighbor and again we go to its neighbor
none of these yielded any good any
particular good result so what we do we
backtrack in that case and again from
this a we would pick another neighbor so
let's say we pick this neighbor this
time and through this neighbor we would
go to this neighbor and we would also go
to this neighbor and we found out value
number B so we can say that okay this is
the connection between a to B and let's
just say for this example the value of
this neighbor is node number c so we can
say that there exist a path from a to c
and from C to B where it is connected
now this would be the strategy for
breath first search uh and I hope that
my explanation was clear enough so that
you get the idea now let's see that what
would happen in the depth for search
scenario so in the depth for search
scenario we will pick one neighbor and
we will keep going deeper and deeper
into that neighbor so let's try to
understand this with an example suppose
we are again located at this position
number a so from this position number a
first we will pick a neighbor so let's
say we pick again this neighbor now
again for this neighbor we would pick
one more neighbor so one more neighbor
we ex now we uh concluded all the
possibility that there this neighbor
does not have any neighbor that we
haven't visited so what we would do is
we would backtrack to this position
again see that are there any neighbors
that we haven't visited so we actually
check this neighbor okay this one we
haven't visited so we visit that and
that also did not yield any result so
again we backtrack we come back to our
main a then we pick another neighbor so
let's say in this case we pick another
neighbor called C from the C we again go
to deep okay so this one did not yield
it result so in this case again we check
for this one and this one yielded the
correct result and we again created a
path from A to B to C and again we got
the correct answer now you must know
that under which situation you need to
use breath for search and under with
situation you need to use depth for
search let's say that you have a graph
and you expect B to be somewhat closely
to your current a if you expect that in
that case it would make more sense to
use breath for search because you are
more likely to find a result within some
of the neighboring graphs but let's say
that you have a graph that is much more
complicated and B can be located
somewhere down the road uh somewhere
very far far far away in that case it
would make sense to use a depth for
search rather than breadth for search in
either case the time and space
complexity for both breadth for search
and depth for search is actually going
to be bigo of M cross n where M can be
the number of vertices and N cross be
the number of edges so it could it would
be B of Vertes multiply by edges and all
the operations we defined for the arrays
they are also going to have or they are
also going to follow the same time
complexity that whenever we need to to
find any any two values it is going to
be the same now let's see that what are
the use cases when you have to use
graphs number one use case is actually
social network so in Social Network we
know that let's say that my name is
person a so person a can be friends with
many other person so I can be friends
with B I can be friends with C I can be
friends with d i can be friends with e
something something something like that
right and E can have their own separate
friends so e can have friends F and uh
Zed and all all all of that now this is
how a typical social network looks like
and that is why it is really common to
use that let's say if I'm using a social
network like Facebook where if I am I
can only be friends with someone if that
person is friends with me in that case
there would be an undirected
relationship but let's say if I'm using
something like Instagram where some X
person can follow me but I cannot follow
that X person so in that case let's say
that I have a relationship like this
where X is following me but I'm not
following back X so in this case we have
a directed graph or a directed
relationship but either cases it works
perfectly fine next there would be a
great use case for uh different internet
and because in the internet we have a
many different web pages that contains
lot of information and we have the HTTP
uh URLs that are are connected with each
other on top of that from every single
uh web page we can also have many
different HTTP web pages that connects
to some other web page and from that it
can have many different web pages that
connects to some other web page so in
this case graph can be a good way to
store all of that information plus I
already mentioned that if you want to
create a GPS system or any navigation
system graphs are a wonderful approach
and you cannot build a navigation system
without using graphs where cities or
places are treated as vertices and the
roads are treated as edges and uh that
is how you move move forward on top of
that wherever you have to resolve any
dependencies you can actually use graphs
to resolve that dep dependency so let me
give you a quick example let's say that
you are studying in a university and in
the University we know that we can only
take courses that are like 204 or 205 if
we already completed its prerequisite of
105 something like this so if that
relationship is done done if unless I
have completed this I cannot move
forward to this particular course so in
that scenarios treating different
courses as vertices and connections with
them between them or dependencies
between them as edges would yield to
Greater success in terms of all the
results so these are all the operations
and all the things where you must use
graphs so first of all we are going to
understand a graph with an example so
this is a very simple problem and I
might use some terms or some Concepts
that you might not be familiar with but
don't worry about it I would be guiding
you throughout the whole journey and
it's actually a quite simple way to
understand what does a typical graph
problem looks like and how does it work
so number one thing in the graph is that
for this problem we are actually given
an N cross n Matrix and in this n cross
n Matrix we are being told that this n
represents the basically cities and if
there is a path from one city that
connects to another city then there
would be a link in this n cross n m
Matrix so it would Mark as one for that
particular cell and if there is not a
path then there won't be U any
connection and it would be defined as
value zero so let's try to see that what
we need to check we essentially needs to
calculate that how many number of
provinces are there so what provinces
are being defined as that let's say that
if there is there are cities connected
with each other then they would be part
of a single Province so this would be a
single Province P1 and even if there is
a unique city that is not connected with
each other still it is a province on its
own so we would consider this as a
province as well and uh let's try to see
some examples of what different
questions or what different things that
we can refer so number one example is
actually quite simple let's assume that
we are given the CI a b and c in this
case and we can see that City a and City
B is connected with each other City C is
not connected with each other so in this
case this is a province and this is in
itself another Province so we can return
that in this case there are two
provinces present and we can return two
as the answer let's consider one more
scenario suppose we are given uh four
cities in this case and let's say that
for the four cities all four cities are
connected like this and you see that
there is actually no connection over
here but still we can conclude these
cities to be connected how because let's
say that this is a so a is connected
with B and B is connected with C and C
is connected with d so in this case you
can still reach to D so all of this
entire cluster would be considered as a
single Province only let's take just one
more example to make things more clear
let's suppose we are given four
different cities and all four different
cities are not connected with each other
in this case we can Define that four
there are in total four separate
provinces available in this case so
let's see that what is going to be the
approach to solve this
problem okay so let's assume that this
is the example we are given and this
would be its Matrix that is going to
represents the connection connection
between any two cities now in this
example we can clearly see that there
are actually going to be three number of
provinces uh this is the first Province
this is the second Province and this is
the third Province but let's see that
how we are going to compute these
results and for that we are going to uh
first Mark or populate these Matrix
basically this Matrix is already given
to you in the example but I'm just
showing you that what is the approach we
are going to take in order to solve this
problem so first we are going to see
that uh since there is a single ended or
one unidirectional connection between a
to B which means we can also Define that
there is a connection from B to a as
well and this is what we are going to
represent in this n cross n Matrix so
first let's see okay so we have u a
connection between a to B so we are
going to mark this as value number one
same way we have a connection between B
to a so we are going to mark this as is
one as well and B to C there is a
connection so from B to C there is a
connection same way from C to B there is
a connection up again from D to e there
is a connection so let's mark that from
D to e there is a connection over here
and same way from E there is a
connection to d as well so let's quickly
Mark that and uh that is over here okay
and then F there is no connection so
basically these are all the connections
we have apart from that all the values
are going to be filled out with values
of zero we can actually consider this as
a uh adjy Matrix for our our given graph
and we can treat each of the Cities as
the node of a graph and the connection
or the edges between these cities are
actually the edges between the these
nodes so now all we need to do is we
need to find the number of connected
components and that's it so that is
actually quite simple to do but how to
do it I'll just show it to you quickly
now I already mentioned to you that in
the graph we have to keep keep track of
the notes that we have visited already
so that we don't encounter any issues
with the visited uh we don't have any
issues in the future so we are going to
have uh basically a hash map that where
we are going to store the values of all
the visited values and plus we are also
going to keep track of the neighbors or
the connected cities for that particular
node as so we can actually skip that in
the future and the approach we are going
to take is we are going to do a breath
for search starting from any node and we
would keep on doing it until we exhaust
or we take care of all of these six
cities so let's start our approach and
the idea is that we are going to start
working from the node a so let's mark
that currently we are located at
position number a so we are located at
this position now from a we are going to
see that what are the places it it is
marked as one or it is connected to
those cities and we are going to Mark
those cities as visited so let's just
say since because we started a new
province with this new traversal a we
are going to increase the number of
provinces so this probe is defined as
the variable that keeps track of how
many number of provinces we have been
able to find so initial value was zero
and now we have value as one now from a
we see what who is the neighbor of a so
the neighbor of a is actually value
number B which means means in our
hashmap we already had entry a then we
are also going to add entry B and this
can actually be a hash set rather than
hashmap what is the difference you would
soon find out uh when we talk about
hashing but right now just consider that
we are marking these values so this
would allow us to let us know that these
are the cities we have already visited
so we don't visit them again okay now we
are at position number B from B which
are the cities B is connected with so
number one city B is connected with is
City number a but a we have already
visited so we are going to skip this for
now then we are going to visit City
number C and C we haven't visited so we
will mark C over here okay so now we are
at City number c what are the cities C
has that we have we haven't visited so C
is only connected with b and we have
already visited B so which means we can
conclude that in this case since we
visited C does not have any more
neighbors that we need to visit so we
will do a backt trck we will go to B B
again does not have any more neighbor
that we have to take keep track of so we
and once again we will backt track to a
and a we already visited all of its
neighbors so we can conclude this a b
and c to be completed over here and so
far we have been able to find one
Province but now in this case we will
jump or have to go to the next city d by
taking a jump because we are not going
through a connection from any particular
node so that is why we are adding one
more Province or we are exploring one
more Province so we will increase the
number of Province to two and in this
case uh at City number D we are going to
visit all the neighbors of D in breath
for search manner so since D only has
one neighbor that is City number e so we
are going to go to City number e and we
are going to Mark uh both d and e as
visited in our hashmap on top of it with
e e only has one city as its neighbor
and that is City number D so in this
case we have already visited D which
means we can Al conclude both d and e to
be visited as well and now we will have
to still go to a city that we haven't
visited so far that is City number have
the moment we go to a new city we are
going to increase the number of
provinces so now number of provinces is
going to be three and we are going to
say that we are currently visiting City
number F now F does not have any more
Neighbors which means we can conclude
that from F we cannot go anywhere else
and now we have visited all the cities
that were present because we have that
value in our hashmap and we so far we
have been able to find three different
provinces connected using this manner so
this is how typically a graph problem
operates where in most of the cases you
are going to have vertices you are going
to have edges you are somehow going to
iterate over all the vertices through
edges and you are going to use an
adjacency Matrix Or adjacency List uh uh
as the way that stores the information
of what the graph is and most like you
are going to use either hashmap or hash
set to keep track of the Cities you have
already visited so you don't end up in a
a continuous loop so let's see the Java
solution for number of provinces problem
basically uh we are we are given the 2x2
or n cross n Matrix that defines that
what are the components that are
connected with each other so first of
all we are going to define a number n
that is be that is going to be the
cities that we have and we are going to
create a Boolean visited array to keep
track of all the cities that we have
visited so far initially the number of
provinces are going to be zero and then
we are going to run a for Loop to
iterate over all the given number of
provinces and initially we are going to
check that whether that particular city
has been visited or not if it is not
being visited then we we will go to our
BFS call or breath for search call and
uh recursively try to find the solution
and every time uh the Call Comes Back we
are going to update the number of
provinces now in the end we are simply
going to return the number of provinces
now let's see that how does our BFS
function works now since we are doing
breath for search breath for search can
be done using a cube so we are going to
first of all initialize a cube and uh we
are going to have a link list for the
cube you can have lot of data structures
s Cube so first we are going to start
with the start value then we are going
to mark that start value as V visited
and then through that start value we
will keep on iterating to its neor
neighboring cities until we have visited
all the values inside the current q and
the moment as Q is empty we are going to
jump out and say that okay now we have
visited all the connected cities and
throughout our connection we are marking
those cities as visited so that's how we
are we have been able to calculate uh
all the connected cities as visited and
only increasing the number of provinces
for the new cities now let's try to run
this
code okay seems like our solution is
working let's submit this code code and
our codee runs pretty efficiently
compared to lot of other Solutions so
you can imagine that how a combination
of data structures are being used to
solve a simple problem and uh KN knowing
all of these data structures would help
you quite significantly in order to
break down and solve a problem and
generate the algorithm for that
problem okay now we will learn about
hash based data structures now hash
based data structure are actually quite
unique in nature plus they have their
own set of uh very important use cases
that you are going to see out throughout
your data structure and algorithm
problems so first let's understand that
what does a hash based data structure is
typically when we talk about hash based
data structure we are usually talking
about a hash map and a hash set now both
are quite similar in nature and both
have very similar properties but the
only difference is that hashmap is
typically used used for to store a key
value based uh mechanism where we have
some key that we use to search through
the given uh data structure so it will
give us an idea that what are the things
currently present inside our given data
structure and what are the values
associated with that hash set is uh
where we only save hash based keys so
nothing more than that so now first
let's understand that what does a hash
map is how to use it we will see an
example of how it is being used uh in an
actual interview and then we will learn
about hash set so hashmap as I already
mentioned that there are two properties
associated with that first one is a key
and second one is a value now let's try
to understand hashmap from a real life
point of view if you have ever seen any
kind of dictionary well typically the
dictionary is a very close example of a
hashmap where in the dictionary
typically on the first page we usually
have an index index page and in that
index page we are given the information
that uh a starts from page number one uh
something like B starts from page number
15 and so on and so forth and this is
usually sorted so if we have to find any
particular value all we need to do is go
to the index page in the index page we
can find the information that okay uh
letters starting from um M are actually
stored at page number 53 then all we
need to do is that in our dictionary or
in our book just go to page number 53
and we would be able to find the meaning
of word man or map or anything that it
would be present over there so this is
the actual idea being used in the inside
the hashmap as well where we are given
two items or we are storing two items
first item is a key and second item is a
value now key is going to be the hash
function that is a some computational
method so this is usually the hash
function we Define where the values are
being stored as keys and whenever we
need to search inside our hashmap that
whether this particular key is present
or not we can do that in B of one time
in constant time so let me give you an
example of how does this actually work
let's try to understand that we
currently have five different values
that we are trying to store and these
five values are 11 12 13 14 and 15 now
for these values I want to create a
hashmap function where I want to retrive
these data in the quickest manner
possible which means I already know that
these five are going to be my values but
I need to create keys for them and the
key I'm creating is that I create a
method where I say that any particular
value that comes in I'm just creating a
basic hash function so you would get an
idea that I create a method where any
particular value that comes in I'm going
to divide that value by five and
whatever the remainder is so the
remainder I'm going to treat it as a key
and now let's see that how would this
work so first let me draw my hashmap and
inside the hashmap I'm going to have two
values key and value so first value is
11 that I'm need I'm trying to input so
I'm going to divide 11 by 5 so 11 by 5
is going to yield me the remainder as
one I'm only concerned about the
remainder I'm not concerned that what
does the division value comes in so
remainder is going to be one so I'm
going to create a value over here where
the key is one and its Associated value
is going to be 11 same way for Value
number 12 the remainder is going to be
two so once again I have an entry two
and the value is 12 same way there is uh
for 13 we have value number three and
the value is three for 14 we have value
number four and value number uh uh 14
and the last one is the value number 15
so what should be the key for Value
number 15 well if you guessed five
that's wrong actually the key should be
zero because remainder in this case is
actually zero when you divide uh 15
divided 5 you actually get the remainder
as zero so 0o is associated with value
number 15 now I have these currently
these values being stored now let's say
in my program for some purpose I want to
check that whether in our hash map do we
all already have value number 13 or not
so what I'm going to do in this scenario
is that for Value number 13 I'm going to
uh basically divide this 13 by 5 so I'm
going to check that remainder is equal
to 3 now this remainder is actually my
key so then I would go to the hashmap
and say that hey hashmap do you have any
value where key is equal to three so
hashmap would say that yes I have key is
equal to three present but I don't know
what value is so you would say okay
bring me this value so you you fetch
this value and this value it turns out
to be 13 and then you would be able to
say that okay in my hashmap I have a
value 13 that is stored currently
present and then I can do some
competition with this now can you
identify some issues with the hash
function I have created uh let me just
draw the hash function again and
currently these are the values I have
and the associated values are 11 12 13
14 and 15 now this is currently my my
hash function okay so far it looks good
but now let's say that I'm trying to see
that does value 61 exist in in my hash
map or not so what would my Approach is
going to be once again I'm going to do
61 divid 5 and remainder is going to be
1 so once again as a remainder I'm going
to go to the hashmap and see that okay
hey for this key number one what is the
value associated with this the value
Associated right now is only 11 so I can
say that 61 is currently not present in
the hashmap once again I got this result
in big off one time but now what if it
happens that I want to add 61 to my hash
map as well well in this scenario I
since the key can only remain constant
so which means for this key 1 I have one
more entry that is 61 that I need to add
over here so in the place of value I
might I might need to create something
like a link list because there is a
collision over here of the keys because
the number of values are more and keys
are less yes so in this kind of scenario
collisions are bound to happen and
because there is a collision now I have
value number 61 let's say the value is
71 I'm trying to add so once again I
will add one more node in the link list
and I would add value number 71 over
here so so far let's assume that
initially when we only had five values
we actually had five keys and five
values so the equation was almost one to
one relation and we were able to fetch
any particular data in big of one time
but now let's assume that we still keep
only five keys and now we have uh for an
example one 1 million entries so in this
scenario or let's say 5 million entries
and five keys so mathematically every
single key would have 1 million entries
ass associated with that particular key
and in that case all of these 1 million
values would be stored in a link list uh
in the value section connect where one
node is connected with the another node
so so once again in this kind of
scenario if I have to fetch any value
now now it it's going to take big of end
time where n is going to be 1 million in
this case so this is actually really bad
so in the hash whenever you are building
your own hash map you need to make sure
that the hash function you are you are
using to build evenly distributes the
values which means that for any single
value typically the hash function tends
to be a unique set of key and that is
one of the biggest consideration now now
lucky for us most of the programming
languages like Java python or whatever
you can think of they already have this
functionality of implementing a very
good hash function that usually tends to
be unique and implements the keys in the
unique manner so we don't have to worry
about it all we need to do is just
declare the hashmap and uh we need to
declare that what type of key and value
pairs are we are going to store so we
can store like integer as the key and
string as the value and then we can name
our hash map as something like my
hashmap and then we simply need to
initialize it and that's it so this way
it's it becomes really powerful so
always make sure that even during the
interview interviewers love asking this
question that uh how do you handle
Collision in your hashmap so typically
you would assign a link list for to
store values when you predict a scenario
where there is going to be a collision
in terms of values now let's see that
what are the different operations we can
do for any given hashmap and I'm going
to store some values so let's say one is
associated with 11 and two is associated
with 12 so this is our current hash map
right now hashmap tends to be dynamic in
nature so which means that uh all the
values you want want to assign if you
want to keep on adding more and more
values in this scenario essentially you
don't have to do anything it will
usually takes care of it and most of the
languages are sophisticated enough to be
smart in that regard so that is really
good for us now first operation we can
do in hashmap is we can add a value so
typically this is done by using
something called a put variable uh and
we can put a new value inside the
hashmap and this is usually done in big
off one time where we need to provide
the value of a key and Associated value
with that remember key cannot be a null
value you can have a key uh that does
not have any value associated with that
that's fine but still key cannot be a
null value you cannot have a value that
does not have a key associated with that
in the hashmap second operation we you
can do is you can delete any value from
the hashmap and this is also done in big
off one time so that's great next
operation you can do inside the hash map
is that you can search for any element
and searching also takes big off one
time because we are using the property
of key value pair and we are searching
using the keys we are not searching
using the values so that is an important
distinction you have to understand
whenever you are trying to think that
how you're going to use hashmap to
achieve your goal next uh operation we
can do is we can actually sort all the
values but that we need to do it
sequentially so there is no inherent
method to do that so essentially this is
still big of n log n uh time operation
where you need to uh call some other
data structure and then you need to
populate all the values uh let's see
what are other operations we can do you
can of course you can modify all the
values that are currently present and
that can be done in B of one time and
that's it so now you can see that uh
hashmap on paper looks pretty good
because all the operations that you can
think of insertion deletion addition
modification uh searching sorting
they're all pretty fast and pretty
efficient uh there is one big issue with
the hashmap and that big issue is that
you cannot have duplicate keys so uh the
key value has to be unique so no
duplicate keys and also the duplicated
values would be stored under the same
key because key these are typically
generated based on based on their values
so always remember that duplicate values
cannot reside inside the hashmap and now
let's see that how does a hash set work
and then we will see an example of a
typical hashmap problem so hash set is
very similar to hashmap but the only
difference is that inside the hash set
there is no concept of key value pair it
is only just the values that are being
stored but these values are typically
stored using the hash function so uh
let's say that I currently have values 1
5 15 uh 31 and 21 uh that I need to
store so so far I have stored these four
values inside my hash uh set so I can of
course enter these values 11 15 uh 31
and five now I want to check that
whether 21 value is present inside the
hash set or not so I can check this in
big of one time why because just like a
hash map hash set also uses the hashing
function it just doesn't store the key
but still it calculates based on the
value that you are trying to input so
there is going to be a mathematical
function that operates and that would be
able to immediately identify that
whether this value has been processed
and stored inside the headset or not and
uh it's not stored so I we can add this
entry now again just like hash map hash
set also does not allow duplicates so
there is there are no duplicated entries
over here and uh one good property that
since there are no duplicated entries
allowed whenever you need to check that
in any other data structure like a link
list or um an array if any duplicated
entries exist you can actually use
hashset to solve that kind of problem
quite easily and there are many use
cases for that as well uh once again if
we look at the operation operations are
pretty much the same so uh everything
like uh adding value takes big off one
time once again deleting also takes big
of one time uh searching takes big of
one time sorting takes big of uh and log
and time so this you can usually
consider very similar to hashmap the
only difference is that in the hashmap
you can actually store the correlation
between key and value in the hash set
you only store the
value now let's try to understand couple
of examples through which we will
understand both hash map and hash set so
let's say for an example we are given
suppose an array a where we are given
five different elements and now our job
is to check that whether
uh the array contains any duplicate
element or not and if it does what is
the duplicate element so let me give you
an example suppose the values are 5 3 1
2 and 3 so we can see that three is the
duplicated element and the purpose of
our program is to check or find that
whether there is a duplicate element or
not and if it if yes then which is the
duplicated element so first let's
understand that what would be the Brute
Force approach in this scenario well it
is quite simple we just take take any
element so let's say we take element
number five in this case and then
iterate over the rest of the array to
see that whether Val value five is
present or not if it it's present we can
return true if it's not present we can
return false and go to the next element
so for three we will repeat the same
process and we would find that three is
also present in this case so we will
return return three as a duplicated
element but this approach yields the big
of n Square time complexity because for
every n element we are essentially doing
n minus one work so that is a
multiplication factor and uh which is
not too good so let's see what would be
the better solution so better solution
would be that uh if we try to sort this
given array then things would become
easier so if we sort this input we will
get an array that looks like this that 1
3 uh sorry 1 2 3 3 and 5 so in this case
uh then we only need to check the
adjacent values and here we would be
able to see that these two adjacent
values are same so we would return
return three as the answer now this
better solution where we are sorting the
array that is also bigo of n log n time
solution so could there be a better
approach and the answer is yes and that
is by using a hash set in this scenario
so what we would do is we would
initialize a hash set our algorithm
would be that we would first check that
whether any element if that is present
inside the hash set or not if it is
present already and it is also in the
array then we can consider that to be a
duplicated element if it is not present
then we would simply add that element to
our ha set so let's try to run this
method so first we would add value
number five over here because it is not
present already uh so then after adding
it we would move to the next element now
value number three is not currently
present inside the haset so we would
again repeat the same process then again
we would repeat the same process for
Value number one and again we would
repeat the same process for Value number
two and all of this insertion would take
big go of one time Plus checking that
whether the element is present or not
that would also take big off one time so
this is not any uh additional overhead
now when we are at position number three
we check that whether three is already
present inside the hash set or not
within big go of one time we would be
able to find out that three is already
present which means we would know that
three is the duplicated element and we
can return true in this case that yes
this array does contain a duplicate
element and if we are being asked to
pass on that which value is repeated we
can return three in the answer so either
case this hash set works perfectly fine
now what would be the solution in this
case or the time complexity well time
complexity is going to be biger of n
because we are going to only iterate
over the element or this array ones to
solve this problem but in this case
space complexity is also going to be
bigger of one uh bigger of n because we
need to create an additional hash Set uh
and its size is dependent on the number
on the given input now let's see that uh
this would be an example where we would
use hash set to solve the answer but now
consider a scenario that in the same
example uh we are being asked that
rather than just giving out the value of
the uh duplicated element give us the
index value so again let's see that how
would that scenario work suppose this is
the uh given new array and we need to
return the index elements of the
duplicated element how what should be
our approach once again we already know
that brute force and uh sorting approach
already works the way it does in this
scenario as well but in this case since
we need to return the index values hash
set would not be the optimal choice and
it would make sense for us to use a hash
map where inside the hash map we would
actually create a key value pair based
database where in the key we are going
to Mark these values and as their
subsequent values we are going to Mark
the index positions so when we need to
fetch that which index positions are
duplicated we can return that quite
easily so now let's see the solution in
this case so for first of all we would
check whether five is is present or not
five is currently not present inside our
hash map so we would add an entry called
five and we would add its index location
zero now again one is also not present
so we would add entry one and its index
location is one three is also not
present so three and index location two
and four is not present so four and
index location three now again this is
key value pair so you understand what
I'm doing now when we are at this
position number five or position number
four uh where the value is one we try to
add one but we already see that one is
already present because it is marked as
a key and this operation can be done in
big off one time because it's a hashmap
so since we already found that we can
actually return one uh is the duplicated
entry and if we want to return the index
positions we can return the index
position from here that would be four
and the value of this key one so that
would be one and this would be the
answer we need to return in this case so
you can understand that how quickly we
are able to solve problems using hash
map or hashset and uh we are going to
use them throughout this course for
bunch of different problems so you
should be able to understand them quite
easily now after learning most of the
basic data structures we are going to
learn couple of advanced data structures
and these Advanced data structures are
actually quite popular in technical
interviews and also a lot of
computational problems as well so there
are quite a lot of advanced data
structures but we are going to shift our
focus on two two main ones first one is
called Heap and second one is called try
now both are combination of various data
structures but they have a very specific
use cases where it is really popular and
really powerful so first let's
understand that what a heap is Heap is
typically an extraction of a binary uh
tree tree based data structure where it
it maintains the property of a binary
tree which means any single node has at
most two children and it tries to
balance out this property as quickly as
possible and even if there is an anomaly
it would only be at one of the positions
where the number of children would be
one but nothing more than that so you
would never encounter a scenario where
any single node has three children or
something like that so after that there
is also one more important property for
a heap and that is that it is a common
implementation for a typical priority
Cube and we all know that in a priority
Cube the most important thing is higher
or lower priority depending on that so
in the Heap usually we use it to keep
track of uh the maximum value out of any
given incoming data stream or the
minimum value of uh any incoming data
stream and both have very significant
purposes and very significant importance
in many of the questions so first let's
try to understand that how does a
typical Heap looks like how does it work
and then we will see some examples so
first we will try to implement a minimum
Heap now the property of a minimum he
Heap is that number one it is going to
maintain the binary tree nature so one
node is going to have at most two
children number two is that every single
parent is going to have less value than
its child and number three property is
that all the nodes that we would try to
enter first we would enter in the root
position if the root is already filled
we would try to enter that node into the
leftmost position if that is also filled
then we would try to enter that node as
a right child for any particular empty
location so we would try to find the
location first once that is done we
would sort of heapify the given input or
the our given Heap to maintain this
property so let's see this in action
suppose uh currently we have an empty
Heap so let me draw an empty circle and
now let's assume that the first value we
are trying to enter is going to be value
number five so initially we are entering
value number five over here now the next
value we try to enter let's assume that
that is value number 10 so remember the
scenario is first we will try to add it
to the root value root we already have
added which means we will try to add in
the left children so let's add the
number 10 in the left child and after
adding that we need to check that
whether this property has been
maintained or not that whether the
parents value is less than the children
value or not and in this case since five
is the parent it is less than 10 so this
is currently correct so we do not need
to do he operation for this step now
let's see one more element so suppose we
try to enter value number 15 now again
15 needs to go to uh either root place
but root is already filled so it needs
to go to left that is also filled so it
will go to the right place and right
place after adding 15 we would again
check that whether the he5 property is
maintained so again parents is still
smaller than children so that is good
now let's try to enter the value number
25 so once again 25 will go go to the
left position and so far everything
seems to be working okay no issues with
this now let's try to enter the value
number seven now again by this logic
first of all seven has to enter to the
right available position so this is not
available this is not available but this
position is available so let me enter
seven over here but does there an issue
with parents being lesser than child yes
there is in this case seven is smaller
than uh value number 10 so we would have
to do the he5 operation so we would move
seven from here and we would make it as
parent and 10 would come to this place
okay now everything is good so far now
let's say that we try to enter value
number 31 once again 31 would be entered
over here and the property is still
maintained now let's try to enter value
number two so by default value number
two is going to come over here but since
two is smaller we will have to make a
shift over here so let me quickly shift
the values so now 2 is going to come and
15 is going to come over here once again
two is still smaller so once again we
will have to do a shifting operation so
in the end two is going to come over
here and five is going to come over here
and now the Heap has been maintained so
this is how typical Heap operates now in
this case if you see always the parent
is going to be smaller than its children
so currently for the entire Heap we have
the smallest value POS positioned at the
root position so this is whenever if we
have to identify that hey we have an
incoming constant data stream that is
coming in and we want to find that what
is the minimum value at all times we can
actually use Heap because it's a self
adjusting uh algorithm or data structure
that maintains its property of whether a
Min Heap or Max Heap so in this case we
can identify that okay the minimum value
is going to be the value at our very
first node and maximum value is going to
be some value amongst the these Leaf
node so in this case maximum is going to
be 31 but we are not bothered about it
right now now once again if we take any
subtree so let's say in this case once
again parent is still going to be
smaller than child once again parent is
still going to be smaller than children
so Heap is a great algorithm whenever
you need to keep track of that hey I
have an continuous incoming stream of
data coming in and I want to check the
fifth smallest value from the beginning
so in that that case Heap would be an
ideal choice where you keep track of all
the values in a Min Heap and then you
essentially needs to go and select the
fifth smallest value which can be done
in log and time so that's great you will
get the answers quite quickly now let's
see an example for a Max Heap and Max
Heap also works in the similar fashion
the only difference is that now the
value of parent has to be greater than
the value of child so let's see that
first we are try we have the element and
we are trying to add value number two
over here now the next element we are
trying to add is value number three so
in this case we will have to do an
adjustment so first we will add three
over here and then we will do our HEI so
we would adjust the values so now three
would be the maximum value and two would
be the smallest value now we are trying
to add value number 15 once again first
we will add 15 over here but then again
we will do the hepy principle and we
will flip the values so 15 will become
over here and three will come over here
now we want to add value number five so
by default five would be added over here
but once again we are going to do over
ep5 operation so according to that logic
five will come over here and two will
come over here and same way we can
maintain a Max Heap as well so in this
case whenever you would see the root
node is going to be the maximum element
at any given location for any particular
subtree the parent is always going to be
greater than child and Heap is going to
Bubble Up and maintain its Max Heap
property so this is how typically we use
Heap in order to keep track of min
minimum value or maximum value at any
given moment on top of that we also keep
track to for any questions like find the
K largest value or k smallest value from
the top so in either case the Min Heap
and Max Heap or are going to be the
ideal choice to solve these kind of
problems and we would see bunch of
operations later on in the course so now
let's try to see that what are going to
be the time and space complexity so
ially the time complexity in order to
insert any element inside the Heap is
actually big go of logarithmic n why log
n because it is already a sorted tree
structure whenever we try to enter any
value in any particular location we
simply need to find that what would be
the right place for it to be so at most
all we need to do is make change to
couple of places and then we can
actually find its correct location so
insert insertion is login same way
deletion is also login same way finding
anything is also login so this is a very
powerful and very fast data structure uh
from many point of you and that is why
it has lot of use cases in the real
world scenarios so this is the example
of Heap now let's try to understand that
what does a TR data structure looks like
now try is also uh an additional
abbreviation of a tree based data
structure now inside the try uh we
actually use try on a daily basis so
whenever you see any system that uses
autocorrect functionality so that is
actually using a try so this covers your
iPhone Android phone your messaging app
anything plus wherever you see
predictive searches so what do I mean by
predictive search uh you can imagine
that whenever you try to search anything
on the Google or Amazon it automatically
completes the statement for you and for
that actually behind the scenes it is
using try as a data structure so try is
a very powerful tool since you can see
that it has lot of practical
applications and also remains favorite
amongst technical interviews as well so
that is why we are going to understand
what a try is basically try typically
operates on a string based characters so
wherever you have bunch of different
characters that you that you working
with and you want to store them in a
sequential manner where depending on the
values you enter in the character You
can predict the next element you can
actually use a try so how does a try
typically work is typically it has a
root node and this root node tends to be
an empty node but in its children we are
going to store all the uh alphabets that
are possible so typically in a real life
try there would be 26 children one for
each character from a to zed but in this
case let's just let's just consider our
example small and concise so we would
try to add five different words to our
try and we would see how they they would
look look like so first word we are
going to add is going to be the word rat
second word is going to be R third word
is going to be uh
men and fourth word we would be uh let's
say tree and fifth word would be uh try
so these are the words we are trying to
add first so let's just start with first
one so first we will try to add R so we
are going to create a child over here
called r then the next word is a so
again R is going to have a sub child
called a and next word is t so T is
going to going to be the child of a and
now since this word has ended so now
this is going to be an end node so we
can determine this as a star or
something okay that defines that this
word currently ended over here now next
word we are trying to add is R so once
again from our root node we are not
creating we are not going to create a
separate child for R we are actually
going to create a r as it as it is and
then we are going to create a sub Branch
so this R has already been taken care of
now there is the word a so once again
for a we are not going to create a new
Branch but we are going to treat this R
A to be of the same group so now you can
see that how different words can be
stored within a tree like data structure
by their character properties because
they are all connected with each other
very deeply and next one is p but over
here the next word is actually T so in
this case we are going to create a new
Branch over here and this new branch is
going to have value number P and since
the word ends over here we are going to
have an ending node so that is denoted
by star so now whenever I start typing r
a uh the system would come over here and
then system would predict that either
I'm typing r a rep or r a rat and then
that is how it is able to do a
predictive search let's say that I print
uh I type something like r a r rare but
the system knows that rare is not a
valid word which means system would
predict that either the valid word has
to be r or R so depending on the con uh
context of the entire statement you are
trying to make it will automatically
adjust the word that you are writing and
over here it would from this it might
autoc correct it to the word rat and uh
things would work fine so this is how
typically autocorrect functionality
works now let's try to add the word man
over here now for M there is no child so
we are going to create a new child and
once again we are going to create a new
child and we are going to create a new
child and then we are going to create an
end node so this is how men would look
like now let's try to create the word
tree so once again for tree uh we do not
have any child so let's create a new
branch and we are going to start with
word t now next one is r and next one is
e and next one is going to be e and then
there is an end node but now let's try
to add one more word try t r i e so we
can already see for T and R it is going
to have the same path or same Branch but
now it is going to have a separate
branch called I and then it is going to
have a separate branch called e and then
it would end the word essentially so
this is how using just these three
branches we can actually navigate all of
these five uh words
so this is the true power of the TR data
structure and uh try is pretty popular
in lot of technical interviews and
wherever you see the example where you
are given bunch of different words and
you are trying to find some meaning and
you are trying to find the best way on
how to process them and how to store
them try to consider or thinking of
using the the data structure try and
once again for try later in the course
we are going to see an example so things
would become much more more clear so I
hope that you got the idea about
Advanced data structures of Max Heap Min
Heap and tribe and now let's move
forward so first of all I would like to
congratulate all of you for making up
until this far uh we have cross the
biggest hurdle in our technical
interview preparation journey and that
is learning about all the popular data
structures I hope that you must have
good enough understanding of each one of
them and now we are going to shift our
Focus towards algorithms which is not so
complicated as data structures were but
needless to say they are quite important
so I hope you give your utmost attention
to this portion because once you
understand algorithms things will become
much more easier for you to proceed for
the subsequent
parts now one of the most important
thing that you have to master in order
to master any technical interview is to
understand that what are the different
algorithms available to you and what are
typical coding patterns that you need to
to recognize but before we start diving
deep into it first let's understand that
what does algorithm mean algorithm is
nothing but a simple set of procedure a
computer or a program needs to follow in
order to generate some solution so let's
say that this is the problem statement
given you need to follow a certain steps
in a certain sequence in order to
generate the results and there are many
different techniques to that that we
will tackle in this uh portion so
following that would generate the
unnecessary output that you looking for
and understanding that what are the
options available to you is going to be
a significant key for your Tech
preparation Journey now what is coding
patterns let me give you an example
suppose if I write down uh few words
over here let's say 2 4 6 can you
predict what is going to be the next
alphabet or next character I'm going to
write over here of course you can
predict that I'm going to write eight
why because by looking at this you
understood that this makes the next
logic sequential sound move and this is
what we need to do in terms of technical
interviews as well that depending on the
problem statement we should get some
idea that hey in this type of scenario
it would make sense to use a data
structure like an array and in the array
we are going to apply maybe sorting and
then with the Sorting we are maybe going
to apply uh binary search and this would
yield us the correct result but we need
to understand this type of pattern and
this can only be done if we examine many
questions of a similar type and then
understand or refer meaning to that so
combination of algorithms and coding
patterns are closely related with each
other and you do that in tandem with
data structures and that's it these are
the three building blocks for any
efficient data structure algorithm
technical interview and uh we are going
to take care of it so these are all the
different techniques that we are going
to cover so first of all we are going to
cover the searching algorithm and
sorting algorithm then one of my
favorite topics that is dynamic
programming and recursion so after that
we are going to see bunch of different
tree and graph algorithms and these are
really popular because there are some
very practical real life applications
completely built upon the concepts of
tree and graph algorithms then we we
will see some greedy algorithms and
backtracking techniques and in the end
we would start talking about the divide
and conquer sliding window two pointers
and interval coding patterns so this
would cover most of the topics that you
can think of for any technical interview
and once you understand this you would
essentially able to master all the
problems that you are facing so without
any further Ado let's just get started
and uh for each and every concept I will
explain the concept first then I'll show
you either one or two examples depending
on how complex the problem is and we
will solve that problem before moving
forward to the next one so completing
this would be one of the most important
key factors for this uh
course so first let's try to understand
the searching algorithm Now searching
algorithms are pretty common across data
structure and algorithm related problems
because at any given moment we need to
find some elements from a variety of
data structures and these data
structures can be an array or something
like a St or a CU and it on top of it
there can be some other more complicated
data structures uh maybe something like
a hash or a tree or a graph so
essentially for any given data structure
you might be asked to search some data
from that and typically we follow two
main techniques so number one technique
is a linear search and linear search is
uh as the name suggest it's quite simple
essentially you jump from one node to
another node to another node until you
find the element that you are looking
for and the moment you find the element
you simply return that search element so
if we have to understand it with an
example suppose we are given an array
and inside our array the values are
randomly jumbled up something like 4 3 1
7 and 8 now I ask you that hey go ahead
and search for Value number eight the
approach is going to be that we are
going to jump through all of these
values until we reach to Value number
eight and the moment we reach we can say
that okay this eight is located at index
number number four or on the fifth
position or we can simply say that yes
eight is present currently in this array
in either case linear search would work
just fine and if we see time complexity
for a linear search it's typically going
to be biger of n usually whenever you
are dealing with data structures like
link list or even Q or stack typically
you are going to deal on the linear
search basis because that is the only
way you can access data uh and if there
are some additional versions of maybe Q
something like a Min Heap or Max Heap in
that case you can actually find the
value you are looking for in little bit
simpler manner but still essentially
linear search you are always going to
encounter uh in whatever you are trying
to do next example uh for a searching is
actually a binary search and binary
search is quite powerful but it has some
predefined condition associated with
that and that condition is that whenever
you are trying to use a binary search
the condition is that the data set has
to be sorted so it needs to be either a
sorted array or let's say a binary
search tree something like that where
you can actually apply the concept or
the principle of binary search and
principle is actually quite simple say
for an example we are given bunch of
different elements over here uh and they
are all sorted in a particular fashion
so 1 3 11 15 19 and 27 these are the
values we are currently present let me
just add one more element somewhere so
value number four okay so currently we
are given Seven Elements inside this
array now I ask you that for this array
can you go ahead and find me value
number 15 what would be your approach
well of course you always have the
option to go linearly and search for
each and every value individually till
you find the value you are looking for
but since this is already a sorted
property it makes sense to use the
binary search approach where first we
are going to find the middle element the
middle element in this case is going to
be value number 11 now we know that
since this array is sorted we are
guaranteed that if 15 exist it has to
exist within this portion and there it
it is not possible that it lies within
these values so we can essentially get
rid of all of these inputs and only
focus our effort for this remaining
portion now once again for this
remaining portion again we will try to
find the middle pointer and middle
pointer in this case is going to be 19
which means once again again we can
eliminate these two values because all
the values are going to be either 19 or
greater than 19 and in either case it is
not going to be 15 so we are only left
with one element in this case and that
is value number 15 we which we can
return so only in three itations we were
able to find the our answer we are
looking for in an array of uh seven
total elements basically the binary
search actually operates in bigo of log
n time and this logarithmic time
complexity is what makes it viable so
this is what how you can understand
searching algorithm and you are going to
see them quite a lot in lot of different
problems you are trying to
solve now before we start understanding
the example for searching algorithm
let's try to understand sorting first
and then combination of searching and
sorting would would be what we would use
to understand one of the actual data
structure and algorithm Rel related
examples so let's try to understand
sorting first now sorting as the name
suggest uh it is the procedure to sort
all the given data in some particular
fashion it could be whether all the data
you are trying to sort in an increasing
order or reverse could be true that you
are trying to sort everything in the
decreasing order or you are trying to
sort everything based on the colors that
you are provided or the names or
alphabets in either case you are trying
to bring an ordered list and sorting can
apply to most of the data uh most of the
data structures like arrays and uh link
list and trees and graphs but mostly you
are going to typically use it on the
arrays that's what I have observed by
solving bunch of different problems so
even to understand the Sorting let's try
to see some examples from array suppose
we are given an unsorted array and the
values currently are 2 3 1 7 and 8 okay
now in this unsorted array if we trying
to sort it how can we do it well
actually sort there are multiple
techniques we can use in order to sort
the data and one of the in inefficient
approach is actually something called
bubble sort now bubble sort is typically
where you compare any two elements and
try to see that whether those two
elements are in correct order or not and
if they're not you swap those two
elements and then go to the next element
and you keep on repeating this process
until all the elements are sorted so so
if we have to see that in example we can
see something like this where we okay we
check two and three they are already in
the correct order so we will leave them
for now then we will compare 3 to 1 So
currently 3: 1 is not in correct order
so we will bring one over here and three
over here and leave 7 and 8 as it is now
once again we would compare these two
elements So currently one and two are
not in correct order so we will add one
over here two over here three over here
and then seven and 8 once again we would
repeat the same procedure so one and two
are correct order two and three are
correct order and three and seven are
Cor in correct order and same same goes
for seven and 8 so in this case all the
elements are now in correct order which
means we can return this as sorted array
and uh we use the bubble sort method but
the issue with the bubble sort method is
that it takes big of n Square time
because it could be possible that for
every single element you need to keep on
uh Shifting the places and that could be
pretty bad so one better approach is
actually something called uh M sort or
there is also a quick sort so let me
give you the better faster sorting
approach once again let's assume that we
are given some random array and we are
trying to sort this now we only have
four elements so a better approach is
that we actually create an entirely new
array and currently this new array is
blank so what we would do is we would
add all the values in the sorted Manner
and whenever we have to identify that
where any new value should go we would
use binary search in order to find the
correct location for that place to be
entered and we all know that binary
search operates in log and time so
essentially our code should run in N log
and time why because we will have to do
the log and operation for every single
element that is currently present inside
our given input array So currently let's
try to see for Value number one so
currently this is empty so we will add
one just anywhere now five for five we
can we need to check that where five
needs to added and five is greater than
one so it has to be added on the right
side of one so we will add five over
here once again for Value number two uh
let's see where it needs to be added now
since 2 is greater than 1 it needs to be
added on the right side of one but it
needs to be added on the left side of
five and this we can calculate quite
easily using binary search that which
should be the correct position for two
to be entered so in this case we can
enter two over here and then five we can
shift on one position to the right and
this whole operation would take
logarithmic of end time once again for
Value number eight we will repeat the
same procedure and we can find that uh
the ideal place for eight is going to be
here on the very end and in the end we
would get our sorted array now this
sorted portion looks quite good and we
were able to achieve this whole thing in
N log n time which is quite nice so
whenever you are trying to deal with uh
any operations try to see that can you
use searching and sorting to solve this
problem and combination of these two
would ultimately yield you better
results because if you can do any
operation on an unsorted array for bigo
of n Square time then same operation can
be done using n log and time uh if you
just simply sort this that given input
array so that is a huge Advantage now
let's try to see one real example from a
problems uh with from the lead
code
okay so now let's try to understand this
problem that is how many numbers are
smaller than the current number the
problem is really easy to understand uh
we are given an input array and we need
to create another array where for every
single position inside the original
array we need to determine that how many
number of elements are smaller than that
particular value so in this case for
four we can see that there are actually
two elements that are smaller than four
so in the answer we are going to mark
two same way for three there is only one
element that is smaller than three so we
are going to mark one for five there are
actually three elements smaller than
five so we are going to mark three as
the answer and zero is the smallest
element so in this case we can Mark
there are zero elements that are smaller
than zero and this would be the answer
we need to return now this is actually
quite simple to understand let's see
that what would be the Brute Force
approach to solve this problem well in
The Brute Force approach the most
simplest thing we can do is that rather
than uh doing anything else we can
simply start checking one element one by
one so we first make a pair from four to
three and we check okay that this is
smaller so we increment the value by one
once again we make a pair of four to
five We compare these two value since
five is bigger we don't do anything then
we check one more time and then since 0
is less than four so once again we add
one more increment and the answer we
store in the answer that for zero there
are two elements that are smaller than
that and we keep on repeating the same
process so this Pro Force approach would
yield as the solution in bigo of n
Square time because for every single n
element we are doing n minus one work so
this is not really good so let's try to
see that what should be the better
approach and one of a very easy
approaches that actually if we take the
same input as it is but we if we sort
that input then the answer is going to
become quite easy so the answer is 4 3 5
and 0 now in this case we need to return
that how many many number are smaller
than that so first let's see that what
does a sorted array looks like and in
this case it's going to be0 3 4 and 5
now at any given position in the sorted
array defines that how many values are
actually smaller than that so in the
case of zero there are actually zero
values smaller than that same way for
the case of three there is one value
smaller than that and that value is zero
for four there are two values smaller
than that and that is two and for five
all three values are zero so we can use
this property to calculate that uh or to
generate this array but how we need to
do that uh we actually need to know the
index location for all of these and then
Mark appropriate value so for four we
need to enter answer two but we there is
one simple way to do it that is that uh
for four we first iterate over this
given sorted are and find the value and
then again repeat the same work but that
would be an additional overhead a better
approach is to use a hashmap here so
after we generate the sorted array we
can put all of its values as keys and
all the index positions as values inside
the hashmap and then uh we can use that
property to to populate our answer quite
easily so in this case 0 is going to
have zero value three as key is going to
have value number one four S key is
going to have value number two and five
s key is going to value number three now
all we need to do is from our example
array let me get rid of this for now and
now all we need to do is from our
example array we will first iterate over
this value number four try to see that
which is the value associated with this
value number four create an answer array
and in the answer array just Mark that
value same way for Value number three
again check in the hash map and the
associated value is value number one
again for five Associated value is value
number three and for 0 Associated value
is zero and this would give us the
correct answer we are looking for in the
simplest manner so now let's see that
what is going to be the time and space
complexity in this case the time
complexity is going to be big of n log n
in order to generate the sorted
algorithm or sorted array plus we have
to do big of n work in order to generate
this answer from this example by
comparing this hashmap so that is pretty
good so overall time complexity is going
to be big of n log n now let's see that
what is going to be the space complexity
well of course since we are using an
additional hashmap the space complexity
is going to be bigger of n but that is
still reasonable because we are saving
uh quite some computation in the time
complexity so now you must understand
that how we are actually using sorting
and then we are using searching plus we
are using the capabilities of hashmap
and everything is connected with arrays
in order to generate one answer and this
is is how typically data structure and
algorithm related videos or uh problems
are done so now let's see the coding
solution okay so let's see that what is
going to be the Java solution for this
problem basically we are given an
integer array called nums so first thing
we are going to do is we are going to
create another array and we are going to
uh sort it so this is the sorted array
and now we are going to create a hash
map uh where inside this hash map we are
going to Mark the indexes values for all
the elements that we have in the sorted
array so it becomes really easy for us
to navigate and generate the results for
our original array then all we need to
do is initialize another array where we
are going to store the results plus we
are going to run a for loop on the
original input array and we are going to
uh check that what is the result from
the hashmap for that particular uh key
value and uh we populate the values
inside our result array and we get the
answer let's try to run this
code and our code runs pretty
efficiently so let's submit this
code and our code runs actually very
fast compared to lot of other Solutions
so this how you can understand what are
the powers of sorting storing and
hashing and combine combining lot of
data structures and to generate a
solution now we will try to understand a
very important topic that is called
recursion recursion is highly used in
many of the data structure and algorithm
related problems plus there are many
algorithms and many programming
techniques that are heavily dependent on
recursion to solve the problem so
recursion is actually a method that we
can typically use uh in order to
complete any set of task where we
usually see some sort of repeative work
that needs to be done for a various set
of uh different inputs and essentially
we need to collect the results of the
them to generate an answer now let me
explain you recursion by a real life
scenario first and then we will talk
about what it is it and how do we
actually use it in our typical technical
interviews say for an example you are
currently standing on a line and you
don't know that how many number of
people are currently in front of you so
all you can see is that there are bunch
of different people ahead of you but you
have no idea and currently this is the
person who is the very first person in
the line now you decide that you want to
check that what is your position inside
the current line so the one approach is
that you get out of the line and then
you start counting all the people that
are in between and then you try to come
back to the line but there are more
people behind you so if you get out you
will essentially lose your place so
there is one more way when you can
identify that what is your current
position that is that first you ask the
person ahead of you that hey what is
your position now again the person ahead
of you also has no idea so he repeats
the same position that hey what is your
position and this question keeps going
on and on and on until we reach to the
very first person and because this very
first person already knows what is his
or her position is this person would say
that hey my position is one which means
this person would understand that his
position has to be second second
position so then he would respond back
to the person behind him and this person
would understand that his position is
now the third position same with this
person will conclude that his position
must be fourth position because this
person is at third position and same
with this person is at fifth position
and he tells you that hey I am on the
fifth position which means you can
conclude that your position has to be
the sixth position in the current line
now what you essentially did is you made
a recursive call and you get the desired
answer you were looking for and you ask
the same question to a different set of
input results until you f reached to a
place who knew the answer and depending
on that answer you started building all
the other answers and that's it that's
the recursion now I know at first it
seems complicated to comprehend but if
you try to understand with real life
examples things would become much more
easier let me give you one analogy
that how it typically appears have you
ever seen those Russian dolls that uh
whenever you open one doll and then uh
inside that doll there is another doll
hanging and inside that there is another
doll and it keeps on happening over and
over for all the different shapes of
dolls so the same concept applies for
the recursion as well that behind any
big problem or behind solution of any
big problem lies the solution of a
smaller problem plus plus some
computation same way for even for that
smaller problem there lies some other
computation and same goes on and on
until we reach to a base case where in
the base case we directly know that what
is going to be the solution for that
particular case and apart from that from
that we would build this solution and
then we would build the other solution
and we would keep on repeating the
process again and again and again let's
try to see that what are the things or
areas of concern for us in any
particular recurs
so every single recursion has two items
first item is that uh recursive function
and this recursive the purpose of this
recursive function is to call the next
sequence or next input in line in order
to get the answer so first one is a
recursive function and second one is a
base case so base case is a scenario
where we know that this has to be the
answer or this has to be the minimum
answer now uh again going back to to our
uh people standing in a q position the
person standing very at the very first
po position in the line knew that he was
the first person in the line and this
was basically our base case now our what
was our recursive function in this case
in our recursive function the case was
to ask the next person that hey what is
your position and keep on asking that to
the next person and the moment we get an
answer from the base case we need to
return to the previous person that hey
whatever the answer we get from the next
element or the base case we need to add
one to that so here base case would say
that hey I'm first person so this person
would say back to the back to his
previous person so person who called
originally this person he would respond
back saying that hey I second I'm in
second position same way this person
would say I'm third position and so on
and so forth the recursive call would
keep on coming back until we reached to
a point who originally called or
initiated that recursive call recursions
are very powerful and they are used in
bunch of different data structures in
many programming techniques data
structures such as uh typical tree or
graphs plus programming techniques like
dynamic programming and also many of the
Matrix manipulation all of this are
heavily using recursion to solve their
uh problem because typically in all of
these problems we need to do the same
computation again and again for
different set of inputs and whenever we
see things like that we have to try to
see that can we solve this problem using
recursion now there is also one more
thing that you need to understand that
any problem you can solve recursively
you can also say solve the same problem
iterative iteratively but the question
is recursive solution is going to be
typically very simple to implement so
you can think of it like a simple manner
just like asking a question again going
back to our people standing in the line
scenario you could have gone out of the
line and calculated all of these values
one by one by yourself but why did you
decide it not to do and you just decided
to ask to the next person because
repetitively you can ask this question
again and again and you can expect to
get an answer coming back in return so
that is how if you would have gone out
and calculated all of this by yourself
it would have been an iterative approach
and if you would have stood in the line
and waited for the result come back to
you it would be recursive approach but
there is a key difference between
iterative and recursive that in the
iterative approach memory is not being
used that much why because in this case
you are the only person calculating that
how many number of people are there
currently present in the line and then
they can you can infer the result that
you're looking for but in our recursive
approach we are dependent on every
single person to know that what is the
position of other person and then adding
one line to it and sending back the
results which means we are actually
creating a memory stack where we are
keeping track of all the memories that
actually called us back so all the
places where we called we are placing
their uh line in the stack and when we
get the result we fetch these values out
one by one because remember the property
of a stack is last and first out so we
get these values out and then we in the
end conclude the answer so whenever
you're dealing with recursion make sure
that uh memory usage is not so
significant that you actually end up in
uh stack Overflow issue now let's try to
understand a program programming uh
example for recursion and that is
something called a Fibonacci series now
we all know what a Fibonacci series is
Fibonacci series is basically the sum of
two numbers now let me give an example
initially so let's say that first value
of Fibonacci series is Fibonacci of zero
so that is going to be the value number
zero second is Fibonacci of 1 Fibonacci
of one is going to be value number one
now if we have to calculate Fibonacci of
2 we will actually have to do the sum of
these two values and that will give us
the answer of fibon 2 so Fibonacci of 2
is actually Fibonacci of 0 plus
Fibonacci of 1 so the answer is going to
be 1 once again Fibonacci of 3 is
actually the sum of previous two
elements so Fibonacci of 2 plus fibon
Fibonacci of 1 so the answer answer is
once again going to be value number two
same way Fibonacci of 4 is sum of
previous two elements so Fibonacci of 3
plus Fibonacci of 2 and the answer is
going to be value number three and this
keeps on going on and on until whatever
the value we are trying to find we get
the answer so now in this case this is a
very good candidate if you want to
implement the solution recursively and
how would the recursive function would
work well we know that for recursion we
need two things we need our base case
and base case is lying right in front of
our eyes that is that uh the Fibonacci
of 0o is zero and Fibonacci of 1 is 1
now we need a recursive function and
recursive function is also in place that
fibon of any number is actually
Fibonacci of number minus one plus
Fibonacci of number minus 2 and you can
apply it to anywhere so Fibonacci of 2
is going to be Fibonacci of Z or
Fibonacci of 1 same way Fibonacci of 3
is going to be sum of Fibonacci of 2 and
ion of 1 so this function applies which
means we got our recursive function and
we also got our base case so now to
calculate any result is going to be very
easy for us okay so let's say that I'm
trying to find the Fibonacci numbers and
I try to find the Fibonacci number of
Fibonacci value number four so first
let's see that what is going to be the
recursive approach well first of all in
the recursive approach we know that what
is the recursive function for Fibonacci
of 4 recursive function is Fibonacci of
3 plus Fibonacci of 2 now we all know
that what is the answer for Fibonacci of
3 that is Fibonacci of 2 plus Fibonacci
of 1 now we know the value of Fibonacci
of 1 but we do not know the value of
Fibonacci of 2 so once again even in
order to get this value we are going to
do Fibonacci of 1 plus Fibonacci of 0
and we know these two values so sum of
these two values is going to be 1 + 0 so
the value is going to be 1 so this is
going to return us the answer
as one so we get the value of one so in
this case currently the Fibonacci of 2
is going to be of value number one and
Fibonacci of 1 is already value number
one so 1 + 1 is going to yield us the
result of three now we got the answer
three in this case now for Fibonacci of
two we again need to do the same
computation and that is Fibonacci of 1
plus Fibonacci of 0o now we don't know
we already know the values of fibon 1
and Fibonacci of zero and that is going
to be some is equal to 1 so this is also
going to be one so in this case
currently the value of Fibonacci of
three is going to be okay this is not
going to be three this is going to be
two I think I Mis wrote this this is
going to be two so Fibonacci of three is
going to be two and Fibonacci of 2 is
going to be 1 so the answer for
Fibonacci of 4 is going to be three okay
so we got the recursive answer now you
see what you did what we did in this
case we took the larger case and then we
started breaking down into the smaller
pieces and even for those smaller pieces
we started breaking down into sub
smaller pieces until we reach to a point
where we are at the base case and
through the base case we found the
solution we return those solution to our
previous calls and then we kept on
repeating the process until we find to
the main value we were looking for now
what are the things we had to take care
of we had to take care of base case we
had to take care of the recursive
function and we had to take care of the
memory call back because this function
is calling back to Fibonacci of 2 this
function is calling back to Fibonacci of
3 same way this function is calling back
to Fibonacci of 2 and we are getting the
answer but at least as long as we are
getting the answer now for the same
problem let's try to do it iteratively
so in the iteratively we are trying to
find Fibonacci of 4 so obviously The
Logical approaches that we are going to
start with Fibonacci of 0 and Fibonacci
of 0 is already Zer Fibonacci of 1 is
already 1 now we are going to calculate
Fibonacci of 2 that is going to be sum
of 0 + 1 so that is going to be 1 okay
so this Fibonacci of 3 is going to be
value two and then we can calculate
Fibonacci of four that is going to be
value three and we will also get the
same answer now in this case in the
iterative approach we started from the
bottom and reach all the way to the
value we were looking for in the
recursive approach we started from the
value we were looking for started asking
and went to the base case and then came
back again for the previous case so this
is one common way to implement recursion
now you are going to see quite a lot of
examples whenever you are trying to
prepare for any technical interviews
because recursion are one of the most
commonly widely used programming
techniques now we are going to learn the
most important topic inside the Entire
Computer Science in my opinion and
specifically for the technical
interviews because if you are applying
for any Tech interview for sure you are
going to be asked some questions related
to dynamic programming so let's first
understand that what dynamic programming
is what are the different variations
associated with that and then we are
going to explore bunch of different
examples so you can get the complete
idea on how dynamic programming Works
basically dynamic programming is nothing
but the art of saving the data that we
have already computed and then reuse
that data for some future computation
that's it uh now let's try to understand
this with an example suppose we have a
map like this where we are given bunch
of different places or points and we we
we are trying to go from one city to
another city now in this case currently
we have all of these variations and we
are trying to get to a city number F now
uh each of this path we can assume that
they are let's say 1 km long on top of
this from a we have some path directly
leading to seat that is also 1 km long
and from C we have one path that that is
directly leading to e and that is also 1
km long and now the aim is to get to
City number f
Now The Logical conclusion is that most
common bro Force approach would be that
we start from City number a and we
explore every single path and for each
of the path we calculated that how much
kilometers or how many kilometers did it
took so we would first calculate a
result for a path like this then we
would calculate a result for a path like
this this this and this and then in the
end we would calculate the result for a
path like this and we would find the
answer but the question is uh is this
the most approp rate approach to reach
over here because we are repeating so
many competitions here we already
calculated for this portion and this
portion and we are actually calculating
it two times uh in order to generate the
result one better approach is that we
actually use dynamic programming to
store the already calculated path and
how we are going to do it typically in
dynamic programming there are two
approaches first approach is a bottom up
approach where you start from the base
case or the very first case and try to
build a solution that would eventually
lead us to the final result we are
trying to get to so that is one way
second approach is a top down approach
where in the top down approach you start
at the very end or at the very top and
then you build smaller and smaller
Solutions and try to come up or try to
reach to the first point and then try to
build a path in this manner now of
course both of this are going to look
quite similar uh compared in regards to
the previous example we C for recursion
because the top down approach is
actually used by done by doing recurs
recursive calculation and bottom up
approach is typically done by using an
iterative solution where we are storing
the data of all the things calculated
and that is a common factor we are going
to store the result of already
calculating calculated the data and we
are going to use it for our next
computation so let's try to see an
example in this case the approach I am
suggesting is that we start from F in
this case and we try to go in the
reverse order to find the best path
suited path so the question is in order
to get to the F what is the nearest
point that leads us to Value number F
and that is going to be value number e
that say somehow if we get to Value
number e we can reach to F in just 1 km
so we can say that distance from E to F
is going to be 1 one okay that's good
now uh in order to get to e what are
different options we have so first let's
explore all of them so let's say that we
are currently at position number D if we
are at D we if we need to get to F we
have this path where we are going to go
from D to e and then e to F so in this
case if you are if we are at D do we
need to calculate this whole path from
going to e and then again going from E
to F no why because we already know that
that once we get to e we can directly go
to F with this effort so we are going to
save our computation and we are only
going to calculate that okay from D if I
get to e using one e using one step then
from E to F distance is already one so I
can say that from d i if I take two
jumps or if I go travel 2 kilm I can go
to the value F that's awesome now once
again let's repeat the same computation
now we are at position position number c
so from C how many options we have one
option we have is that from C if we go
to D we already know that from D to F is
already 2 km so and from C to D it takes
us 1 km so if we were to take this path
from C to D then we don't care how many
number of hops it has to take all we
consider is that from C to D if we go
there then within 3 km we would be able
to reach to our final destination F so
in this scenario we are not even going
to bother checking for this path from E
to F we are only consider the path
between C to D and which is the true
power of dynamic programming so now in
this case we are actually we can say
that from C if we take 3 km we would be
able to get to D but at C we have one
more option and that option is that if
somehow we can go from C to e then at
location e we can only travel 1 km and
get to F so in this case now at C we
have a path from C to D that takes us uh
3 km time and we have a path from C to e
that takes us 2 km time and we are
trying to find the minimum uh time it
takes or minimum travel it takes to get
to e so we can see that at C if we
somehow end up at position number c then
we can actually reach to F within 2 km
so we are going to Mark the value of C
S2 and then we are going to repeat the
same process so now from B if we somehow
end up at C
we would be able to get to F within 2 km
and from B to C it takes 1 km to get
there so we can see that at B it takes 3
km to get to F same way from a if we go
to B it takes us 3 km plus 1 km so 4 km
to get there but if we from a go to C
then it only takes 3 km so we can say
that the minimum amount of time it takes
from us to go from a to F would be 3 km
and this is how we build the solution by
already calculating the previously
computed results and in this case we
actually use a top down approach where
we started from the top and we kept
going in the reverse order and we can
actually have a recursive function call
to find the solution in the recursive
function the base case is going to be
that if we are located at position
number e it only takes us 1 km to get
there and then uh the solution would be
that we need to check that how can we
get to that next location in the minimum
amount of hop so that's pretty awesome
actually now let's see some other
examples on how would a dynamic
programming would work now previous
example we saw that how does a recursive
function work for a Fibonacci numbers
now once again we are going to use the
same Fibonacci numbers but this time we
are going to use dynamic programming to
solve the problem so let's see that in
action in the previously recursive
operation we had the example that if we
wanted to calculate the the result of
Fibonacci number five then what we would
do first we would calculate the number
of four plus uh Fibonacci number three
same way for four we would calculate the
number phys Fibonacci of 3 plus
Fibonacci of 2 and plus over here we
would do Fibonacci of 2 plus Fibonacci
of 1 same way over here we would do
Fibonacci of 1 plus Fibonacci of 2 and
here we would do Fibonacci of 1 plus
Fibonacci of 0 in order to calculate
this value and in this case we will do
Fibonacci of 1 plus Fibonacci of 0 in
order to calculate this Fibonacci of 2
and Fibonacci of 1 we already know the
value as 1 because this is a base case
now see how many times we are repeating
the same computation over here we are
calculating the value of Fibonacci of 1
plus fibon of 2 in order to generate the
answer same computation we are doing
here as well Plus here we are
calculating Fibonacci of 1 plus
Fibonacci of 0 same way we are doing it
for Fibonacci of 1 and Fibonacci of 0 so
in both the cases rather than doing all
of this computation what we can do is we
can actually create an array and inside
the array we are going to store the
results that we have already calculated
now we know that for our base case it's
fibon of Z so let me mark down the value
0 1 2 3 and four for all of this and let
me make one node for five as well okay
now we all know that the values for 0 is
actually going to be 0er and 1 is going
to be one these two values are already
calculated now let's start Cal start
let's start our recursive function so
first we start with four four and three
now in order to do that we need to
calculate these two values now we need
to calculate this two value so this
would be the first case we would be able
to calculate where we need to calculate
the value for Fibonacci of 2 so we
already know what is Fibonacci of 1 and
Fibonacci of 0o and this is going to be
value number one so we can do that that
we can put Fibonacci of 2 as value
number one okay now for Fibonacci of 2
we need to do Fibonacci of 2 plus
Fibonacci of 1 that is going to give us
the result for Fibonacci of 3 and that
would be value number two okay now we
are done with this portion and this
whole computation now let's do
computation for Fibonacci of 4 so in
order to calculate Fibonacci of 4 we
actually had to do all of these three
calculations but in this case we don't
have to do it why because at Fibonacci
of 4 we need to get the answer of
Fibonacci of 3 which we have already
computed and Fibonacci of 2 which we
have already computed as well so we can
just say that this value is going to be
three and based on that the value of
Fibonacci of five is going to be some of
these two values and we can just mark it
as five so see how storing all of these
values actually saved us lot of time and
imagine that if we were not using
dynamic programming so if we are not
using dynamic programming then the time
complexity would be big go of 2 to the
power n because at every single position
we are doing two more computation and
same way for every single computation we
are doing two more another computation
so that is a very bad time complexity
meanwhile in this approach we can
actually complete this whole transaction
and B go of uh and time only that we are
only traversing and we are only doing
the all the entire transformation just
once and generating the result so that
is pretty quick and pretty efficient
approach and this I showed you the
example of top down approach now let me
show you the same for the same example
bottom up approach now in the bottom up
approach once again let me just draw an
array with all the values I have
currently calculated so 0 1 2 3 and 4
okay and uh the values are going to be 0
and 1 these are my base cases now I'm
trying to calculate the value for
Fibonacci of 2 so Fibonacci of 2 I can
easy easily calculate using these two
values as value number one and in the
bottom up we are actually using the
iterative solution so we are doing it
iteratively okay now same way for the
third value we can do some of these two
value get the answer fourth value once
again do the sum of these two values get
the answer and same way for Fibonacci of
five do the sum of these two values and
get the answer as five and return this
in the answer once again pretty
awesomely and pretty simply we were able
to solve the entire computation now you
must be thinking that this is a very
simple scenario for dynamic programming
and yes this is a very simple scenario
so let me give you a more complex task
and that is actually uh that we need to
calculate the number of coins problem
okay so what does number of coins
problem suggest is that we are given a
value and let's say that this value is
uh currently value number eight okay and
we are given some coins so in this case
let's assume that the coins we are
currently given are 1 and two now we are
told that we can use as many number of
coins as we want in order to reach or
build value number eight but the catch
is that we need to use the minimum
number of coins so in this case the
answer is going to be if we use 4 * 2
Coins we would get the value eight so
the minimum number of coins we need to
use in this case is going to be four but
how do we actually calculate this so for
this let me show you a bottom up
approach and same would be true for the
top down approach as well so I'm just
showing it to you from the bottom of
approach let me just quickly draw an
array where we are going going to store
the value for all the items we are
calculating and initially our case is
going to be zero that if we want to
generate zero value how do we do that so
let's say and for at each position we
are going to calculate the possibility
that what if we use coin with value one
uh what how many number of coins would
we use if we have to use coin number two
how many number of coins would we use
okay so both scenarios we are using and
uh let's mark all of these values so 0 1
2 2 3 4 5 6 uh 7 and 8 okay now for zero
we know that we need to use zero coins
so let's just mark this as zero now if
we have to generate value number one uh
how many number of coins do we need
currently previous results we can't get
much information from because it is uh
for the zero value now we have two coins
available to us the coin if we use coin
number one we can create one within just
one coin okay so that is one option and
and second option is if we use coin
number two but that we cannot use to
generate value one so we have to use one
coin in order to generate value one and
that one coin is going to be the simple
coin one that we use I'm just marking
white color as the the coin we use now
same way in order to generate two what
are the options we have we already know
that currently let's say this coin is
one coin number one so now our aim is to
generate value number two but if we use
one coin number one then we can already
know that if we do 2 - 1 so whatever
value we have stored on top of that if
we just add one more coin over here that
is this coin number one we would be able
to generate this value too you will
understand what I'm trying to say but
let me just write it down for now so in
this case if I use two coins with value
number one then I can generate the value
two so two would be minimum number of
coins we have calculated so far but we
also have the option for coin number two
so if we take for check for coin number
two two is actually the exact value so
if we just use one single coin of value
two we can generate the amount two so in
this case the minimum number of coins we
need to generate is going to be value
number one and the coin we are using is
going to be value number two okay now
let's say that we need to generate value
number three now once again the number
of option we have for the coins is going
to be 1 and two so let's redo the same
calculation again now if we use coin
number one which means if we are let's
say somehow we are at this previous
position two and then we use coin number
one we would be able to generate value
number three quite easily that's a given
fact and we already know that in order
to generate value number two we only
need to use one coin and that is the
true power of dynamic programming that
we are using the value we have already
calculated over here so in this case if
we use coin number one
plus the dynamic programming value of
coin number two and how did we arrive at
this coin number two we did a
subtraction from the current coin we are
trying to calculate that is this coin
number three minus the coin value we are
currently using that is value number one
so we can make a dynamic programming
function that would be that dynamic
programming of let's say this one is
currently value number three is equal to
going to be the so first condition we
have is that we can actually use dynamic
programming of three minus coin that
currently we are using and in this case
coin is 1 so we can say dynamic
programming of 3 minus 1 and if we use
that then we will also have to use the
current coin we have and that coin only
takes one value one coin only adds one
coin to the previous coins so this would
be one consideration and second
consideration would be the next option
with value number two but currently in
both the cases the number of coins are
going to be two so I'm just marking
coins to be two and you have two options
over here you can either pick coin as
one and two or you can pick coins as two
and one in either case you will be
picking two coins in order to generate
value number three and we don't care
about what coins we pick we only care
that what are the minimum number of
coins we need to generate that value now
we are at position number four okay now
let's again apply the same logic to our
dynamic programming function and let's
see that what are the options we have so
So currently we are considering value to
be one so coin we are choosing is one
okay if we and we are trying to
calculate for dynamic programming for
Value number 4 so first option is that
we do 4 Min - 1 so 4 - 1 is going to be
dynamic programming of three dynamic
programming of three is already know
that the minimum value is 2 so that is
going to be 2 + 1 so we have the option
of choosing three coins in order to
generate value number four but we have
another option where we can use coin
number two as well so let's try to do
that so again the second option is that
we do dynamic programming of 4 - 2 + 1
because we are using the the coin with
value two so in this case uh we know
that we need to generate dynamic
programming of two so dynamic
programming of two's result we have
already stored and that is one so second
comparison is that 2 + 1 so these are
the two comparisons we have and we need
to find the minimum value amongst both
of this so this would lead us the value
of d dynamic programming of four or the
number of coins needed to generate value
four so first option is three and second
option is actually uh three as
well sorry second option is actually two
because the value of dynamic programming
of two is actually one so in this case
we are going to mark this as two so
among these two of course two is smaller
so we are going to mark two over here
and the coins we took to generate is
going to be 2 and two same way for for
Value number five what are the options
we have we can if we subtract one value
so then uh if we use coin number one
then we can generate this in three coins
if we subtract or if we use coin number
two then 5 - 3 is going to be 2 so 2 + 1
is also going to be three so we this
three is going to remain constant here
same way in order to generate value
number six if we use coin number one
then we can use 3 + 1 so one option we
have is four second option is that we
can come up up to Value number four and
then use one coin to reach to six and
the value over here is two so we have
two options to choose from that is four
and three so we can actually choose the
value number uh three in this case okay
cool now after calculating this at 7 we
again have two options we can either use
coin number one or coin number two in
either case the answer is going to be
four so we can mark four over here now
at this position number eight we
actually we can actually check that if
we use one coin like coin with value 1
then we need to do dynamic programming
of 7 + 1 so that gives us the result of
five second option is if we use coin
number two then we need to do dynamic
programming of 2 + 1 so uh sorry not
dynamic programming of two dynamic
programming of 6+ 1 so in this case that
is going to give us the result of four
since we we are picking the minimum
value we only need to pick the value S4
and that's it we got the answer that it
takes 4 minutes minimum coins to
generate value number eight if the given
coins are uh 1 and two so you see how
beautifully we we were able to solve
this problem in just one single go
because we were calculating all the
results we have calculated so far and
that is the true power of dynamic
programming in my
opinion so now let's try to do a really
popular lead code problem that has been
asked in tons tons of interviews many
times and you can see how popular It Is
by number of people who have liked this
video
so basically uh you are you are being
asked to climb a staircase now you it
takes end steps to reach to the top you
are given the value of n now we have the
option of either climbing one step at a
time or climbing two steps at a time now
in either case we need to calculate that
how many distinct ways can we climb to
the top now for this problem I'm going
to show you both top down approach and
also bottom of approach and in the code
we will see the solution for the bottom
of approach okay that Mak makes sense so
first let's try to understand the
problem with a few simple statements so
let's say that if you are currently
standing at stair number zero how many
steps does it takes of course zero
that's a given fact let's say now you
currently have one steps available and
you are currently standing at position
zero and you need to get to step number
one how many distinct ways can you get
there of course one distinct way because
you can only take one step let's take
one more example uh currently the number
of steps given are two and you are
standing at step number zero now how
many distinct ways can you get to to
Value number two once again you have the
option to taking one step over here and
then one step over here so that is one
way and second way is you can take two
steps directly to get to Value number
two so there are two distinct ways you
can get to Top Just One Last example
that is for Value number three okay that
let's say that you want to get to the
step number three you are at zero and
you have the option of 1 2 and three so
now how many distinct ways can you go
first distinct way is just taking one
step each time so this would be way
number one second distinct way is that
we take two steps directly and then take
one step so this would be second step
and third step is that we take one step
and then we take two steps directly so
there are three distinct ways to climb
to the top uh for Value number three but
now if you notice some interesting
property the interesting property is we
already know that if we have just one
step we need to climb there are only one
ways we can do it if we want to climb
two steps there are at Max Two Steps we
can do it the moment we wanted to
calculate that how many times what are
the distinct ways we can climb to the
top we don't even have to calculate all
the values why because in order to reach
to three there are only two
possibilities first possibility is that
we start from value number two and then
take one step so that would be one way
and second POS possibility would be that
we start from value number one and then
take two steps basically this would be
second possibility now you must be
asking that hey what if we take one step
to get here still it is still going to
be counted towards this distinct step so
all we care about is that how many
different ways can we get to this value
and how many different ways can we get
to this value some of these two would
allow us to find the next value in our
path and this is the important property
for dynamic programming that we need so
let's try to understand this with an
example that in this case for in order
to climb to step number three we have
two options that we can climb from one
is from Step number two and one is from
Step number one so if we do sum of these
two we can get the value 1 + 2 is equal
to 3 now let's try to understand the
same logic for five steps okay and now
for five steps I'm actually drawing it
on an array uh and starting from value
zero we will go to all the way to five
and see that how each iteration how many
changes it takes for us to to get to the
value number five okay now in this case
uh currently we are using the bottom up
approach we are starting from the bottom
and then we are going up so initially
this takes zero steps this takes one
step and this takes two step that's a
that's a given fact now in order to
climb to step number three we can either
take one jump from here or we can take
one jump directly from here so we are
going to do some of these two so the
answer is going to be three once again
from 3 to 4 it only has two
possibilities one step from here or two
steps directly from here so once again
we are going to do some of these two the
answer is going to be five now in order
to reach to step number five we only
need to do the sum of these two values
and that is eight and eight are the
distinct ways we can reach to Value
number five see how easy it became in if
we if you were to do this in the Brute
Force manner you would actually have to
first create all the different decision
trees you can make starting from
position number zero so zero now you
have uh two options you can either take
one jump and go to position number one
or you can take two jumps and go to
position number two once again you have
two more possibilities you can go to
position number two or position number
three you can once again have two more
possibilities you can go to position
number three or position number four and
once again you have two more
possibilities you can go to position
number five or position number four or
five and here position number five and
the moment you reach to the five you can
consider that to be an end of the path
and just over here you see that these
are this is just one path you can take
in order to reach to Val number five
then this would be a second path this
would be third path and so on and so
forth if you keep on going on you would
be able to find eight distinct paths and
if you were to do it in the Brute Force
manner without using the dynamic
programming the time complexity would
have been 2 to the power of n because at
every single position we have two
different options to choose from and
this is a disastrous result so that is
why you using dynamic programming was
great now you understood that how we use
bottom of approach let me show you the
result for the top down approach as well
where we are going to start from the
very top element and we are going to
come our way down to the very last
element okay so currently the values are
5 4 3 2 1 and zero now we know that if
we are at step number five how many
distinct ways to get there of course
zero because we are already at set step
number five we don't have to calculate
anything if we are at step number four
there is only one distinct way to get to
step number five so we are going to mark
this as one if we are at step number
three there are actually two ways to get
to step number five we can take one step
over here and then one step over here or
we can take one step directly over here
so in this case there are two options
from now on we can apply the same logic
in the reverse order because from Step
number two we only have two options that
we can choose from we can either go
directly to step number three that would
be one distinct way and second distinct
way would be we can directly go to step
number four from there on we already
know that how many different ways it
takes to get to step number five so we
can just use that property so basically
from Step number two we can go to three
distinct ways and that came from some of
these two values same way from value
number one we can actually go to five
distin distinct Ways by taking the sum
of these two values because these are
the only two possible jumps we can make
and from value number zero we again have
eight different ways that we can make
this jump and this is our top down
approach so see in both the sessions we
got the correct answer we used dynamic
programming to calculate the already
calculated result and then we were able
to come up with the appropriate and
successful result in the end so now
let's see the code for this and I hope
you understood what dynamic Pro dynamic
programming is and what are its key
fundamental reasons so this is the
problem statement and here is the Java
code for that uh basically we are using
bottom up op approach so first we are
checking for the edge case that if the
given n is equal to 1 we can simply
return one if that is not the case we
are going to initialize our dynamic
programming array and we are going to
check out or put down the base case
values for uh number of stairs as one
and number of stairs as two after that
we are going to run a for Loop starting
from the step number three all the way
to the end and we are going to apply our
dynamic programming logic which is quite
simple to understand in the end we are
simply going to return the dynamic
programming value be found at the very
end value now let's try to run this code
okay seems like our solution is working
let's submit this code and our code runs
100% faster than all the other Solutions
which is pretty good to see and uh now
you can understand that how simple it is
to code the dynamic programming
solution okay so now let's learn the
sliding window technique this is a
really popular coding technique and
typically works really well with many of
the array and string kind of problems
now first let's try to understand that
what does a sliding window technique
means let me give you an example suppose
I tell you that you have this rope and
currently this rope the entire rope is
actually in the color blue now I ask you
that I want to change this color from
Blue to Pink so how would you do that
well you actually have a couple of
options to do it number one and most
naive approaches that you actually put
down a table now on top of this table
table you lay down your blue colored uh
uh rope and then you start pouring on
the pink color all across the table and
then eventually entire table is now
dripping up with p pink color and some
of that paint has already stuck onto the
Rope as well and now our rope is
actually pink colored so this approach
will give you the correct rope color
that you want but in this process you
would have wasted lot of paint as well
so that is not a very good approach a
better solution might be that suppose
you are given this rope uh I ask you
that hey paint this uh in the pink color
you take a paint brush and now in this
paint brush you apply the color pink for
this portion and after applying whatever
the current width of the paint brushes
you take that width and try to paint
that much area pink for now and once
that is done you again take your
paintbrush replenish it with the pink
color and again repeat the same process
for for the next set of uh remaining uh
rope as well and eventually you would
cover all the ground and eventually the
whole rope would have been painted blue
or sorry pink and that is the most
simple example of what a sliding window
is where in the longest input we had
which was our rope we actually created a
small subset of window that we applied
on one particular portion of given in
input once it achieved our con
conclusion or the thing we wanted to
compute then we took the same thing to
the next area and then we took the same
thing to the next area until we reach to
the very end and we find the appropriate
answer that we were looking for so this
can be a very powerful tool in many
examples and let's try to understand
that with a simple example suppose we
are given an input array a where we are
given some arbitrary random values okay
let's just Mark these values is 1 3 7 uh
2 5 8 and 9 okay these are the values we
are currently given now I ask you that
find me the maximum sum of three
consecutive elements so what you what
would be your approach in this case well
one approach is that you actually start
doing or making every single pair and
try to come up with the solution so in
that case you first take these three
values do it sum then you take these
three values do it sum then you take
these three values do it sum and so on
and so forth and eventually you will
find the result or the second option is
that you actually create a window of
three characters and then keep on
incrementing the sum uh and try to find
that which has the maximum sum so let's
try to use the sliding window technique
in this one so suppose I create an
element called Max sum that is to keep
track of the maximum sum I'm also
creating another variable called current
sum and this is going to be our window
of three elements that we are dealing
with so first let's say that we take
these three elements so now the sum is
current sum is 11 and so far the maximum
sum we have been able to find is also 11
okay now we need to check or move our
window on the on the side but the window
size will remain same so once again we
are creating a new window and that new
window is going to be starting with
value value three okay so let's create
another window now the moment we we
created new window do we need to
calculate the sum of all of these three
values well actually no we have a better
approach and that better approach is
that we can actually take the previous
sum we already had that had current
value what we did essentially in this
one we subtracted one from this window
that we got rid of this value and we
added two in this case so we can simply
do this computation now you must be
wondering that this is only three
elements so why are we even bothering
doing this imagine if this was like 500
elements and this was a very large area
of million characters in that case this
computation would save you so much time
because every time you only have to
subtract one element and add another
element and that's it you will get the
sum of all the consecutive values of
those 500 values you don't have to to do
much work and iterate over all 500
values to find the result so in this
case now this sum is going to be uh 12
so 12 is definitely greater than 11 so
we would update our Max variable that
currently the maximum sum we have found
is going to be 12 okay and we are also
going to update our current sum as well
to Value number 12 once again we got rid
of three and we add value number five in
this case so - 3 + 5 the answer is going
to be 14 once again we update our
maximum variable to Value number 14 and
same way we update our current variable
as well so 14 and 14 and currently we
were looking at this uh pair now let's
subtract seven and add value number
eight so in this case the current sum is
going to be 15 which is also the maximum
sum we have found so far so we would
update that once again let's get rid of
value number two and add value number N9
so in this case the sum is going to be
22 and that is the maximum sum and we
can update that see how easy it became
once we created a simple window and then
we iterated or moved all the way over
there so this is everything you need to
understand about sliding window
technique well sliding window is not
very TP very difficult to comprehend and
let me give you another example okay now
this is one of the most popular problem
on lead code and has been asked in tons
of companies uh basically we are given a
simple string s and we need to find the
longest substring that does not have any
repeating characters so if we see an
example example over here in this case
we have we are given a bunch of long
string but we can see that first a b c
is the longest string that does not have
any repeating characters and its length
is three so we are going to return three
as the answer because apart from that
all the other places actually has
repeating character so the window is not
large enough okay so now let's try to
see that how would we solve this problem
suppose we are given a problem like this
that uh a b a c d a something like this
this okay we are given this as the input
and we are trying to find the longest
substring without repeating characters
so of course we are going to use sliding
window in this on top of that we will
also have to use some additional data
structure to keep track of all the
values we currently have in our existing
window so for that uh hash map or hash
set is actually great so we will use
hash set because we don't need to have
indexing in this place but we only need
to know that what are the elements
currently present inside our existing
window okay so let me just quickly draw
our hash set and now the approach is
that we are going to have two pointers
so first pointer is going to be left
pointer second pointer is going to be
right pointer initially we are going to
keep moving right pointer until the
point where we do not encounter any uh
repeated characters and we would Mark
its length uh as the maximum length we
have been able to find so far the moment
we encounter a repeated character we are
going to take left pointer to move one
step to the right right and then keep on
repeating the same process and meanwhile
we would only move right if the value is
not currently present inside the hash
set if it is present then we would move
the left pointer and uh let's try to see
the solution in action okay so first we
are both are at the same position and we
have our maximum uh substring length
that is currently zero and hash set is
empty okay so now let's see currently a
is not in the hash set so we will add
entry a over here and then move right
pointer to the next element uh now after
doing that now let's see a b are still
distinct B is not added so we would add
B over here as well and move on to the
next element so next element currently
is uh a again so because this is a once
again okay what is the maximum window we
have been able to find so far that was
only two characters so we will Mark two
two over here as the answer now because
we find an identical value we are going
to move our left pointer to the right
the moment we move left pointer to the
right whatever the value we had in the
left pointer we are going to delete this
so first let me get rid of this value
okay now after getting rid of this value
uh we we have our R located over here so
we will have to add an entry a over here
and now currently the window size is
still two now let this R go to next
element so it will go to next element c
c is also unique now let this R go to
next element d d is also unique so it
can still still stay over here now the
next element is once again a a we
already have inside the existing hash
set which means okay so far the maximum
window we have been able to find is of
size four so let's mark four over here
and once again let's try to update the
value so now we are going to move move
our left pointer one step to the right
okay after moving it one step to the
right again remember we haven't added
this a yet because it was a duplicated
entry okay so we added we removed B from
here so we got rid of B from our hash
set once again this value is a and once
again our right pointer is still stuck
over here now this left pointer we got
rid of a okay after getting rid of a now
we can check that whether right pointer
can be added over here or not yes now it
can so we will add a over here and now
uh we will try to move our right pointer
but now it is the end of our list so
this is only of size three this uh
substring without repeated characters
and maximum we have been able to find is
four so four is going to be our answer
and this is what we are going to return
return so now you imagine how we had
like a dynamically changing sliding
window in this example to solve this
problem and we actually use hash set and
tandem to solve this problem now U this
is quite a simple problem so I'm not
going to show the coded solution but I
do have the coded solution available on
the GitHub link and I'm going to post it
in the description so you would be able
to check it out from there if you are
curious ious now let's move on to the
next topic that is called two
pointers okay now let's try to
understand one of the interesting uh
coding pattern that is very similar to
sliding window and that is called two
pointers now this two pointers is
actually really popular with data
structures like array and strings and
the idea is that just like a sliding
window we are going to have two pointers
but these two pointers are typically
going to be located at the edges of Any
Given array and depending on certain
scenarios the pointers would come
towards each other based on the various
scenarios that we have available okay so
this is the whole premise now if you
want to understand this uh with a real
life example you can think about that
let's say that you are currently located
on a Long Beach and inside this Beach uh
you maybe lost something or uh some some
of your maybe cousin or child or someone
so the idea you are going to use is that
you and your wife you both are going to
go to different ends of the beach and
you would try to come towards each other
trying to find the child that whether
that child is maybe located somewhere
and try to consider that beach is just
like a simple line so you are not moving
in any other direction So eventually you
would be able to find the child who is
going to be located somewhere but
essentially you and your wife you are
going to be coming towards each other
and the this is the whole concept of
two- pointer solution so let's try to
understand this with an example okay so
let's try to solve this problem squares
of a sorted array now this is a very
popular problem and also a very simple
explanation yet it explains that how we
can use two pointers to our maximum
Advantage uh basically we are given a
nums array and we are told that this
array is already sorted in an increasing
order now we need to return a new array
that contains square of every single
element but we need to make sure that
this is also in non decreasing or
increasing order so assume that suppose
we are given an input array like this 1
2 and four this array is currently in
increasing order so in the answer we
need to return the square that is also
going to be 1 4 and 16 and this is the
answer we need to return now looking at
this example you must be thinking that
hey this is quite simple all we need to
do is just square of two elements and
then we can simply return it as it is
but it's not as as simple as it is
because we could have an input that
looks like this where the values could
be Min - 8 - 1 0 and then 1 and then two
suppose if this is the array given in
this case the answer has to look
something like this where the first
value is going to be 0o because 0 square
is 0 then 1 square is going to be 1 then
once again - 1 square is also going to
be 1 then 2 square is going to be 4 and
then - 8 square is going to be 16 64 so
see this value came over here this value
came over here this value came over here
so everything got jumbled up because we
had some negative values and yet this
satisfied the property of being in
increasing order and this also became an
increasing order so now how do we deal
with negative numbers in this scenario
so one root force or naive approaches
that whatever input we are given suppose
the values are -4 -2 1 and 3 suppose
this is the input value we are given uh
one simple approach is that we simply do
a square as it is so values like 16 4 1
and 9 and then we do the sort operation
on this array so if we do that we will
again get the correct answer that is 1 4
9 and 16 but this is going to be done in
N log n time so we will try to see that
can we do it faster in just log and uh B
of end time rather than using log andun
function and yes the answer is we can do
it plus you already know because we are
explaining two pointers for sure we are
going to do it using two pointers the
idea is we will have our left pointer
located on the last location we will
have a right pointer located on the
rightmost position and then we are going
to have our answer Square okay now what
we are going to do is it is only
possible that if this value is too
negative it could either end up
somewhere over here here or it could e
if it is positive value then it has to
end up over here there are only two
possibilities so what we are going to do
is at every single location we are going
to compare the value of this with its
right counterart and whichever value is
going to be higher we are going to put
that in the end and whichever value we
put that pointer we would move to the
next element and again repeat the same
procedure so let's see the solution I'm
proposing in ation action so first we'll
compare this left with right and we are
going to do square of both of them so
square of left is going to be 16 and
right square is going to be 9 so again
left is greater because left is greater
first we are going to add value number
16 over here and then we will move our
left pointer and once again repeat the
same exercise so now this time uh left
pointer is located over here okay so now
square of two is going to be four and
square of three is going to be 9 so
because 9 is greater now we are going to
put 9 over here once again we are going
to move left pointer in this case
because we added nine here now this is 1
and this is min -2 so square is going to
be four and this is going to be 1 so
once again next value we have to enter
is going to be four and then we are
going to move our left Point pointer on
the right and then since because left
and right now both are at the same
position we are going to add the one as
the last element over here and return
this as the answer so see how we were
able to generate the entire solution in
just one single pass and this is the
beauty of two pointer approach that
whenever you see solution where you need
to compare both sides of given input
array or string try to think that can
you solve this problem using two
pointers and most likely this could be
one of the possible solution so now let
me give you a quick trick after we have
understood lot of things about array
first thing is whenever you are given an
array try to think that can you sort
this given array to generate some result
second try to think can you use some
some of the hashing function like hash
map or hash set then if not try to S
think can you use a sliding window
technique otherwise try to think can you
use two pointer technique typically
amongst all of these most likely you
would be able to find the answer you are
looking for and this is the key trick
for to solve any array based question in
any of the technical interviews okay so
now we are going to see the solution for
squares of sorted array uh so let's see
first of all we are going to create a
variable called n and that is going to
be the length of given input array then
we are going to create a new array to
store the result we are also going to
initialize two pointers first is going
to be the left pointer second is going
to be the right pointer left pointer is
located on the leftmost position
rightmost right pointer is located on
the rightmost position then we are
running a for Loop in the reverse order
and we are we are going to have a
function that basically takes care of
the Square value and then we are going
to compare the square of the left
element with the right element so
basically what we are doing is uh we are
simply comparing the absolute values of
left element with the absolute values of
right element so we are ignoring the
minus sign and whichever value is
greater we are putting that in the
square and in the end in the result of
that particular I value we are just
storing whatever the square variable we
were able to find either left or right
and then uh in the end we simply return
the result array that we have created
now let's try to run this code okay
seems like our solution is working let's
submit this code and our code runs 100%
faster than all the other Solutions
which is quite awesome so now you got
the idea of how two pointer Solutions
work okay so first let's try to
understand a really interesting coding
pattern that is called fast and slow
pointer now this is most prevalent and
very heavily used in link list kind of
problem so you might think whenever you
are trying to solve some linkless
problem try to think that can you use
this technique in this scenario and
first let's understand that what does a
fast and slow pointer technique is it is
very similar to a two-p pointer
technique but uh in the two pointers
where we have two pointers left and
right coming towards each other in this
scenario we actually have a fast pointer
and a slow pointer both typically starts
from the same position but fast pointer
would would make double jumps so fast
pointer would go to the next to the next
value meanwhile slow pointer would only
make a single jump like a normal uh
typical traversal we do and doing this
would yield us uh some good results in
couple of specific positions so first
let's try to see that how does a typical
concept looks like let me draw a random
uh link list now we are assuming that
this one is a single link list but same
thing would apply for a dou link list as
well and this is the head of the link
list and this is the last element so
this value points to the null value now
in this case the overall idea for the
pattern is that we are going to have two
variables so first one is a fast and
second one is a slow variable okay so
currently let's imagine that both fast
and slow pointers are based at the head
position okay now fast pointer is move
in the Direction Where We are going to
choose the next element for fast is
going to be node do next do next so next
to the next element for any given node
would be the next node for the fast
pointer meanwhile for slow pointer it is
only going to be node do next that is
the regular traversal so during the
first iteration fast node is going to do
node do next do next so fast pointer
would end up over here meanwhile slow
pointer would have end up over here in
the second iteration fast pointer would
end up over here meanwhile slow pointer
would have ended up over here and doing
this now fast pointer is is at the very
last element inside the link list so now
we can use some properties so the
question comes that where does this
technique is actually used so I can give
you two examples right now first example
is that I already showed you previously
in the course where you need to find the
middle of the link list in that case uh
fast and slow pointer is very good use
case to follow that if we want to find
the middle of the link list typically we
can do that and try to consider the same
scenario in this example we are seeing
that right now the fast pointer actually
reached to the end position because fast
do next is equal to null which means
this is the last position around that
time slow pointer is exactly located at
the middle element and which we can see
right over here so whenever we are being
asked that hey go ahead and find the
middle of the link list always try to
use fast and slow pointer because that
would be the quickest method to find the
solution another one solution is that
when you need to detect a cycle inside a
link list and now the question comes
that how can we actually detect a cycle
inside the link list using the fast and
slow pointer so let me give you an
example for that as well now suppose uh
let's assume that we currently have a
bunch of different nodes lying around
and we will try to see that how would a
cycle inside the link list would look
like okay now let's assume that all of
these nodes are connected and in this
case there is a cycle present like this
okay now we don't know initially because
this is a singly link list and we we
have no idea that what are the next
elements so let's assume that if you had
to detect that find that if there is a
cycle in this case or not how would you
detect it uh one basic and naive
approaches that let's say that these are
all the values for this given uh link
list what we can do is we can actually
start iterating the given link list and
we can have another data structure like
a hash set and we can keep checking that
whether this node has been previously
visited or not and if we reach to the
null value we can say that there are no
Cycles in the link list like the next
node is the null node then there are no
Cycles in the link list if the next node
is not null and we encounter some node
that is already present in the hashset
we can say that this node has been
repeated so let's try to run this
example first we will add all of these
values so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and 8 all the
values we would iterate but before that
we would check whether it is present
inside the hash set or not because it's
not present we would add all of this 1
to eight values over here now the moment
we would try to iterate to this value we
would realize that this three has
already been added to to the hash set
which means we encountered a value that
has been added so that's why we can say
that yes there exist a cycle in this
case but now issue with this approach is
that we actually have to use an
additional has set so the space
complexity in this case would be big go
of n which we don't want we want to do
this problem without using the space
complexity so the another approach is to
use fast and slow pointer and let me
show you that how would that look like
the whole solution okay so let's get rid
of this hash set and let's have our fast
and slow pointer ready so initially our
fast pointer would be located over here
and slow pointer would be located over
here now let's make two jumps for the
fast pointer and one jump for the slow
pointer so after which fast pointer is
going to end it up end it up over here
and same way slow pointer is going to
end up over here okay now once again
fast pointer is going to end up over
over here and slow pointer in this
position has ended up over here okay now
let's repeat the same process now fast
pointer would come over here same way
slow pointer would come over here and
let's get rid of the previous two
elements once again fast pointer is
going to make two jumps so fast pointer
would end up over here and in this time
slow pointer would have made one jump so
slow pointer would be here now when fast
pointer makes two jumps it is guarantee
that it is going to encounter slow
pointer in this scenario and the moment
we find out that fast pointer actually
came back to the slow pointer or the
position where slow pointer is we can
say that there is a cycle in this
scenario and we can return true that yes
there exists a cycle so basically this
is the whole concept of fast and slow
pointers so whenever you are trying to
solve some problem related to link list
try to think that hey can I use two
pointers where one pointer is faster
than the other and try to come up with
the solution more than likely you will
be able to find some good answers in
that now let's learn an awesome
technique called backtracking
backtracking is highly popular in lot of
different scenarios and you can
typically use backtracking to solve
problems like dynamic programming
recursion uh tree problems and graph
traversal problems so for all of these
things backtracking is heavily useful so
you can imagine that how popular it is
going to be if you ever wants to
implement these data structures and try
to come up with a solution so first
let's do this we will try to understand
that what backtracking is then we will
try to see that what is some real life
example so I'll probably give you a
couple of real life examples and then we
will try to see how we can navigate
using backtracking in the depth for
search manner so that is how and we are
we will try to navigate it within trees
and graph and on top of that we will see
one of the lead code examples as well
okay so first let's understand that what
does a backtracking is backtracking is
nothing but an ability to go back to the
previous place we were at essentially
let's say that we are following some
certain path and at any given position
we have the option to choose uh some
different paths as well depending on the
CH choices we make so let's assume that
in this scenario we decide to take down
uh and go we initially started with this
and we go down this path this path and
from this moment we decide to go to next
PATH over here and from this we decide
to go to the next PATH over here but we
did not find the answer we were looking
for so what we would do we would come
back again to this node and try to check
a different path once again since we did
not get the answer we would once again
try to get back to this path where we
originally branched out come back to the
same PL same path and then choose a
different option and keep a track that
which path that we have already taken so
that would help us determine or backrack
our actions that's it this is the whole
concept of backtracking if you have to
understand this let's say that you are
currently located inside a garden and
this is like a maze Garden so you don't
know where you are going okay so
typically all the roads are crossed in
weird manner
where some roads don't lead to any other
place and then there are some roads that
leads to different positions in the
garden so what would be the approach you
would take let's say that you typically
started from here what is going to be
the approach you are going to take well
essentially the idea is let's say from
this place you started traversing this
path you would keep on going and realize
that hey there is no path in this case
so of course you are going to backtrack
you are going to come back to the
position where you originally started
once again try to take a different path
and again make some different decisions
so if you go down this path once again
it does not work so you will backtrack
to a previous position where you made
the choice and once again take this New
Path and eventually this New Path might
end up might lead you to the Final
Destination you are trying to get so
this is one example of backtracking so
now let's try to see that how does
backtracking would typically work in a
tree like scenario okay so currently let
me just draw a very simple binary tree
where I have bunch of different uh nodes
and each node had has some children
associated with them and for each one of
them I'm trying to see that what is
going to be the most optimal path or
let's say I'm trying to find this value
x uh this node X so first I go down this
path then once again I go down this path
and by the way I'm using DFS in this
case depth for search which means I'm
going in the depth rather than going in
the breath so I go over here I don't
find anything so I will backtrack once
again from this I know that there is one
option left that I haven't checked once
again in this case I haven't checked the
I didn't find anything so I'll backtrack
once I know that I have exhausted all of
this possibilities I can also go back to
the original root node and once again
repeat the same process and in this case
since I don't find anything I will again
backtrack and okay here I find the X I
was looking for and I can say that yeah
this is the correct path and I can
return that as the answer so this this
would be an example of how uh
backtracking would work in a tree like
data structure and same concept applies
to the graph as well because trees and
graphs are very similar the only
difference is graphs can have Cycles
trees typically don't have cycle so even
in terms of backtracking the same logic
would apply that let's say that you
decide to go to this path and then this
path first but this part does not yield
the result you are looking for once
again you would backtrack and you would
go to a different path and through which
you find the result you are looking for
and you get the correct answer so
backtracking is nothing but the ability
to go back now let's try to understand
backtracking with one of the lead code
examples okay now let's assume that this
is the problem we are trying to solve
binary tree paths now we can see that
this has been relatively popular problem
and the problem statement is actually
quite simple to understand we are simply
given the root of a binary tree and we
need to return all root to leaf paths in
on any order so let's try to understand
this with an example suppose we
currently have a binary tree that looks
like this now in this case let's give
some arbitary values as well uh so the
values are going to be 1 2 3 4 five and
six okay these are the values for each
node so in this case how many different
paths we have from root to node so first
path is that we can go down this this
scenario and this scenario so 1 to 2 to
3 this is a path to leave okay once we
identify and let's create our answer
list where we are going to store all the
results that we are we have been able to
find so far Okay so we found one path
after finding this we will backtrack to
the previous element once again repeat
the same procedure to the remaining path
okay we completed the remaining path and
now this path is 1 2 and four okay once
again back track okay now we exhausted
all the possibilities over here so once
again we are going to backtrack to the
previous element from one we still have
unexplored paths so we will start
exploring and we will keep on going
until we find the leaf node that we are
looking for so in this case okay we find
the leaf node as six and now we will add
one more path that is 1 5 and six and
now we explored all the paths so this
answer list we can return as the answer
and basically that's it okay so this is
the problem statement binary tree paths
and here is the solution basically the
first thing we are going to do is uh we
are going to check for the edge cases
that if the given root element is equal
to null we can simply return the paths
we have if not we have already created a
new link list that contains the list of
all the parts we are going to create now
in order to implement the backtracking
we will have to use stacks and in the
stack we are going to add the current
root node and then we will keep on going
it to iterate all the possibilities
until we find our stack is empty or not
and when we learn more about DFS you
would be able to understand this
technique that how this technique
actually really works and how it is
pretty efficient way to implement the uh
backtracking method for the depth first
search scenario so so now we have our
link lists initialized now first we are
going to add the root element to our
link list and then we are also going to
add a new path to store the integer
value and then we are going to run a
while loop that while the given stack is
not empty we will keep on repeating the
same process and basically this piece of
code does nothing but it only Travers
through the left side of the node or the
right side of the node until we reach to
a point where there no longer exist any
more children for any particular value
and once we get that we would add those
values to the subsequent paths and in
the end we are simply returning the path
so if you didn't understood what I
mentioned I'm going to post the solution
in the GitHub link as well so you can
check it out from there and you should
be able to understand let's try to run
this
code and seems like the solution is
working as expected let's submit this
code and our code runs pretty
efficiently compared to a lot of other
Solutions Plus this is this gives you an
idea that how does a typical uh depth
for search or backtracking works for any
tree or graph related
problems okay now we are going to
understand another interesting pattern
that is called intervals intervals are
nothing but the spaces of time or
sequence in between and we need to do
some work with that or some computation
with that typically in the intervals
type of problem you would always be
given some specific set of time based
connections or intervals like something
like a starting time and ending time
starting time and ending time and then
through this you would try to make some
meaningful information so let's say that
this is the starting and ending time
chunks of the entire day uh between 9:
to 5: and let's say that these are the
meetings that this meeting starts at 10:
and ends at 11: this one starts at 1 and
ends at 2 and this one starts at 4 and
ends at 5 so if this is the information
given if I'm trying to create or
schedule a meeting how would I be able
to do it so what are the empty time
slots available to me so this is an
empty time slot available this is an
empty time slot available so if I want
to schedule a new meeting I can actually
schedule in that and that is the whole
point of intervals typically most of the
times intervals are actually being used
for various set of uh time management or
calendar management type of activities
and trust me this is important because I
personally got asked interval questions
in two of the very big company
interviews I I I actually give so that
is why interviews are intervals are
really simple to understand on top of it
once you know the technique it's
actually quite easy to take care of it
so let's see that what are the different
possible scenarios we can have inside
the interval number one possible
scenario is that we are given the time
schedule for A and B to two different
people now we are being told that uh
this is the time sequence now these are
the times that a currently has a meeting
and for B we are being told that these
are the times B currently has a meeting
so now if I if we want to arrange a
common meeting between them to take
place how can we do that and the idea in
this case would be to create or merge a
new interval common interval this is
just for the example sake I'm telling
you and in this case what we would do is
we would take whichever the starting
point is smaller at first and whichever
the ending point is larger at second so
if there is a conflict between any two
entities that can be resolved quite
easily and we would start creating new
intervals that are combination of both
of them so that would give us the idea
that which are the empty times available
so another interval like is like this
and this one ends with the schedule so
now this is the
common time schedule for A and B which
means we can say that there is only one
empty space available where we can
schedule a new meeting if you want to so
this this would be one of the use cases
second use case would be that let's say
that for a we are actually being told
that a is overbooked with multiple
meetings on many places so which means a
has overlapping meetings throughout his
day and we wants to simplify this
process so what we want to do is uh
whichever meeting is smaller in the
value we want to get rid of it so we
want to get rid of the interval that is
actually causing a conflict between the
existing meetings so in this scenario we
can check that okay currently this
meeting is 2 hour long let's I'm giving
you for an example and this meeting is
only 1 hour long but we do see that
there is a conflict in this case so
because there is a conflict if we want
we can get rid of this meeting entirely
and say that uh now a does not have any
conflicts same way in this case there is
a conflict between this time and of
course this meeting is smaller so we can
also get rid of this one so this would
be a remov of removal of interval kind
of scenario another way to treat this is
that we can actually move this meeting
to the side so let's say if meeting is
like this rather than canceling the
whole meeting what we can do is we can
just get rid of the conflicted part and
we can create another new meeting that
looks like this that okay now a has two
separate meetings even though they are
back to back with each other still they
are not conflicting so this would be
another type of scenario for inter
interval questions and the third type of
scenario would be where we are actually
being told to merge
intervals okay now let's assume that
this is the problem statement given to
us that we need to merge the intervals
and you can see that this is a very well
like problem on lead code basically we
are given an array of intervals where at
any particular position position defines
the starting and ending point for that
particular interval now we need to merge
all the overlapping intervals and return
return an array of nonoverlapping
intervals that cover all the intervals
so here we are given an example if you
want you can take a look at this example
but I actually plotted this example on a
very nice like graph so you you should
be able to see the idea now in this case
we can clearly see that there are four
different intervals given to us but
among these four intervals we see that
these two intervals are non overlapping
they are just as it is now how do we
know that on our side we can just see
them and realize that they are not
overlapping but if you wanted to check
that if any two o intervals overlap or
not all you need to check is the ending
point of the previous element and the
starting point of the next element and
if there is a difference between them
let's say that because this ending point
is smaller than the starting point of
the next one which means we can Define
that there is no overlap between these
two so because there is no overlap we
can keep them as it is we don't need to
do anything now in this case if we see
this is the starting point this is the
ending point same way this is the
starting point and this is the ending
point so starting point of this is one
and ending point of this is three same
way starting point of this new element
is actually two and this uh this
interval is actually six so in this case
we can see that for this interval we do
have another interval Who start starting
point comes before the starting before
the ending point of this previous uh
interval so that is why we detect that
there is an overlap because there is an
overlap what we can simply do in this
scenario is that we would take the
starting point whichever is smaller so
in this case the smaller starting point
is one and then we would take the ending
point whichever is greater so ending
point greater is six so we would create
a new interval called 1 to 6 and then we
would take keep this 8 to 9 interval as
it is and same with this 15 to 18
interval as it is so the new answer
array is going to be this 8 to 10 and
then 15 to 18 and this is the answer we
need to return so basically this becomes
a very simple problem to understand I
don't know why lead code mentions this
as a medium problem in my opinion this
should have been easy all you are doing
is comparing the values between starting
and ending point between any two
subsequent variables and remember in
many scenario to trick you the intervals
that we are originally given in the
original input might not be sorted so if
they are not sorted then in this case
first thing you will have to do is sort
them in the basis of starting time and
once you have the sorted values then
things becomes quite easy and then you
should be able to solve any of the
interval problem so let's quickly see
the Java code for this problem so here
is the problem statement merge intervals
and let's see the Java code for that so
first thing we are doing is we are
actually sorting the given input based
on the starting times and once we have
that things becomes quite easy now we
are just initializing a new link list uh
named answer and then we are iterating
over the original intervals array that
we are given where we are given two
values one for starting point and one is
for ending point where we have all of
these conditions that if the answer is
empty or if it is the last element or
whatnot we are going to add element to
the interval if that is not the case we
will have to do the merge operation
where we are simply going to add the
value of the last element or the maximum
value of the last element compared to
both the intervals and minimum value of
the first interval that comes in the
normal sequence and let's try to run
this
code okay seems like our solution is
working as expected let's submit this
code and our code runs decently
efficiently so this is a very simple
problem to solve once you know that you
have to sort the given intervals based
on the starting
time
now we are going to start with a very
important topic called BFS now if you
don't know what BFS means uh it is short
for breath for search and it is a very
popular tree and graph traversing
traversal
service
so typically whenever we are going to
see any data structure such as tree or a
graph and we need to iterate over either
tree or graph for traversal one of the
very popular technique is is a breath
for search technique and we spoke about
this little bit uh in the previous
sections but now we are going to go into
much more deeper on how what are the
considerations how it works and how to
implement this plus we are going to see
an example of uh an actual live lead
code problem for this problem as well so
we all know that in the breath for
search essenti essentially you are
traversing outwards towards your
subsequent neighbors first before going
out out to their neighbors so at any
given position first you will encounter
all the neighbors of that value then you
will start encountering its neighbors
and until you have done for all the
cases you will not Branch out to the
deeper levels so essentially you are
traversing level by level for all of the
nodes that are currently present inside
your graph so if this is let's say that
this is a graph that you are given now
in this graph first of all you are going
to start at the root position and this
is the root position so first you are
going to visit all four neighbors once
visiting all four neighbors then for
each neighbor you would start visiting
their subsequent neighbors and one only
after you have visited all the
subsequent neighbors then only you would
go to further higher or deeper levels so
let's see some examples of this in both
tree and graph like structures suppose
this is the tree we are given I'm just
drawing a very simple binary tree and
and I'm going to associate some values
to it so let's say that the values are 1
2 3 and 4 5 6 7 these are the values so
if we if we have to apply breath first
search in this scenario basically we are
going to first visit for any root node
we are going to first visit its
neighbors so first of all we are going
to visit node number two and node number
three uh and then we are going to visit
its subsequent nodes that are 4 5 6 and
7 so where this type of solution can be
useful well let's say that at any given
position you want to print out that what
are all the numbers available at any
given level of a tree then you can use
this uh BFS approach or if you are
trying to find some elements and you
expect that element would generally be
closer to the root element also in that
case it would make more sense to use the
BFS approach plus now let's see that how
this would work in a graph like data
structure typically in a graph we have
bunch of different various data
connected with each other
and there are there can be some or many
cycles associated with each one of them
now assume that in this graph this is
currently the root node so in this case
for the BFS basically we will visit all
the neighbors so this is the neighbor
this is the neighbor and this is the
neighbor and also this is the neighbor
and only after visiting all these four
neighbors we would start going to the
deeper levels and that would be visiting
neighbors of these neighbors uh so where
is typically BFS useful for the graph
likee structure is that let's say that
for any particular node you want to know
that how distant it is connected with
some other node so in this scenario we
can consider these two nodes to be
Distance by two because this is directly
connected with this so there is a
distance of one and this is the distance
of two this can easily calculated using
BFS and there are some very real life
practical use cases like uh websites
like LinkedIn or even Facebook you can
actually see that how what is your
common connection between any two people
and for that uh it's quite easy to
implement the graph based bread for
search method to calculate those values
so you can calculate the degree of
distance between each each other
neighbor on top of that even for graph
basically uh BFS is used to search any
element plus Traverse over the entire
graph and if you want to find any
connection between between two end
points you can do that if you have to
visit all the neighbors of any
particular element for any of your
problem solving requirement you can also
use BFS in that scenario and again
remember any problem that you can solve
with BFS you can also solve that with
DFS as well the only difference is
depending on the problem statement
sometimes it would make sense to use the
BFS and many times it would make sense
to use DFS so always make sure that you
are aware that which data structure
approach you are going to choose now
let's see that how BFS gets typically
implemented and usually in order to
implement a BFS we usually use a cube
where we put one value inside the cube
and then we add its children to that
Cube and then we keep on repeating the
process so the output of that CU would
be the breath for search manner
traversal for any given tree or graph
and let me show you an example of a tree
so suppose I'm given a simple tree and
I'm just drawing uh five noes over here
and let me Mark the values as 1 2 3 and
four and 5 so initially we are at this
first position now we are trying to do
the BFS so let me also initialize my Q
as well and in my Q uh we all know the
principle first in first out okay so
first the value I have currently is
value number one so I'm adding one over
here now before processing one I'm going
to add all the children of one I repeat
before processing one I'm going to add
all the children of one so there are two
two childrens's of 1 2 and three so I'm
going to Mark values 2 and three over
here after that and only after adding
all the children I'm going to process
one so let me print out the value one
over here that this node has already
been processed and also let me get rid
of this now the immediate value or the
very first element inside the Q is value
number two so once again before
processing two we are going to add all
of its children so the values are four
and five and then after that we can
process value number two so once again
let me get two out and uh second element
over here would be two now in this case
the next element I have is three now
since we already process all the
children of three or three does not have
any children so we can take three out
then same way after taking three out
four and five also does not have any
children so we will take four out and
then we will take five out and in the
end our que would be entirely empty
because we process all the nodes so we
are going to keep on processing until Q
is not empty and using this approach we
can actually solve the BFS for any given
tree problem same logic applies for the
graph problem as well so you would be
able to understand what I mean now let's
try to consider one example uh and then
we will see the code for that the
example is that we want to find the
average at the uh level for any given
binary tree so the problem statement is
quite simple to understand we are simply
given a binary tree and all the values
we need to find the average at the its
own level now let's give some arbitrary
values so 1 2 3 and 4 5 6 7 and then 8
and 9 so these are the values now what
is the answer going to be currently on
the very first level there is only one
element and its value is one so the
average for this is also going to be one
now for the second element we have two
values 2 + 3 so the average is going to
be uh 5 / 2 so 2.5 so this answer is
going to be 2.5 next over here the
average is going to be uh 4 + 5 is 9 and
9 + 13 so 22 22 divided 4 so I think
it's something like 7 uh sorry
5.5 yeah I think it should be 5.5 so
this average is also going to be
5.5 and now for this one the average is
going to be 8.5 and this is what we need
to calculate so you must must have
understood by the logic of it that we
are going to do the traversal based on
the levels that we are
performing and we are going to have our
Cube and in the cube we are going to
first insert the value number one we are
also going to have a method to calculate
the average and in order to do that we
will need to know that how many children
are currently Pro or how many elements
are there because this is a root element
currently we only have one element so
I'm going to encounter a value called
count and initially the count is only
one for this one I'm going to add its
children so I added children 2 and three
over here because I added two values I
know that for next time when I need to
calculate the average the count is going
to be two okay so now this one this time
using this I can calculate the average
one and I can print one over here same
way uh before processing two and three
I'm going to process its children and
even for the children I'm going to keep
track that how many what was the count
and eventually I should be able to make
all of this continuous a average
calculation because it's a very simple
problem and this is how we can actually
Traverse in the level order for the
given tree and solve this problem quite
easily so now let's see the lead code
solution for this as well this is the
problem we are trying to solve average
levels in the binary tree and here is
the Java code for that first of all we
are given the definition of the tree and
then in the main solution first of all
we create a new list where we are going
to store the result values plus we are
also going to initialize a q where we
are going to store our tree nodes and on
top of that we first add the root
element to our Q now we run our while
loop that while Q is not empty we are
going to keep track of what has been the
long sum plus what has been the count
for every single children we added we
are going to add a temporary node to for
our Cube and we once again for that we
are going to keep track of or add all
the children of it and increase the
value of the count and we are going to
keep on incrementing until the left node
is not equal to null or right node is
not equal to null and uh after
calculating that we are simply going to
run the average function that is Su
multiply by one divided by count and um
uh that's it so we will add those
results into the result list we created
earlier and this is the whole solution
now let's try to run the
code okay seems like our solution is
working as expected let's submit this
code and our code runs pretty fast
pretty efficiently which is awesome so I
hope you understood uh that how things
get easier whenever you need to Traverse
in level order for any graph or any uh
tree you can use BFS quite
easily okay so just like BFS now we are
going to shift our focus on the DFS and
DFS is also a graph and tree traversal
method and in this scenario we are
actually going down into the depth
before going into the breadth so we are
going to pick a path keep on going on
and on in the depth until we reach to
the very last Leaf node on that path and
then only we are going to backtrack our
way to a different possibility and then
keep on repeating the same process so
let's try to see an example suppose this
is a tree that we are given now in the
same example rather than traversing in
into the sequence of breath we are
actually going to go down into the deep
so first we are going to Traverse down
this path then after traversing this we
still have one node that we haven't
process in the reverse order so we will
go and do a backtrack after backtracking
go back over here once again solving
this we would again backtrack and
through here we would complete the
remaining uh path that we haven't taken
and in the end we will return this
solution of all the paths that has been
traveled so this was an a depth for
search for a tree same logic will apply
for a graph based depth for search as
well that let's assume that we have some
complicated graph based algorithm or
many different nodes that are connected
with each other in all sorts of manner
and once again we would try to generate
some graph based solution for this one
as well so let's assume that if this is
our root node initially so we decided to
go in in the depth for each one of them
so first let's say that we pick this
node now this node also has other
neighboring connection node so we are
going to go to its neighbors again this
also has neighbor so again we are going
to go to its neighbors and again this
also has neighbors so we we are going to
go to its neighbors after completing all
of this we are going to do a back trck
to see if we missed any other branches
in the depth this one has no branches
this one also has no branches this one
also has no branches so we come back to
our root node but root node we still
have other nodes that we haven't
traveled so we will go to that node
first before traveling to the other
nodes and every time we are going to do
the backtrack function now we know that
in the breath first search we were using
Cube but actually in the depth for
search we are going to use a stack T to
keep track of of all the nodes that
would help us with the backtrack
function so how would this work I will
just give you an example but first let
me talk about that if you have to do a
tree traversal using DFS you actually
have three different ways to do it now I
already showed you what those ways are
but I'm just giving you the name that is
in order
traversal pre-order traversal and post
order traversal and all of these would
be part of or would be considered a
depth for search traversing
methodology now the question is that
what are some of the benefits of using
the depth first search so first number
one use is that if you are trying to
find the full path between any two
entities so in that case DFS tend to be
more useful second thing is if you're
trying to find some element so again in
that regard as well that you are able to
generate it very easily using DFS uh
same same way let's say that if you are
trying to make some dependency graph and
and this is heavily useful in lot of
scenarios let's say if you are trying to
build a compiler or if you're trying to
build like a schedule prerequisite
dependency course kind of a module for
our University so in all of these
scenarios graph based DFS is going to be
very useful so these are some of the
most critical scenarios wherever you can
think of that from one node in the graph
you need to go to far away to some other
node try try of thinking to use
DFS okay now let's assume that we would
try to do a DFS stack run example for
any given note now initially we are
going to have an empty stack and inside
our empty stack just like BFS method in
the DFS we are going to add the root
node now remember stack has a different
property that is last in first out okay
and we are going to follow some
principles so first okay let me add one
value number one over here now the
principle we are going to follow is the
moment we take one value out from the
stack we would see that how many
children that value has and both of
these children we are going to add to
the stack after that and we are going to
keep on repeating the same process okay
so now currently we have element number
one so we are going to take one out so
if we take one out let me just node
create a method where we are going to
keep track of process node So currently
we have process node number one okay now
we are going to add its children 2 and
three into the stack as well so let me
add this value now once again just like
the same logic we are going to pop value
number two first so let me pop value
number two so we process node number two
but because we process node number two
we are going to add its children into
the node as well so let me add values
five and four over here as well now once
again same logic we are going to pop
value number four first so after popping
value number four we are also going to
add children of four as well that is
value 8 and N so once again even for 8
and 9 we are going to pop them now since
8 and N does not have a children of
Their Own so even if we pop value number
eight and value number nine they are
going to remain as it is because they
don't have any children that we can add
so now we can get rid of 8 and N from
here now next value we have is element
number five again element number five
also does not have any children so we
are going to mark value number five over
here and then we can remove that okay
after that we are only left with value
number three so we will try to pop value
number three out the moment we pop value
number three in this case we will have
to add its children over here so first
let me delete this okay so now currently
we are going to add value number six and
seven here and then we are going to mark
three as presented and then we are going
to pop value number seven out and then
we are going to pop value number six out
so this is going to be the whole flow of
the sequence in which we Traverse
through all the nodes inside the given
tree using the depth first search method
and uh we can see that all the
iterations leads us in the in the graph
sequence so here here first we visit
node number one then we visit node
number two then we visit node number
four then we visit node number 8 so we
go down in depth after visiting eight we
do a back track and we go to the four
and visit the remaining child that is
nine so like this and after visiting
nine we do another backtrack and two we
visit value number five so this is how
the sequencing of death depth for search
is being followed and you can find
plenty of examples of depth for search
in all across places so I hope uh the
concept of BFS and DFS is quite clear to
you now so we can move on to our next
topic okay now we are going to see a
really important algorithm that is
called greedy approach now as the name
suggest in the greedy approach we try to
be greedy in order to generate the
answer and we try to find the solution
on every substep as well in the given uh
algorithm or given problem now before we
start understanding the technical
details of greedy approach let's first
try to understand the local detail of
the how greedy approach typically Works
let's say that you currently have an
empty truck and you are trying to fill
this empty truck with bunch of different
boxes uh that you currently have now in
terms of boxes you have three different
types of boxes first boxes that uh and
remember all three box boxes are
identical in size but they contents are
different so let's assume that the first
box we have this contains all the ion
now second box we have this contains all
the aluminum and the third box we have
this contains all the
feathers now in this case what should be
our approach to fill in the all of these
boxes into the trucks so that we can get
the maximum return out of weight we are
trying to put in of course the approach
is going to be quite simple we are at
every given position or every particular
item we are trying to fill we will try
to maximize the value of these pink
boxes and we will try to see as many
number of uh these boxes we would try to
fit inside the given uh truck before we
run out of them and once let's assume
that we fit all of the iron boxes what
would be our strategy in next case next
case strategy is to fill out the
remaining of remaining portion of the
truck with all the aluminum boxes uh so
doing this method would grant us the
best weight ratio amongst uh inside our
truck and in the end if we have space
then we will try to put the boxes with
feathers in them if not then we would
essentially fill out our entire uh truck
with these two type of boxes so the load
we would be handling the heaviest load
so what we did in this scenario that
let's assume that we consider that
filling one box inside the truck as one
sub problem for the given algorithm or
given step so in every sub problem
amongst all the options we always choose
the best fit option in order to solve
our problem that we are trying to solve
and this is the classical example of a
greedy approach where even during the
each and every suboptimal level we try
to choose the most optimized and best
available option in order to go to the
next next step so now let's see that
what are some of the important
characteristics of a greedy algorithm so
greedy algorithm as I mentioned it is
built on piece by piece by piece and
every single time we are always choosing
the most available and best uh
suited particular option for our graph
in order to build the solution so no
matter if there are how many number of
choices available we are always going to
pick the choice that is the most suited
in order to F fulfill our need now
greedy algorithm also suggest that the
global Optimum or the best results we
can achieve by every single time at
every single sub problem selecting the
best available option so that is one of
the characteristics of the greedy
approach and uh there is also one more
choice or one more uh thing that we have
to understand that is that in order to
optimize or find the optimal solution
for all we need to consider that what
are the overall constraints available to
us because many times the greedy
approach might look okay at the
beginning but it might not be the
correct Choice uh because let me give
you an example for that do you remember
the scenario we were trying to solve
where we had bunch of different coins
and we were trying to make uh any
particular number so let's just say that
we were trying to make value number 11
uh to see that which are the smallest
number of coins we can make or we can
use to to build this property and let's
assume that the available coins to us
are going to be value number one uh then
value number five and then value number
s and we are trying to see that how many
number of coins would it take for us to
generate this value number 11 if we were
to use greedy approach our approach is
going to be that for first sub problem
we are going to choose the coin with the
maximum value So currently the maximum
value is seven okay so after choosing
the 7 once again now the remaining value
we have to create is going to be value
number five because sorry value number
four because 17 minus uh sorry 11 - 77
11 - 7 so 11 - 7 is give us the result
four so now we will have to create value
number four for that we still have three
options but we cannot choose value
number seven because it is too high we
cannot also choose value number five
because that is also too high so the
next option is to choose four different
$1 coin so in this case we are going to
choose 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 so in this case if
you see in total it took us five coins
to build this value number 11 uh and we
use the greedy approach but do you think
this was the most optimal way to solve
this problem no why because we already
have a sub option where we could have
choose coins like 5 + 5 + 1 and this
would have also given us the value
number 11 and even though at every
suboptimal level we did not choose the
most appropriate or most greedy approach
we still found the optimal result in
terms or three coins so you always have
to consider that whenever you are trying
to solve a problem think about it that
will greedy would be the best solution
or could there be a scenario where
rather than using a greedy approach you
can try to think of using a dynamic
programming approach which is what we
did in this scenario so greedy problem
and dynamic programs they go hand in
hand they're very closely correlated
with each other but you will have to
make that decision and you can only
understand that decision after correct
directly figuring out the given input so
this is really important now let's move
on to the next property and let's try to
understand this with an example now the
example is that suppose uh we are given
an we are given a text okay and this
text contains lot of different
characters now we are trying to build an
editor where inside the editor we are
trying to put the encryption of some of
these values so now we need to identify
that which character should be encrypt
so that the that those encrypted values
would be easy to travel over the given
Network and that would consume less
space so let's say that if there is a
character like um
chloroform and there is another
character called the so which character
should I pick in order to uh compress or
in order to encrypt of course at first
glance we would think that chloroform is
is a bigger word so we should put the
chloroform in the encryption but the
idea the better choice would be the why
because the is more likely to appear at
multiple places throughout the document
so if we choose to encrypt this
character it would give us more value so
what should be the greedy approach in
this case to decide that which
characters should be good candidates in
order to uh have
them have them available for the
encryption and one of the best
approaches that what we we can still use
the greedy approach in this case we can
actually create a heap for all the
characters by their
frequencies and frequ frequencies means
I can see that how many times they
appear now we can have the condition
that if any two characters A and B if
they have the same amount of frequency
then we would choose the character with
bigger length so this is our greedy
approach that if the if there are like
let's say that there are 10 10 times
character a appears and 10 times
character the appears in the same
document so the would be our first
choice rather than the character a
because the contains three different
characters so if we encrypt that there
is more value behind it and in the end
we would be able to written uh using the
Heap whatever the top five answers are
those five would be the characters that
are most repeated bigger in size and
also give us the best value for encrypt
encrypting our result so this would be
one of the good example for greedy
approach and basically this sums up most
of the questions we had regarding our
different
algorithms so first of all I would like
to congratulate all of you for making up
until this far I know it was lot of
information to take in but you took it
like like a champ so congratulations on
that now let me give you some of the
popular rule of thumbs and some tips and
tricks that will help you
come to the conclusion faster in an
actual technical interview manner so
first one is whenever you identify any
question that deals with uh hey give me
top closest minimum maximum of K numbers
out of the given total n numbers in that
case of scenario always try to think
that hey can I use a heap in this
scenario because Heap will allow you to
store the values based on their
properties either like maximum values or
minimum values and let's say that I I
ask you that hey out of the given input
data stream give me the fourth maximum
or fourth largest number the approach
would be to generate a heap to store all
of those values and then start popping
out values one by one by one until you
reach to the fourth character and that
would be the answer you are looking for
so always think about that can I use
Heap in these kinds of scenarios and
most likely the answer is going to be
correct with that approach now second
thing is whenever you are given a binary
a sorted array always try to do a b
binary search in that that type of input
because binary search is going to save
you lot of time because binary search
operates on log and time meanwhile the
regular search operates in bigo of end
time so it makes huge difference in
terms of performance now next step is
let's say that whenever you are given or
you are being asked to compute the all
the combinations and permutations of
given various path choices always think
that can I use backtracking or breath
first search in such scenarios uh why
I'm telling you this because
most of the time there would be
possibilities where you need you are
given bunch of different input paths and
you need to pick one correct path and
many times you need to try out different
paths and then come back to some
previous point and then again try
another path so for such kind of
problems backtracking and breath for
search are perfect uh also one more
thing whenever you see any question
related to trees or graphs try to think
about solving them using either breadth
first search or depth first search we
already talked talked in quite detail
that what are the difference between
each one of them and what are under what
circumstances which one to choose but
either ways you would be able to come up
with the solution by using either breath
for search or depth for search because
most likely you are going to Traverse
over the entire tree or entire graph to
find the optimal solution you are
looking for so always trees and graphs
equals to BFS and DFS that's a golden
rule next thing is whatever solution you
try to make if you make a recursive
solution you can all also make the same
solution using iterative approach using
Stacks so many times it would happen
that during an interview you are
discussing you are uh brainstorming you
are coming up with the solution that is
a Rec recursive approach your
interviewer is for sure going to ask you
that hey instead of recursive approach
can I do something else and you you can
say that yeah instead of recursion if
you use uh an iterative approach you can
come up to the solution using Stacks so
that is a very powerful tool and
basically they both achieve same kinds
of uh results on top of it many times if
the recursion is long enough there you
could encounter issues such as like
memory overflow or stack Overflow and
things like that so that can be avoided
if you are going to use the iterative
approach next thing is if any problem
related to array that you can solve
using bigo of n Square time I repeat if
there is any problem using an array that
you can solve in bigo of n Square time
you can solve the same problem using n
log end time if you decide to go with
the Sorting approach and you can solve
the same problem in big off end time if
you decide to go with either hash map or
hash set approach and we already saw
examples of that using two some problem
um and many other array problems so
always arrays and be go of n sare time
complexity try thinking about sorting
the array or try thinking about using a
hash map or hash set in such kind of
scenarios next one is is whenever you
see that you are being asked to optimize
or do the find the minimum or maximum
value amongst all of the given path and
you need to do some sort of optimization
most of the cases you would be able to
come up with a dynamic programming
approach that would be able to do things
in much faster Manner and we saw that
using coin change example where we were
given bunch of different coins and we
were trying to make a particular value
so in that case dynamic programming
allowed us to come up with a much better
approach and much faster approach now
next uh Golden Rule has to deal with uh
searching or manipulating bunch of
different strings now we all know that
try is a data structure very closely
associated with strings and whenever you
are given this kind of scenario try to
think that if there are multiple strings
and I wanted to do many manipulations
can I use a try and more than likely
that would be the correct solution uh so
these are the nine golden rules let me
me give you the 10th one and the 10th
one is actually that whenever you are
given a link list and you are explicitly
told that you should not use any
additional space so IE you should not
use any additional hashmap or hash set
or something like that to store any
extra computation in such scenario try
to think that in the existing link list
can I use a fast and slow pointer method
because that would yield us the correct
result and we I already showed you two
examples of that first example is
finding the middle of the link list
second example was that finding that
whether a link list has a cycle or not
and both are pretty popular and widely
known problems amongst tech tech
interviews so these are the most common
approaches and rule of thumb that should
be in the behind the back of your mind
so always make sure that you are
following upon
them now let's talk about what are the
common pitfalls to avoid because many
times you can do everything right and
still get it wrong during the actual
technical interview and for that it's
not only about your technical knowledge
but it is you need to have a combination
of smart communication skills uh
optimized thinking and also being able
to come up with the solution in the
given limited time management so there
are lot of things so let me tell you
that what are some of the common
pitfalls that you should also avoid
during any of your interviews so number
one is always make sure that you are
well prepared if you're not well
prepared you cannot blame anything on
anyone else because if you are not
prepared and you go to a battle you are
for sure going to lose and missing out
any opportunity for a technical
interview could be a career changing
opport opportunity that you might be
missing out you might be uh saying
goodbye to your favorite job or your
favorite company so please don't do that
always make sure that even if you are an
experienced individual you have like 10
years of experience still go through all
the data structures once go through all
the coding patterns once maybe try to
solve two or three questions amongst
each one of them on the lead lead code
or hacker rank or there are a lot of
resources available because preparation
is half half the battle one so that is
the number one thing I would advise
number two
is always try to listen to your
interviewer first because many times
interviewers are intentionally giving
you a very small and very a complete
subset of the original larger problem St
because they wanted to check that can
you come up with the thinking that hey
what should we do in this kind of
scenario or what should we do in this
other kind of scenario are you asking
the clarifying questions so always try
to understand the problem fully first
before diving deep into start going on
and solving the problem uh because I
have seen and I have personally
experienced this many times that
whenever I hear a question I would get
too excited if I know the answer and I
would try to start building and start
coding and after 5 minutes the
interviewer would be like hey did you
think about this scenario and in those
cases interviewers were actually
expecting me to ask that clarifying
question so always make sure that you do
that number three suggestion would be
always manage your time accordingly
because you are only going to be given
45 to 60 Minutes to complete an
interview and during this 45 to 60
Minutes you need to maybe uh introduce
yourself so 5 minutes go there there
would be 5 minutes in the end uh to ask
any questions you have so you are
essentially your interview time breaks
down to only 50 minutes amongst these 50
minutes you need to understand two
problems you need to come up with the
solution you need to explain the
solution you need to walk through all
the edge cases you need to code the
solution check whether your code has any
errors or not run through run through it
and uh explain the time and space
complexity maybe explain different
approaches and also say that why did you
choose this or why did you choose that
data structure answer those kinds of
questions so there are lot of things
that needs to happen amongst those 50
minutes so make sure that you are not
you are managing your time correctly and
you know that what are the cases you
need to do and you are you need to
prepare for on top of that that brings
us to our next point do not Overlook the
edge cases try to think that what if the
given input does not have any value what
would be the result then what if there
happens to be like a million values for
this particular uh use case or this
particular input how would your solution
approach that is your solution scalable
enough or not are you considering all
the edge cases so so think about those
things and always make sure that you are
taking care of all the happy path plus
edge cases and my next step is do not
write any messy code because many times
you would be solving these problems
either on a page like Google Docs or
maybe if you are in person you would be
solving it on a on an actual physical
whiteboard where your all your thoughts
and your code is all over the place and
you get lost of track and you don't
realize that where where you have
written what and which method or which
class is pointing back towards which
instance or Which object and then it
gets confusing so you that would cost
you your time and also it doesn't look
good on your uh on your personality as a
coder as
well next step is always say what you
are thinking because the interviewer
doesn't like awkward silences it's okay
that you you first ask the permission
that hey uh can I take maybe 30 seconds
or 1 minute to think over this problem
that is uh fine that is acceptable but
if you are just sitting quiet for long
periods of quiet time then those
uncomfortable silences doesn't look good
on your interview and also it sometimes
the interviewer gets the impression that
maybe you don't know the answer or you
are getting confused always say what you
are thinking on top of it always reach
out to interviewer if you are stuck at
anywhere I have seen at lot of places uh
where people don't raise their concerns
and if even if they are stuck they don't
voice that uh where they are stuck and
what are they thinking most of the cases
it is acceptable uh and interviewer also
predicts that that you might get stuck
at some place and they are there to help
you they are it's in their interest that
you get a job because an interviewer has
so many things to do throughout the week
and if they are spending 5 hours just
speaking with five different candidates
it is a major wastage of their time so
they want uh they want to have a good
candidate who have solid understanding
and they would be more than happy to
help you out to reach to that end goal
but in order to do that the precursor is
that you should be able to speak out
loud and always mention that what is
your thought process how are you
processing the problem and what are you
currently thinking what are the
different options are coming that are
coming to your mind so always make sure
that you are voicing your thoughts next
thing is at least be familiar with one
of the programming language it could be
Java python go JavaScript whichever you
choose make sure that you at least have
good command over at least one program
programming language because you at the
end of the day you would still have to
write the code in any language so make
sure that you have good understanding of
different programming languages also
don't become flustered or don't become
frustrated if you make any mistakes
let's say that I ask you a question and
then you started solving and then you
went on the wrong path and you went keep
on going for five minutes before
interviewer corrected you and then now
you just you just feel burdened that I
wasted 5 minutes on top of it I was not
able to come up with the solution and
interviewer had to point me back don't
think about these thoughts have these
thoughts after you done with the
interview during the interview just stay
focused that okay now at least you have
the correct course now let's uh think
about moving forward and reaching to the
end line and finding that correct
optimal solution so that would be the
number one thing that your that should
be your focus and coming up with that is
don't give up even if you don't know the
solution at least try to come up with a
Brute Force approach see that what would
be the most trivial most preliminary
approach you can take and once you have
the Brute Force approach then you can
start building on top of that for that
next block or try to see that why brute
force is not optimal what are the things
it is lacking are we doing a lot of
repeated work can we use something else
um maybe it's an array and we have to
search it all the time in order to find
a value can we use a hash map so things
like this will pop up if you at least
have the basic Brute Force solution so
if you can't find any of the Optimal
Solutions at least start with the brute
force and interviewer would help you
navigate through your thought process as
well so that would look at at least in
better condition that even if you did
not knew the answer you still attempted
and at least went as far as you got so
that that will that can also work in
your
favor next thing is that do not fail to
optimize your solution because many
times you would think you would be
thinking that hey my solution is the
optimal solution and this is the best I
can do but try to think about scenarios
that okay can can I do better in terms
of time complexity U maybe I'm using an
additional space can I reduce that
additional space and improve upon the
space complexity ask these questions to
yourself and also voice their answers in
the interview towards the interviewer
because many times let's say that you
are building a great solution or you are
using Dynamic program pramming and in
order to do that you are actually using
an additional hashmap to store all the
results but as it turns out that you
don't need to store all the results
maybe you just need to store couple of
results so rather than spending
resources on creating an entirely new
hashmap you can actually just have two
variables and those variables can go
through and solve the problem that you
that was needed so these are the
optimizations is what interviewer is
looking for and if you can do that you
would be a great candidate in everyone's
eyes
and the last note I would like to give
you is after our interview is done make
sure that within 24 to 48 hours at least
you are sending a thank you note and
after 3 to 5 days you are at least
asking that hey what is the status on my
application uh maybe they are
interviewing other candidates and they
haven't made the decision but still you
do not want yourself to be uh hiding
behind the scenes and not appear at
least uh connect with them write a nice
thank you email saying that hey thanks
for the giving me the time I really like
the interview process I learned a couple
of new things and whatnot and it it's
always going to look good imagine if you
are an interviewer how would you feel if
the candidate actually sends you a
message and saying that thank you for
giving me your time I find it productive
of course it's going to bring a smile to
your face so think about these things
and uh I wish you best of luck in your
Tech preparation
Journey so now we are at the last piece
of our our entire course and it has been
an incredible journey for me I hope it
has been productive for you as well now
let me give you some of the important
resources that would become quite handy
whenever you are trying to prepare for
your interviews so first resources at
least get a lead code account I'm not
saying that get a lead code premium
account if you have the financial means
for sure if you cannot still at least
get your lead code account in line uh
and there are some other websites like
code Chef hacker rank geek for geeks
they are also quite good so if you want
you can check those out as well but in
either case build the practice of
solving the questions and the tech
interview questions now first confusion
comes in whenever you are you start
grinding lead code is that lead code
actually has more than 2,000 questions
and you are not going to do all of them
so the question comes that where can I
find the curated list of important
questions so I have actually created one
list where I have listed down 125 most
Tas most uh popular and most like
problems from the lead code on top of
that I have also curated the data
associated with that which means that
for any particular question how many
companies have asked this that question
and how popular that is uh also what is
the difficulty level so I'm going to
link that uh Google doc in the
description as well and that is open to
public so anyone can use it that can be
a good starting point if you want there
are other list available as well like
blind 75 or need code 150 they are also
pretty good so if you can you you can
use that resource second resource I
would recommend if you like to read
stuff this is a great book that cracking
the coding interview this has been the
Bible for all the tech interview
preparation so if you can buy the book
if you cannot there are online copies
available as well so you can read those
uh and one last thing is don't stop
practicing and if you can find a
mock interview buddy or group of buddies
or some friends or anyone there are some
online forums available who also
conducts mock interviews because by
doing a mock interview number one you
would alleviate the pressure of actually
being in the interview this would be
like a net practice for your actual
technical interview preparation Journey
uh and if you are playing the role of an
interviewer during the mock interview
with any of your friend you can also
imagine that when your friend responds
how as an interviewer you you are also
considering or you are also thinking
that this is what he's doing right and
this is what he's doing wrong and you
can build a sort of an expectation that
how should I approach any question from
interviewer's point of view and that
would become that would become greatly
advantageous um whenever you are
actually appearing for your interviews
also if you cannot find Solutions there
are very good YouTube channels available
so if you want you can go to my channel
destination Fang or otherwise if you
want you can also go to a channel called
need code he is pretty good uh and there
are channels by hacker rank that is also
pretty good so there are lot of
resources available there is no shortage
of it uh the only thing is you need to
keep on grinding and keep on preparing
yourself now at the very last moment I
just want to take this time and say
thank you thank you to all of you
because of your constant motivation I
was able to build and make this entire
course this is something I never thought
I would be able to do but it has been an
incredible experience so good luck with
your journey and take care